Intro/Outro
Hallo Wolfgang Hallo Stefan wie gehts deiner Lunge. Ich gestehe dass ich ein bisschen mehr rauche jetzt in Quarantäne Zeiten aber es geht ihr noch gut. Dir geht es wahrscheinlich prächtig. Du bist sportlich unterwegs ja.
Was höre ich da. Du brauchst jetzt mehr.
Ein bisschen mehr. Aber es hält sich alles in Grenzen.
Dafür macht man andere Dinge nicht aber an Bewegung mangelt es dann schon dadurch dass man so Alltäglichkeiten ja unterlässt oder sehr stark reduziert hat.
Ich gehe aber jetzt am Rhein spazieren und an manchen Stellen hier am Rhein war ich bestimmt acht neun Jahre nicht mehr weil ich sonst nicht so spazieren gehe sondern eher mit einem Ziel irgendwo hin gehe.
Das sind so die kleinen änderungen des Alltags aber sonst ändert sich gar nicht so viel bei dir wahrscheinlich durch die Kinder mehr.
Ja nicht nur das flanierenden das hat man ja mit Kindern sowieso drin dass man ziellos vor der Tür entscheidet gehen wir nach rechts oder nach links Richtung will man eigentlich.
Und ich konnte auch grad per Twitter die SPIEGEL ONLINE Meldungen mal weiterreichen.
Die Deutschen kehren doch wohl zu ihrem Mobilitäts Alltag zurück.
Datengrundlage ist natürlich wie es bei SPIEGEL ONLINE So ist man weiß es nicht genau worauf sich das hier bezieht aber,
von dem großen Einbruch was Kontakte betrifft minus 40 Prozent im Monatswechsel März April ist man wieder auf minus 20 Prozent hoch.
Da gibt's eine Rückkehr und was die allgemeine Mobilität angeht gilt das Gleiche umgedreht. Das sind krasse Zahlen.
Die Kontakte gingen tatsächlich um bis zu 35 prozentiges Niveau vom vorherigen Durchschnitt zurück also ein krasser Einbruch um zwei Drittel.
Mobilität minus 38 allgemeine Mobilität Handy Bewegung aus gewertet.
Ich könnte mir gut vorstellen dass diese Mobilität jetzt von 40 auf 20 Prozent wieder hochgegangen ist auf ein Minus von 20 Prozent.
So ungefähr ziemlich lokal stattfindet. Ich glaube es gibt jetzt keinen großen Intercity Verkehr Man besucht halt vielleicht doch mal seine Familie.
Aber ich glaube man ist einfach wieder in seinem Lokal wo er dann auch Kontakt hätten wieder einfach nachvollziehbar sind oder auch der lokale lockerer und einfacher zu machen wäre.
Wir müssen jetzt Kiehl runterfahren weil in Garmisch alle durchgedreht sind. War das Beispiel von Christian Lindner.
Die beiden Städte auswählen. Aber ich kann dir andere Sachen vermelden und wir waren ja. Wir haben im Januar angefangen über Fitness-Apps zu sprechen.
Ich habe ja schon vor meiner Uhr erzählt und es ist tatsächlich so dass ich jetzt jeden Morgen über meinen nachgucken.
Ich könnte dir jetzt eine Wasserstandsmeldungen geben über mein Blut Sauerstoffsättigung meine Schlafdauer mein Blutdruck.
Allerdings macht die Uhr nicht alleine.
Erstaunlich wie geruhsame ich morgens aufwache weil ich solche Kennziffern im Blick habe Wenn du mir dann sagst du rauchst während ich weiß dass du solche Uhren nicht trägst weil du nicht mein Smartphone hättest um sie auszulesen.
Da bist du ja völlig außen vor was das angeht.
Ja aber das ist ja auch dann wieder ein entspanntes Leben. Also stellte jetzt vor Ich würde deine Uhr tragen und müsste dann jedes Mal sehen was ich am Abend zuvor wieder angerichtet habe.
So unmittelbar ist ja die Rückmeldung nicht. Man kriegt es dann nicht mehr so langfristig denkt sich Oh nein da nützt auch heute ein guter Tag nichts um da wieder rauszukommen. Na ja.
Gut aber ich sage Ja ich und darüber werden wir noch reden wie wir ja dann doch ein bisschen das risikoreiche Leben und sage Das Risiko gehört auch zum Leben dazu.
Und ich mache auch da in gewisser Weise eine Kosten Nutzen Abwägung.
Also sage ich mir gut das wird für die Lunge nicht besser wenn man raucht.
Andererseits sind das schöne Freuden die man hat.
Erklär mir das mal. Rauchen macht so viel Spaß.
Ich kann es nicht ganz nachvollziehen.
Ich finde schon. Also ich bin ja niemand der rausgeht,
wenn es kalt ist und muss dringend mal eine Zigarette rauchen sondern bei mir ist es eher so dass ich sage,
zu einem Gläschen Wein oder auch zu einer Cola light rauche ich jetzt mal eine Zigarette oder auch in Gesellschaft rauche ich jetzt gemeinsam,
mit anderen eine Zigarette und das genieße ich dann wenngleich ich sagen muss Die Zigarette ist natürlich so die kleine Lust die man da einfach mal befriedigen kann.
Eigentlich lieber sind mir Zigarren und die kann man aber nicht ständig irgendwo rauchen.
Da braucht man ja auch nicht viel dass man raucht mal eine Zigarre alle zwei Wochen oder so.
Und das ist glaube ich auch nicht so schlimm da man sie ja nicht über Lunge raucht.
Ein eigenes Thema in meiner Nachbarschaft und in meinen Lokalen Freundeskreis spielen Zigarren auch eine große Rolle Ich bin immer wieder überrascht Es wird so weit getrieben dass man überlegt welchen kleinen Minibusse man umbaut,
um sich buchen zu lassen für irgendwelche Partys.
Um dann dort hinzufahren. Die Türen zu öffnen und damit gleichzeitig einen großen Zigarren Schrank sozusagen Gelegenheit so ungefähr und man fährt dann einfach zu der Party die das möchte.
Einen Humidor.
Und dann gibt es da Zigarren Verkostungen oder wie auch immer man das dann praktiziert aber man kommt dann sozusagen mit den Zigarren vorbeigefahren. Naja gut.
Man muss ja sagen während wir so darüber reden wie man sich die Lunge ein bisschen kaputter Macht zerfällt gerade die Welt.
Es ist wirklich erstaunlich da wir hier auch einfach nur ein Podcaster Gespräch führen hab ich mir gedacht wir können ja zum Anfang mal einen Podcast Gespräche reinhören die ich,
schon seit einer Weile so ein bisschen höre und wo ich jetzt einen Stimmungswandel feststelle.
Wir hören ja immer aus Deutschland das ist ja das Land der Seligen.
Dramatische Bilder aus Bergamo Wir sind eigentlich gut durchgekommen 10000 intensiv Betten frei das ist natürlich in anderen Gegenden wo man Sprachen spricht die wir im Podcast hören also vor allem der angelsächsischen Bereich ganz anders.
Und wie es plötzlich in mein mir so vertrauten Podcast wo ich denke dass ich,
täglich höher häufiger als meine Eltern und da plötzlich die Stimmung so kippte hat mich doch ein bisschen beeindruckt,
vor allem wie nebenbei ist plötzlich so passiert hier mal ein Beispiel 28 Sekunden Tomorrow Podcast habe ich ja auf vielen Ebenen schon immer mal wieder lobend erwähnt.
Joshua to Polski vor allem und platzt hier plötzlich aus ihm heraus letzte Woche.
Wie andere pièce.
Das Ende der Welt macht. Da wird es mal so ausgesprochen und ich glaube das wird auch retrospektiv dann die Positionen sein die doch viele einnehmen und sagen Hier hat sich dann gezeigt.
Eine Feststellung.
Wer die neue Weltmacht ist wer sich da neu platzieren konnte und dass es dann eben China.
Es ist ja nicht nur die Frage Wie fühlt sich die Krise gerade an und wir kennen die ökonomischen Kenndaten aus Amerika ja jeder Sechste ist arbeitslos und absolut desaströse Verhältnisse in den Krankenhäusern.
Erst heute morgen wieder in New York wo mal die fünf oder sechs Krankenschwestern eine weibliche junge Menschen von denen wir wissen Die werden von covert nicht erreicht werden.
Es kommt auf die statistischen Zahlen aber die typischen jungen Frauen zwischen 25 und 35 gerade im Berufsleben angekommen werden von Covic nicht erreicht statistisch sozusagen Niemandsland für dieses Virus.
Und das wurde jedes Mal auch bebildert wie die Leute ihre Pause verbringen und da sieht man das Trauma kann man jetzt schon in den Gesichtern ablesen und die Zitate in den Text zeigen.
Und diese Menschen machen das ja und manchmal reden sie ein Podcast drüber manchmal nicht.
Ein anderes Beispiel von Burner Das ist so sauer Das ist so eine Wortspielereien mit irgendwas aus den,
Sachen die man gerne mag alkoholisches Getränk oder so wie du dich aus irgendeinem Podcast wo junge Menschen zusammen und sich die eine oder andere Frage stellen Brexit viel zu Labour viel zu sehr. Wie geht man künftig mit Staatsschulden um.
Interessant ist die haben mal eine Folge begonnen habe ich mal den Anfang noch mit reingeholt wo man hört in welcher Stimmungslage sonst auch immer super fröhliche welche Stimmungslage plötzlich so Sendung beginnen.
Berna James Butler.
In Lockl Smoking.
Wird aktuelle Sachen und dann wird diese Frage hier in den Mittelpunkt dieses Podcaster gestellt.
Black Panther MC Highlight,
Pero period.
Kingdom.
Ist England eigentlich noch ein modernes Land. Die Antwort ist irgendwie Nein.
Und jetzt sieht man es vor hat man es immer schon geahnt Bildungssystem Gesundheitssystem und so weiter.
Aber jetzt sieht man es eigentlich. Jetzt wird es so richtig offenbar wie dort regiert wird das der Regierungschef selbst covert 19 bekommt und in diesem Moment niemand weiß wer regiert eigentlich weil nicht mal verfassungsmäßig vorgegeben ist wieder so eine Art,
säkulare Thronfolge aussieht sondern das heißt dann Außenminister.
Teile der Geschäfte. Und man hofft dass es dann doch irgendwie biologisch einfach gut geht.
Es ist schon erstaunlich wie das hier was sich so entwickelt Naja.
Ich wollte nochmal auf unseren kleinen Werbeblock machen für unseren Salon denn mir ist aufgefallen gestern Wir haben eine ganz schön gute Trefferquote Trossen hat er in seinem Podcast.
Das ist schon erstaunlich dass die Studien die wir immer Besprechen von den Servern dann doch irgendwie ein Monat später relativ zügig dann prominent untergebracht werden in diesen Magazinen.
Und ich will mal kurz Januar und Februar als wir quasi noch nicht über Kuroda sprachen ein kurzes Review aus unserem Salar.
Damit auch jeder ist dann überzeugt ist muss ich jetzt auch noch buchen.
Mir reicht dieses nicht denn Du hattest beispielsweise diesen Text über den Flugshow in Meer wo man sich das Fantastische Projekt vornimmt um Kopenhagen zu ziehen.
Und genau diese Art von Grenzziehung die Diskussion ist ja nicht ganz daher.
Aber wenn Containment funktioniert müssen die Grenzen hoch und das werden wir die nächsten zwei drei Jahre Impfstoff. Diese Hoffnung werde ich uns daher noch einmal austreiben.
Dass es da eine große Lösung gibt. Wir werden eine große politische Kontrolle über Kontakte haben müssen und am Ende werden es nicht nur Klimarat sondern sozusagen Coruna Ringe um die Metropolen dieser Welt sein.
Dann haben wir beispielsweise diesen Mega Dominic Cummings Text über Empathie bloß technokratische politische Handeln gemacht genau das was wir in England sehen.
Korrespondierend mit Stable Eugenia ist also kein Buch hat uns so drauf vorbereitet wie das was wir gerade bei Trump live erleben.
Du hast die Texte über den Weltraum gelesen billig Raketen am Fließband und Astronom Entsorger und was haben wir für eine Diskussion gerade.
Elon Musk schickt 12000 Starling Satelliten nach oben und keiner kann mehr durchblicken.
Die Dinger sind so hell dass selbst ihnen Musk auf Twitter gesagt hat Ja ich werde das mal ein bisschen anders neigen zur Sonne.
Mir ist aufgefallen dass wir hier ein bisschen übertreiben. Larry Fink Blackrock Brief wo er darauf hinwies Achtung Achtung.
Klar Klima und so weiter aber es geht ja vor allem darum Unsicherheit aus dem Investitions Markt zu treiben was haben wir jetzt einen ölpreis von minus 37 Dollar und die größte Unsicherheit aller Zeiten.
Wir wissen ja ohnehin nicht ob diese Skifahrers ölgewinnung überhaupt je ökonomisch vernünftig war.
Und jetzt sieht man halt besonders wie unvernünftig das Ganze ist. Und es muss jetzt was die Investitionen anbelangt auf einen Green New Deal hinauslaufen.
Ob das dann wirklich einer ist in dem Sinne wie das viele Aktivisten als grüne Jody verstehen das sei dahingestellt. Aber man wäre ja als Investor vollkommen idiotisch wenn man jetzt sagt da muss ich jetzt weiter dabeibleiben.
Also ich glaube auch dass so psychologisch gesehen ein Zukunfts versprechen her muss jetzt gerade durch diese Desillusionierung die stattgefunden hat gerade auch der Desillusionierung der Globalisierung.
Dass man jetzt wieder neues Zukunfts versprechen braucht und das kann ja nur dort liegen wo wir es nicht mit fossilen Energien zu tun haben.
Der Wandel hin zum klimafreundlichen finden wir alle gut.
Aber es ist vor allem eine Abkehr von den fossilen Ressourcen von denen wir bisher dachten die sind stabil da wissen wir ja Wir buddeln jetzt das Loch und da haben wir 30 Jahre lang jeden Tag drei Schaufeln Kohle und so weiter und genau diese Stabilität steckt nicht mehr drin.
Das haben wir jetzt gesehen bei minus 37 Dollar das ist nicht nur eine hohe Bandbreite sondern da sind auch vor allem Minusbereich die man nun wirklich nicht rein will.
Da wird einen großen Wandel geben und da wird dieser Black Rock Brey von seinem Prinzip her wie wir ihn besprachen noch einmal groß ausschlaggebend sein dann hast du Ernst Jünger gelesen aus Stahlgewitter und haben uns alle gefragt.
Klar das ist jetzt hundert Jahre her und so weiter und wie wird man Opfer wie wird man Held wie im Krieg.
Wie werden diese Rollen neu verteilt und wie hängt das mit Verhalten zusammen und jetzt haben wir es mit einem Virus zu tun bei dem wir uns wirklich fragen wer ist eigentlich gerade Opfer wer es hält und in welchem Maße.
Müssen eigentlich jetzt die jüngeren die älteren beschützen oder in welchem Maße müssten sich die älteren für die Jüngeren opfern.
Ganz interessante Fragen die noch nicht so ganz aber in den kommenden Diskussionen dann doch recht nahe an solche Erfahrungen wie von Jünger oder anderen die dann eben tatsächlich mal eine echte Auseinandersetzung mitgemacht haben.
Richtig körperlich gehen nicht einfach nur Gerede im Fernsehen sondern wo es richtig zuging Da haben wir beispielsweise mal verglichen SPON hat ja mit Bertelsmann.
Publizistisch darauf hingewiesen dass in Deutschland droht die Staatsschuldenquote auf 10 Prozent abzusenken alle fragten sich Was bedeutet das ZAG haben mit 100 Prozent plus weil wir Haushalte brauchen völlig andere.
The World In Twenty die hundert Jahre alte Dinge von.
Denen wir dachten es sind schon krasse Sachen die da drin vorkamen eigentlich läuft doch alles ganz Mulis gerade einen Monat später muss man sagen Na ja läuft gar nichts ganz gediegen sondern hier werden ganz große Fragen an Leute kommt in den Salon.
Da werdet ihr gut vorbereitet auf alle Diskussionen die ansonsten noch so anstehen.
Naja ich würde gerne Mega hart einsteigen.
Was aber wenn uns jetzt nicht gleich überfordern würde ich sagen es doch ein erstes Thema von.
Ich stelle ein erstes Thema vor das mit Coruna zu tun hat aber doch weit darüber hinausgeht und zwar möchte ich mich mit der Gefahr mit dem Risiko,
auseinandersetzen und da gab es einen Anlass zu es gab einen Artikel in der FAZ,
die er jetzt zu Kona Zeiten im Feuilleton wirklich tolle tolle Texte hatte und einer der ist mir besonders aufgefallen Er wurde auch sehr heftig kritisiert auf Twitter und zwar war das ein Text von Stefan Zweifel Stefan Zweifel ist Literaturkritiker.
Er hat in jungen Jahren schon zart übersetzt Er ist ein Experte für französische Literatur.
Und er hat dort einen Text geschrieben der heißt Wir werden alle Chinesen wie die Corona Kriese uns von unseren Utopien entfremdet so sehr dass wir sie vielleicht nicht einmal vermissen werden.
Und man muss jetzt eines dazu sagen wenn man jetzt da Ausschnitte daraus hört.
Wir haben es hier mit einem feuilletonistischen Text zu tun also im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Er ist essayistisch Er ist assoziativ.
Es ist kein Text den ein Mensch kein Gesundheitsminister und auch kein politischer Journalist so schreiben dürfte. Man kann ruhig sagen dürfte.
Aber es ist glaube ich schon statthaft dass der intellektuelle seine Gedanken fließen lässt und dass er Dinge ausspricht die vielleicht ein wenig auch verschrecken irritieren.
Gerade in einer Zeit in der wir so unglaublich vernünftig sein wollen indem wir noch einmal gerade prüfen wie ist das dann jetzt mit der Infektion.
Worauf soll ich noch achten muss ich noch meine Einkäufe desinfizieren bevor ich sie in den Kühlschrank lege. All diese überlegungen.
Da kommt jetzt ein Text und sagt Na ja aber wir haben doch auch mal eine Literatur gehabt und wir hatten mal ein intellektuelles denken das von der Grenzüberschreitung schwärmte.
Das sagte Ja wenn die Gefahr wächst dann wächst die Lust auch und ich habe jetzt schon mal einen Auszug aus diesem wunderbaren Text eingelesen und das hören wir uns jetzt mal an.
Während du das du sagst kann man sich richtig vorstellen mit dem Gefahr wächst die Lust. Sitzt da noch Zigarre rauchend dabei während du diese Texte konsumiert.
Quasi ja.
All die Gründer Figuren der Postmoderne und Vertreter einer erotisch politischen Transgression aller Tabus und Grenzen die den Humanismus der Aufklärung dekonstruiert werden also auf dem Müll der Geschichte entsorgt.
De Sades 120 Tage von Sodom finden nur noch im einsamen Scrollen durch die hundert Twenty Sites auf Penthouses statt.
Auch wenn das Klopapier für die Entsorgung des Sperma knapp wird und Josh Tails Philosophie des Objekten des aus Wurfs und Schlimmes deren Unterform die humanistischen Ideale im Schlamm des Formlosen versinken lässt,
wird mit dem Bannfluch belegt nur noch in die eigene Armbeuge zu husten.
Der Traum einer Regelung aller Sinne im Rausch der Drogen Erotik und Kunst wie ihn 1872 Arthur Rambo im Gründungs Manifest der Moderne eine Zeit in der Hölle einforderte,
gleitet endgültig aus unserem kulturellen Gedächtnis.
Man erinnert sich nicht einmal mehr wehmütig an den dionysischen überschwang an das Ja zum jetzt Augenblick das den Tod bejaht und uns weit über den Horizont eines langen Lebens in Langeweile hinaus heben könnte.
Die Politiker modellieren als Technokraten nur noch den Verlauf der Ansteckung Kurven in Abhängigkeit der freien Spitalsbetten.
Freilich scheint es schwierig angesichts des Schreckbild es wie die eigene Mutter oder man selbst vor den Türen überfüllter Spitäler zurückgewiesen wird.
Und angesichts der sich aufopfernden ärzte und Pfleger die ihr Leben für uns alle aufs Spiel setzen.
Solche dionysischen Gedanken wollten zu verteidigen.
Der Blick nach Bergamo und in die Spitäler von New York lässt das nur noch als frivol erscheinen.
In der engen Gasse neben meiner Wohnung versuchte eine Schweizerin fast schon verzweifelt einer Gruppe von drei Chinesinnen auszuweichen und flüchtete in einen Hauseingang.
Dabei trug sie das chinesische Diktat bereits in ihrem eigenen Kopf,
Gesichtsmasken auf den Straßen werden unsere Gesichtszüge genauso ent individualisieren,
wie die Helme auf den Fahrrädern und den Skipisten wo wir einst nur über Buckelpisten fuhren um am Skilift im richtigen Moment neben einer Frau mit wehendem Haar zu stehen.
Dass sie jetzt unter einem Helm versteckt der sie von einem Mann ununterscheidbar macht im Versuch unser nacktes Leben zu retten verbergen wir jegliche Nacktheit.
Zweischneidig würde ich sagen denn ganz heruntergebrochen auf fast Verbraucher journalistische Anmerkungen die ich jetzt mache was das Verhalten angeht bin ich einverstanden. Sehe ich sozusagen.
Ja ja.
Also kann ich gut nachvollziehen werden ja auch gestern im Podcast mit Hans H. Das gipfelte dann in der Frage Wollen wir jetzt auch Autofahren verbieten weil es ansonsten 3000 Tote gibt. Aber wir wissen nicht genau wo fallen sie denn an und so weiter.
Klar aber bei dem Umgang mit dem eigenen Körper über Masken und Helme gesprochen da würde ich sagen Das haben wir beim letzten Mal auch schon so ein bisschen prognostiziert.
Bei Masken wird sich schneller Design und Selbstverwirklichung sichtbar durchsetzen als alle tragen die gleiche asiatische Fließ Maske die man eigentlich tragen sollte weil die gibt's einfach nicht.
Ich finde wenn wir jetzt auf Twitter Instagram anguckt wie die Leute ihre Masken präsentieren das sind schon sehr ausgefallene Sachen. Da würde ich schon sagen Da steckt sehr viel Individualisierung drin.
Da würde ich diesem Text widersprechen. Ansonsten finde ich es total angemessen jetzt auch in dieser Sprache zu schreiben.
Oder es ist doch wirklich einmal wohltuend das so zu tun.
Und vor allem glaube ich dass es dann auch so ein Twitter-App Problem ist dass man dort so ein Nebeneinander von Texten und von Positionen hat.
Aber man kann nicht wie man das bei der Zeitungslektüre tut sagen Okay das eine findet jetzt gerade im Politikteil statt.
Also stellen wir uns vor es würde Karl Lauterbach einen solchen Text veröffentlichen Man würde sagen ja ist der Mann noch bei Trost.
Aber in der Zeitung kennen wir okay das ist gerade im Feuilleton geschehen das ist vielleicht auch noch mit irgendeinem Porträt von Partei oder Fukui bebildert.
Und dann denken wir darüber nach und das war aber auch schon eine Erfahrung die ich immer an der Universität gemacht hatte die Professoren liebten Foucault liebten die Grenzüberschreitung wo es dann wirklich.
Ein Liebäugeln mit dem Tode gab und schreiben dann bei Foucault dass sich ja in die Körperöffnungen geradezu hinein bohrt.
Sobald man aber selbst auch nur im geringsten eine solche Position vertrat oder versuchte in eine solche Richtung auch zu schreiben dann sagte man nee nee.
Wir müssen jetzt aber mal hier. Es gibt ja wissenschaftliche Standards und das finde ich aber auch sehr problematisch so etwas einzusehen also das Dionysische dieses,
Böse Denken das man bei Sartre schon finden kann in ganz extremen Maße was sich aber dann wirklich durch die französische Literatur des 19. und 20. Jahrhunderts zieht.
Das ist heute was was man eigentlich gar nicht mehr haben möchte sagt man Ja das ist aber unmöglich so jemand wie Michel Houellebecq.
Ja ich meine ich würde sogar noch strapazieren. Nicht nur das Böse Denken ist gerade sehr schwer sondern überhaupt differenziert zu denken wenn man auf Twitter mit einem Tweet versucht in dem das Wort Grippe auch nur vorkommt,
kriegt man tausend Pleiß.
Die Frage ist nur darauf abzielen dass man doch diesen Vergleich zwischen Coruna und Grippe nochmal möglichst so wiederholt dass danach die Empörung aber auch richtig losgehen kann.
Und genau dies nenne ich lese jetzt diesen Filter und Text erstmal bis zur letzten Zeile zu Ende und danach hole ich mir die Gegenmeinung von Seite 7.
Diese minimale etwas langsamere Lektüre langsameres denken im Vergleich zu diesem schnellen Denken findet gerade gar nicht statt.
Damit kann man allerdings auch sehr spielen finde ich denn so eindeutig wie das der Lauterbach eben schon genannt.
Lauterbach dominiert die Debatte gerade in beeindruckendem Maße.
Man sieht aber schon dass es nicht mehr lange durchhalten wird denn es gibt auch die ganzen Klinikdirektor vom Uca Hamburg z.B.
Die ganz bewusst sagen und wie man das Herma als Auto allein um so eine Debatte schon einmal vor zu sein wie sie die nächsten Monate kommt.
Aber die Leute die den Klinikalltag mitmachen die sagen jetzt ganz bewusst und zwar auch vor Journalisten ist dokumentiert.
Wir brauchen Herden Immunität und dann ist natürlich alles schon getriggert.
Das ist doch das was in Schweden und England nicht gelang und dann sagen die ja das mit der Impfung ist natürlich auch Herden Immunität nur eine künstliche.
Und jetzt ist die Frage Schaffen wir es mit der künstlichen Immunität also Wir warten auf den Impfstoff überzeugen dann auch alle hoffen dann auch dass nach den ersten 200 000 Impfungen keine großen Nebenfolgen auftauchen sodass das Vertrauen in diesen Impfstoff bleibt.
Kann man das als ernsthafte Alternative der natürlichen Immunität nämlich Wir öffnen alle Schulen und Kindergärten.
Es ist nicht meine Meinung meine Meinung aber dass es reproduziert.
In Hamburg öffnen wir jetzt alle Schulen im Kindergarten und machen eine kontrollierte Durchleuchtung derjenigen von denen wir wissen,
Die haben so wenig mit Cove zu tun die Kinder selbst den Impfstoff der in eins zu einer Million fehlschlägt und krasse Nebenwirkungen hat.
Wer noch mehr als covert bei diesen Kindern verursachen würde weil diese Zahl haben wir mittlerweile die Fallzahlen für so ein Argument sind hoch genug.
Es gibt keine große Kinder. Betroffenheit von covert.
Solche Diskussionen werden natürlich kommen weil da hat Markus Preiß der in Brüssel als ARD-Korrespondent ein bisschen härteren locker und gerade erlebt hat das gestern mal durchgerechnet.
Wenn das jetzt also wenn sich jetzt alle dran halten wie es die letzten zwei Monate ja angeblich so erfolgreich war dann hieße das Wir müssten das nur noch 382 mal so lange machen 382 mal zwei Monate sind 63 Jahre und die Frage ist.
Welche Perspektive rechnen wir jetzt gegen welche auf und.
Meine Frisur dann aussehen.
Wie wird deine Frisur dann aussehen.
Und man muss sagen bisher die ersten zwei Monate das war eine politische Notmaßnahme die war völlig alternativlos.
Aber jetzt muss die Politik zurückkommen weil 63 Jahre Notmaßnahme in diesem Amt wie wir es jetzt gemacht haben.
Das ist völlig ausgeschlossen das kann man auch einfach so sagen.
Das ist einleuchtend.
Was bisher so alternativlos war ist langfristig keine Alternative. Und die Diskussion wird kommen.
Aber das ist schon das du das ansprichst denn es zeigt sich darin ja vor allem auch dass sich eben unser Verhältnis zum Risiko zur Gefahr sehr verändert hat dass wir zum einen zwar bereit sind,
vielleicht irgendwelche Extremsportarten zu machen dass wir aber zugleich möglichst vernünftig sein wollen dass wir eben sagen Na ja wenn wir nur diese Kurve flach halten können solange es irgendwie geht.
Und deswegen will ich nochmal ein bisschen bei Zweifel weitergehen.
Nicht dass ich Ihnen jetzt weiter zitieren möchte sondern ich möchte zum Beispiel mal einen zu Wort kommen lassen den er da auch zitiert nämlich Jobbik-Partei Großpartei hat sich sehr mit der Erotik beschäftigt er hat pornografische Werke geschrieben im 20.
Jahrhundert und wir hören jetzt aber mal einen Auszug aus seinem Essay Der heilige Eros.
Was die äußere Gewalttätigkeit der Opfer Handlung aufdeckte war die innere Gewaltsamkeit des Seins gesehen im Licht des ausströmenden Blutes und der hervor quälenden Organe.
Der Liebesakt und das Opfer decken beide dasselbe auf. Das Fleisch das Opfer lässt an die Stelle der geordneten Funktion des Lebewesens das blinde Zucken der Organe treten.
Dasselbe gilt für die erotische Konvulsionen. Sie befreit die Blut gefüllten Organe deren blindes Spiel sich über das überlegte wollen der Liebenden hinaus fortsetzt.
Das ist nicht Till Lindemann.
Das ist nicht Till Lindemann. Partei und Partei hatte solche Fantasien und hat sie dann auch,
literarisch sehr galant ausbuchstabiert wie das eigentlich ist ist nicht eigentlich der Sex auch immer mit einem Wunsch verbunden.
Man hat ja beim Orgasmus sowieso diese Rede vom kleinen Tod und das ist eben eine Literatur die sich da sehr weit hinaus wagt bei der wir aber sagen,
Gut literarisch ist das ja alles schön und gut aber wie ist dann eigentlich unser Umgang damit.
Ist das jetzt die exzentrische Position eines Künstlers die er da einnimmt die wir dann wir die Bürgerlichen die Vernünftigen aus der Distanz beobachten.
Oder ist das auch ein Lebensmodell und wird das daraus resultiert wahrscheinlich dann auch diese Kritik an dem Text von Zweifel.
Wird das problematisch wenn man irgendwie daraus auch Lebens.
Maximen ableitet wer dann noch ein bisschen weitergegangen ist.
Ist Michel Houellebecq insofern als er Bezug nimmt auf eine große Gefahr Die als dieser Text 1996 entstand besonders akut war und dass er aber auch da,
ein bisschen mit dieser bösen Lust spielt die den Franzosen doch sehr zu eigen ist Wir hören da mal rein.
Johann Sebastian Bachs Kantaten habe ich nie gelten lassen können.
Allzu perfekt ist in ihnen die Aufteilung zwischen Stille und Geräusch.
Ich brauche Geschrei ätzen des Magmas Angriffslust die die nächtliche Stille zerreißen kann.
Unsere Generation hat offenbar das Geheimnis einer vollendet durch rhythmisierten und daher vollendet langweiligen Musik wiederentdeckt,
zwischen Musik und Leben ist es nur ein Schritt pro Kopf bezahlt im Dienste der Menschheit reiße ich eines nach dem anderen meine lyrischen Streichhölzer an.
Zum Glück hält Aids wacht.
Ja das ist ein Gedicht von Michel Houellebecq. Erschienen ist dieser Band der Sinn des Kampfes 1996.
Man muss sagen dass es unter französischen Schriftstellern damals durchaus eine Debatte gab um den Umgang mit Aids wie man eigentlich das literarisch verwertet und ob man nicht,
an dieser Position bleibt dass Sex gefahren voll ist es gab beispielsweise den Aids-Kranken schwulen Schriftsteller.
Dystonie der auch ein paar Jahre später gestorben ist der ein Verfechter von Bernburg Sex war.
Von Sex ohne Kondom weil er sagte das gehört zur Gewalt zum Sex dazu die Gefahr.
Und wir merken aber dass uns das sofort nicht mehr so sympathisch ist wie wenn das einfach nur in einem 19.Jahrhundert Text mal so als Fantasie beschrieben wird.
Denn ist eine reale Gefahr da also ist da beispielsweise ein Virus das AIDS auslöst oder eben jetzt covert 19.
Dann gehen wir zu Literatur auf Distanz und wir können dann nicht sagen na ja aber ich würde sagen die meisten können es nicht und es ist wahrscheinlich auch sehr vernünftig es nichts zu tun.
Aber doch würde ich immer wieder dafür plädieren dass vielleicht dann im literarischen Raum diese Fenster und Türen offen bleiben dürfen in denen diese Gedanken erlaubt sind.
Denn zugleich brauchen wir glaube ich auch in irgendeiner Weise Transgression Fantasien.
Allerdings kann man kritisch anmerken Wir sind ja doch in einer Moderne irgendwie Gewissen angekommen.
Sexualität spielt sich ja nicht nur körperlich ab hier wird ja sehr auf die Körperlichkeit ist ja auch eine sozusagen geistige Sache seelisch mit Vollzug. Alles zum Thema Liebe und so weiter.
Und Eva Illouz hat es ja in ihren mehreren Büchern zur Liebe jetzt mal so dargestellt dass er immer so eine Verletzlichkeit mitkommt.
Man investiert sich mit seiner ganzen Persönlichkeit in einen Flirt in der Hoffnung dass er gut ausgeht und wenn er nicht gut ausgeht dann ist nicht nur ein Gespräch gescheitert nicht nur eine Interaktion sondern dann geht man irgendwie doch geknickt nach Hause.
Man fühlt sich dann doch in gewisser Art missachtet als Person.
So jetzt kann man natürlich das sehe ich bei Till Lindemann der hatte genau dieses Thema seit 25 Jahren Liebe aber nicht unter diesem romantischen tollen Sachen sondern mal aus einer anderen Richtung betrachtet.
Was ist wenn es schief geht oder was ist wenn die Gewalt dann doch überhand nimmt.
Wenn leidenschaftslosen ins Gewaltsame stößt und man feststellt Ich bin lieber.
Lieber bin ich so egoistisch und lasse die Gewalt durchkomme als dass ich jetzt diesen Liebes Bogen zwei teilen sich einwählt Entwurf also genau das abzuwenden.
Man könnte schon so ein Argument machen würde ich sagen dass wir in dieser modernen Zivilisation eigentlich angekommen sind.
Zu sagen sowohl die geistige als auch die körperliche Liebe die findet.
Geistig statt. Die lebt sich nicht mehr in Brutalität aus sondern die der Sex ist eigentlich Ergänzung zur geistig schon,
gegenseitig abgesprochenen und vereinbarten Liebesbeziehung die sozusagen auf Dauer gestellt sein soll und nicht wie Lindemann tatsächlich singt.
Alles was ich liebe muss sterben weil ich genau weiß irgendwann übermannt mich die Leidenschaft also bringe ich lieber alles sofort um was mir jetzt schon zeigt. Das könnte dich ja verwirren.
Meine zehnjährige Tochter ist immer ganz verwundert wenn Lindemann Sie singt.
Was ich liebe das muss sterben was ich liebe soll verderben.
Lindemann bricht dann in diesem Text so um und sagt Ich mache es.
Bevor mir etwas passiert weil mir jemand meinen Liebenden nimmt den ich liebe lieber selbst weil dann habe ich es zumindest noch unter Kontrolle.
Zumindest in geweihter noch auf meiner Seite.
Da würde ich sagen das ist halt wirklich Spielerei aber man hat jetzt auch wieder.
Spielerei die man sich in einer sehr zivilisierten Welt auch mal leisten kann die dann immer eine besondere Ernsthaftigkeit bekommt wenn wir es jetzt mit realen Fällen zu tun haben.
Denken wir an die Fälle oder jetzt auch diese Spielereien mit den klaffenden Organen und auch dem infektiösen von Sex.
Dass das eine literarische Spielerei wird die dann ziemlich ernst umzuschlagen droht wenn wir es dann mit realen Infektionen zu tun haben.
Und doch gibt es ja so eine Lust an der Gefahr auch die ist nicht ganz passé.
Nicht umsonst machen Leute lauter Extremsportarten oder bestellen irgendwelche Erlebnisse Gutscheine bei Jochen Schweizer auch wenn das jetzt gerade nicht so möglich ist.
Und das ist aber auch so ein Thema in der Literatur Du hast ja Ernst Jünger schon angesprochen Auch er diagnostizierte eigentlich schon eine moderne Welt in der das heldenhafter das Abenteuer kaum noch möglich ist und dann,
kommt der Erste Weltkrieg und der Erste Weltkrieg verspricht noch einmal das große Abenteuer zu sein.
Und Du erinnerst Dich vielleicht an das Buch 7 Nächte von Simon Strauß der ja F.A.Z.
Redakteur ist Theaterkritiker. Und der hat ein Buch geschrieben in dem er auch sich mit der Gefahr auseinandersetzt und eigentlich sich in diesen sieben Nächten noch einmal überreden will etwas Unvernünftiges zu tun.
Wenngleich man sagen muss Es ist dann nicht so unvernünftig wie das was Zartbitter so schildert sondern es ist oft nur das blutige Staake das man jetzt einmal essen geht es ist gar nicht so viel mehr was heute als Gefahren voll.
Anerkannt wird oder was.
Oder es reicht heute schon wenig um wirklich vom gefãhrt zu sprechen.
Gerade in den Anfängen ganz kurz rein.
Ich der ich von Anfang an dicht bei der warmen Heizung gesessen habe immer schon satt gefüttert mit allen Chancen versehen das Opernabend gleich bei der Geburt abgeschlossen.
Ich bin schon als Schwächling auf die Welt gekommen und meine Privilegien haben mich nun noch weiter geschwächt. Was Gefahr heißt habe ich nie gespürt nie geahnt dass Wege auch nach unten ins Abseits führen können.
Ich bin gefangen in einer Blase aus Glück gekämpft habe ich für wenig Tischtennisplatten. In der Pause gab es immer genug. Und als ich 18 war wurde der Wehrdienst abgeschafft.
Es ist wirklich bezeichnend wie,
deutlich der Wunsch ist und gleichzeitig aber bei ihm,
sehr vorsichtig da völlig klar ist Es ist eine Spielerei die bleibt zwischen zwei Buchdeckeln.
Und da gibt es auch viel Kritik an Till Lindemann im Sinne von jetzt wieder so ein Gedichtband vorgelegt.
Das ist zu brutal das zu frauenverachtend und so weiter.
Aber es wird dabei übersehen dass es zwischen zwei Buchdeckeln bleibt.
Till Lindemann ist kein Massenmörder der rumrennen macht sondern er bietet sozusagen dieses Denken an.
Und wir wissen warum die Krimis in Deutschland im Fernsehen so erfolgreich sind weil man das was man in seinem Alltag niemals erlebt und auch nicht erwartet.
Trotzdem sehen möchte und umso größer die Distanz ist zwischen dem was man selber im Alltag erlebt und das was man im Fernsehen dann sieht aber eben zwischen zwei Buchdeckeln zwischen einem Vorspann und einem Abspann.
Umso größer diese Distanz ist um umso mehr sollte man eigentlich darüber zufrieden sein dass diese Distanz so groß ist.
Das heißt aber auch der Wunsch danach das ist richtig brutal zugeht.
Der ist dann auch da auch Oma Erna nicht davor gefeit dass sie sich natürlich nochmal insbesondere für diese skandinavischen Krimis interessiert.
Und wir hatten auf der Buchmesse die kleine Szene da war Jenny hier ein Buch für ihre Mutter noch mitgenommen und wollte unbedingt ein Autogramm von diesem Autor und dieses Buch hieß Messer,
und der Typ saß dann vorne auf der Bühne und es war eine riesen Traube an Frauen zwischen 25 und 55 und er saß dann vorne wurde gefragt Warum heißt ein Buchmesse und er meinte,
ja Messer habe ich das genannt weil ich irgendwie mit der Idee spielen wollte dass man bei einem Messer besonders nah ran muss.
Sieht man dem Opfer noch einmal in die Augen und hyper dramatisiert diese Brutalität.
Das Publikum fiel aus allen Wolken wenn man das sah.
85 Prozent Frauen und 100 Prozent in der Altersklasse 25 bis 55 die diese Gewalt wirklich nie so selber erleben und wenn doch mal,
in der Regel Ausbruch da passiert und man sagt Das ist ein Einzelfall dann hat man es aber auch wirklich auf allen Titelblättern.
Ist das nicht irgendwie so unter den Teppich gekehrt sondern es findet eigentlich nicht.
Und diese Diskrepanz finde ich immer wahnsinnig interessant gerade wenn dann wieder so ein Shitstorm gegen Till Lindemann losgeht obwohl das eigentlich der Beweis ist wie weit wir schon in der modernen Zivilisation angekommen sind da regt man sich dann darüber wieder auf völlig zu Unrecht.
Das hat ja auch bei den Rammstein Konzerten fast schon reinigende Effekt kann man sagen Man erlebt dort noch einmal den Exzess wird gespielt mit archaischen Symbolen mit all dem.
Und man schwitzt und schreit und tanzt zusammen und dann ist aber auch wieder damit zugleich so eine Kanalisierung dieser Emotionen hergestellt.
Das bleibt also auf dem Festivalgelände bleibt in der Konzerthalle,
zurück und dann gehen alle wieder zurück zu ihrem Auto Zentralverriegelung fahren mit dem Kleinwagen nach Hause aber nicht so schnell weil man nicht mehr als 5,5 Liter verbrauchen will.
Und jetzt guckt man mal ob man noch ein Getränk zu sich nimmt. Es ist ja ungeheuer brav.
Das ist aber auch das generelle zivilisatorische Erlebnis das wir laufend haben.
Ich gehe ja auch aus dem Kino raus sehe einen Film mit Sylvester Stallone der es nochmal ordentlich krachen lässt.
Und dann steige ich auch in meinen Peugeot ein und fahr in meine kleine Welt zurück.
Dass wir jetzt über Jahre diese Erfahrung im Stadion nicht machen können. Rammstein Konzerte Fußball und so weiter.
Das werden noch viele merken es wird Effekte haben dass diese Art von Kompensation wo man ganz kontrolliert in so ein Stadion geht.
Man hat einen zugewiesenen Platz und dann wird es laut. Der Bass kommt Rammstein hat ja nicht nur auf der Bühne Feuer sondern mir auch noch so Türme mit Live-Show wo das ganze Stadion rundherum anzünden und.
Das fällt jetzt alles raus. Da bin ich immer sehr gespannt weil ich bin auch ich hänge dieser These sehr an das zweiStunden Rammstein Konzert können was gewisse Bedürfnisse angeht so ein Puffer für ein Jahr aufladen.
Sehr schön.
Irgendwann ist halt zu viel Corona Quarantäne zu viel.
Aber blicken wir zum Schluss um das Thema wie Infektionen denn Sex sein darf nochmal in die Zukunft um das abzuschließen. Und zwar mit Ray Kurzweil.
Der hat in den 90er Jahren ein Buch geschrieben Die Intelligenz der Evolution und da malt er auch schon den Sex der Zukunft auf er hat sich ein bisschen vertan ein bisschen früh dran denn wir können jetzt heute sehen.
Ganz so weit ist es noch nicht wie er dort für die zehner und zwanziger Jahre des 21. Jahrhunderts ausmalt.
Aber was Kurzweil hier tut er gibt uns da schon mal so eine Anleitung wie es werden wird und dass wir dann auch keine Angst mehr haben müssen vor so etwas wie Covic 19.
Gegen Ende des ersten Jahrzehnts des 21.
Jahrhunderts wird man dank der virtuellen Realität mit einem Liebhaber einer Sexarbeiterin oder einem simulierten Partner auditive und visuell völlig real zusammen sein können.
Man wird mit seiner Partnerin alles tun können außer sie zu berühren. Eine zugegebenermaßen gravierende Einschränkung.
Die virtuelle Berührung wird zu diesem Zeitpunkt zwar bereits eingeführt sein aber das allumfassende hoch realistische visuell auditive taktile virtuelle vehement wird erst in der zweiten Dekade des 21.
Jahrhunderts bis zur Vollendung perfektioniert sein.
Ab diesem Zeitpunkt wird der virtuelle Sex zum Realen in echte Konkurrenz treten.
Paare werden unabhängig von ihrer realen Entfernung virtuellen Sex haben können.
Und selbst wenn sie sich nahe sind wird der virtuelle Sex in mancher Hinsicht besser.
Und auf jeden Fall sicherer sein virtueller Sex wird Gefühle vermitteln die intensiver und angenehmer sind als beim konventionellen Sex. Und er wird körperliche Erfahrungen vermitteln die heute noch unbekannt sind.
Natürlich ist der virtuelle Sex auch der ultimativ sichere Sex da kein Schwangerschaft oder Infektionsrisiko besteht.
Gruppensex wird insofern eine neue Bedeutung gewinnen als mehrere Personen gleichzeitig die Erfahrung eines Partners teilen können.
Die Prostitution wird wie der virtuelle Sex überhaupt nicht mehr mit gesundheitlichen Risiken verbunden sein.
Ab dem vierten Jahrhundert werden virtuelle Erlebnisse durch Neuro Implantate möglich sein.
Dank dieser Technologie wird man in der Lage sein fast jede Art von Erfahrungen mit fast jeder Person zu machen und zwar real oder imaginär und zu jedem beliebigen Zeitpunkt.
Es wird ganz ähnlich sein wie die heutigen Chatrooms im Internet nur dass man die notwendige Ausrüstung bereits im Kopf hat und sehr viel mehr tun kann als nur zu plaudern.
Man ist den Begrenzungen seines natürlichen Körpers dann nicht mehr unterworfen da alle beteiligten Personen jede gewünschte körperliche Gestalt annehmen können.
Eine Vielfalt von Erlebnissen wird möglich sein ein Mann kann spüren wie es ist eine Frau zu sein und umgekehrt.
Und natürlich wird es in der zweiten Hälfte des 21.
Jahrhunderts Nano Botz Schwärme geben die Nanobereich Schwärme könnten augenblicklich jede gewünschte Gestalt und jede gewünschte Art von Erscheinung Intelligenz und Persönlichkeit annehmen.
Eine menschliche zum Beispiel wenn man sich davon angetan fühlt.
Eine ganz kleine Korrektur Ich habe einmal Vierteljahrhundert gesagt Das meinte das vierte Jahrzehnt im 21. Jahrhundert.
Ray Kurzweil Ich finde die Biografie beeindruckend. Google gründet eine Universität und macht ihn zum Chef und so weiter der Gipfel das ist ein Spinner.
Er ist ein Spinner Ja und das wollen wir nicht.
Man kann es nicht anders sagen.
Ich könnte mir aber vorstellen dass jetzt gerade in diesen humanistischen Think Tanks man sagt Ach das ist doch auch eine schöne Chance jetzt mit Covic.
Jetzt geht ja so vieles gerade nicht die Dating-Apps lassen ja erheblich nach wie wir wissen was ja ganz logisch ist vor Gruppensex wird gewarnt.
Und deshalb sagt man dass es eigentlich jetzt ein guter Zeitpunkt um Cybersex.
Jetzt an den Mann an die Frau zu bringen um zu zeigen dass das eigentlich die Zukunft ist Infektion frei und zugleich intensiver genießen.
Das ist ja dieses merkwürdige versprechen das unsere Zivilisation immer bereithält das wir intensiv genießen sollen und dann aber das bitte ohne Risiko tun sollen.
Ich trinke ja auch hier ein Getränk nämlich Cola.
Aber die Light-Version Ich kann ganz viel davon genießen ohne dass ich dann zugleich zu viel Zucker zu mir nehme.
Also ich beraube dann das Ganze auch wieder meiner eigentlichen Substanz das Genussmittel das ist ein bisschen was Cicek immer beschrieben hat.
Wir leben heute in so einem Zeitalter wo wir alles der Substanz berauben. Also Kaffee ohne Koffein Bier ohne Alkohol.
Und er sagte dann in gewisser Weise stimmt der alte Spruch dass Sex mit Kondom wie Duschen im Regenmantel ist.
Er provoziert auch da und zugleich ist das aber auch kann man sagen Der Fortschritt den wir auch gerne in Kauf nehmen wie wir uns,
heute selbstverständlich anschnallen wenn wir im Auto sitzen und nicht sagen Ich werde hier gerade meiner Freiheit beraubt selbst Ulf Poschardt würde das nicht sagen.
Ja es ist doch wirklich ein bisschen witzig dass man gerade feststellt dass die Kurve der Kranke und dadurch abgemildert werden kann dass der Körper vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Nikotin als im natürlichen Zustand hat während gleichzeitig Nikotin,
wenn wir ihn konsumieren in die Lunge kommt und die Lunge eigentlich zerstört.
Also da ist eine gewisse wie soll man sagen So ein heimlicher Humor hat sich da die Natur wieder mal ausgedacht.
Aber zu dem was Kurzweil da sagte Es gibt eine sehr große Rentner republikanische Frage die ich auch im Buch ganz tiefgehend diskutieren werde nämlich Warum steht eigentlich Treue und Monogamie immer noch so weit oben,
obwohl doch die technischen Möglichkeiten und zwar schon lange bevor jetzt die Realität von Wir können uns einfach schon implantierte müssen nur noch einschalten und schon können wir körperliche Nähe fühlen die gar nicht gegeben ist.
Das Smartphone steckt schon sehr viel näher her zu sehr entfernten Menschen. Das kann man über Video Telefonie und so weiter.
Jeder kann das nachvollziehen aber die Frage ist trotzdem Warum ist jungen Menschen von denen wir glauben sie sind alle Porno verseucht weil ja Porno so verfügbar ist.
Warum stehen die immer noch so auf Treue. Warum ist Ihnen das so wichtig warum wollen die ihren einen Partner haben Warum orientieren Sie sich an dem Lebensmodell der Eltern und der Großeltern und warum hat das sogar Konjunktur.
Es nimmt nicht ab sondern es nimmt sogar wieder zu und Kurzweil hat selbst ein bisschen verraten als er nämlich die Möglichkeit nannte.
Wir können dann in Sekundenbruchteilen diese Verbindung herstellen und auch wechseln jeder steht plötzlich zur Verfügung Partner für so ein körperliches vermitteltes aber körperliches Ereignis zu werden.
Und genau das ist das Problem das Smartphone oder sagen wir mal so sehr viel Ehen werden geschieden und das Einzige was.
Vor Gericht dann Als Datengrundlage dient um zu verhandeln wer jetzt wie wem entschädigt und wo der Schaden der ihr herkommen.
Es sind irgendwelche Cheat die Facebook suchen.
Das muss man sich jetzt genau verdeutlichen.
Menschen befinden sich in derselben Wohnung sehen aber dass der andere gerade am Smartphone ist und haben dann Zweifel hätte der gerade mit irgendjemanden anderen ist er eigentlich geistig total abwesend ist er nur noch körperlich.
Hier wünscht er sich eigentlich woanders hin ist aber so eine Beziehung Gefesselter.
Und dieses Gefühl wird natürlich Eifersucht ganz elementar natürlich mega strapaziert,
wenn dein Partner den Raum verlässt und nicht nur ein Bildschirm hat auf dem man sich mit irgendwem gerade unterhalten kann sondern in seinem Kopf noch irgendwas einschaltet.
Wir haben jetzt beispielsweise die Woche vermeldet bekommen Vibratoren die sich übers Internet fernsteuern lassen,
wo man das Szenario ist Man macht ein Video Konferenz Gespräch und auf der anderen Seite sitzt der Partner und wird stimuliert durch das was ich auf meinem Handy auslöse.
Genau das ist ja auch ein großes Geschäftsmodell inzwischen Es gibt ja quasi digitale Prostitution.
Dass das dann mit Webcam Sex verbunden ist wo dann Leute Geld überweisen und können damit dann dieses Treusch steuern.
Genau das vibriert dann umso mehr umso mehr derjenige der auf der andern Seite der Leitung das steuert.
So stell dir mal vor was es für Eifersucht Szenarien gäbe wenn du weißt mein Partner sitzt auf dem Sofa und er ist nicht nur sozusagen visuell.
Alles Smartphone gebunden sondern der sitzt vielleicht noch jemand auf der anderen Seite der gerade irgendwelche Vibratoren hoch und runter regelt.
Und du bekommst es gar nicht mit als Partner und umso mehr solche Szenarien das Fremdgehen möglich sind.
Und welche Meldung war das welche Meldung war das mit denen mit den Sextoys.
Welche Meldung,
Christian Siebers hat im heute journal Nr.
1 vermeldet dass die ferngesteuerten Vibratoren in der Corona Zeiten Absatzplus von 50 Prozent haben,
auf diese Meldung bezog ich mich also Man geht jetzt so langsam in diese Ray Kurzweil Richtung.
Das ist eine Zeier.
Man kann dieses körperliche Erleben tatsächlich über die Distanz spannen und es wird aber diese.
Genau und würdest du dann sagen Das setzt sich nicht durch weil es doch die den Wunsch nach Leiblichkeit gibt in der Sexualität und zugleich den Wunsch danach dann doch auch.
Auch wenn die Möglichkeiten die man wählen kann klirrenden man aber trotzdem auch sich als Opfer dieser Möglichkeiten dann rechtzeitig begreift und sagt Gut,
wenn ich hin und her switchen kann wie ich gerade möchte dann kann ein jeder andere das mit mir aber auch tun und das will ich nicht.
Dinge haben Erfolg wie wir sehen. Die haben ja auch bei der Sils beobachtet dieses Zeug findet jetzt Aufmerksamkeit und Absatz nur in dem Moment wo der eine das zum Weihnachtsgeschenken des Partners macht,
weiß er ja nicht ist eigentlich nur mein Handy mit dem Gerät verbunden oder steigert es nicht sozusagen des gedanklichen,
die Eifersucht Potenziale zu wissen es könnte auch jemand anders damit verbunden sein und Zugriff auf meinen Partner haben.
Diese Form des Smartphone hat sich schon sehr eingemischt und Eifersucht in Situationen möglich gemacht wo vor 50 Jahren die Leute dachten Wieso muss ich eifersüchtig sein Die Frau ist doch bei mir zu Hause die niemanden anderen,
und ich habe auch den ganzen Tag mit ihr verbracht und das ist so langsam aufgelöst worden und es wird jetzt geht immer weiter bis hin zu,
Jahre später da können wir uns einfach alle fünf Minuten neu entscheiden gucken und sich irgendwelche Bilder sondern alle fünf Minuten eine neue.
Ich hab jetzt mal mit dem Sex oder Ich hab jetzt genug bezahlt.
Das widerspricht also die technischen Möglichkeiten das zu fabrizieren.
Widerspricht der Realität der Menschen dass sie sich eigentlich wünschen dass Treue bei ihrem Partner total wichtig ist und dass sie eigentlich monogam monogam Lebensentwurf haben und so weiter.
Da gibt's ein bisschen auseinander denn die Tendenzen sie jedenfalls beide ersichtliche mehr Absatz von solchen Techniken die diese Richtung gehen.
Gleichzeitig haben wir immer höhere Werte an Treue ist mir wichtig meine Beziehung ist mir wichtig.
Ich bin immer unzufriedener damit wie sehr sich andere Menschen an mich binden wollen. Diese Unzufriedenheit nimmt ja auch immer weiter zu.
Sicherlich auch daran liegt dass man erkennt Ich kann zwar all diese Möglichkeiten ergreifen aber ich werde nicht glücklicher dadurch.
Das ist ja auch die Erfahrung die viele machen die sich mehrmals trennen dann auch gerade mit Kindern noch einmal mit Mitte 30 die dritte Ehe versuchen den dritten Anlauf.
Patchwork wird dann auch irgendwann immer immer komplizierter.
Das ist dann auch organisatorisch eigentlich nur noch mit einem Profi Management zu machen.
Und man sieht aber dann dass man doch eigentlich wieder mit dem neuen Partner in Lebenswelten gerät die eigentlich denen die Welt verlassen hat aufs Haar gleichen.
Und dass es tatsächlich wie du sagst Das glaube ich diese Gelegenheit Diebe schafft die es früher nicht gegeben hat.
Es gab einfach ganz viele Möglichkeiten der Transgression nicht oder wenn dann musste es auch eine Transgression sein die einen gewissen Mut erfordert.
Während heute schnell irgendeine App installiert Tinder was weiß ich.
Und dann einmal losgehe scrollt was dann so alles zur Verfügung steht dass es eben sehr sehr leicht und ich glaube das.
Müsste man statistisch mal erheben können wie viele Ehen eigentlich geschieden werden dadurch dass es eine Verbindung zu irgendwelchen Dating Plattformen oder so gab vielleicht gibt es da schon erste Zahlen drüber.
Aber das ist sicherlich ein Trend der anhalten wird.
Das wird sicherlich nicht weniger werden. Ich glaube aber dass tatsächlich dieser Wunsch nach Treue wächst und dass diese Polyamorie Konzepte.
Das war mal so vor paar Jahren ein Trend das in der Zeit und überall ständig irgendwelche Leute sagten wie großartig ihr Polyamorie Leben ist dass sie dann sehr schnell verkennen wie viel Leid eigentlich permanent dadurch produziert wird.
Und das kam dann auch manchmal noch so daher mit dieser Idee.
Das ist jetzt so richtig subversiv ja zeigen wir es mal der bürgerlichen Gesellschaft muss man sagen Nee der Neoliberalismus der lebt davon dass Menschen sich mobilisieren flexibilisieren ohne Ende.
Und da hat er dann eine Hinterende fast eine kapitalismuskritische Funktion.
Ich glaube Norbert Blüm hat das sogar mal so ausgeführt der ja in diesem Monat leider verstorben ist und es gibt eine schöne überlegung von Slavoj žižek.
Stellen Sie sich eine Frau vor die ein vollkommen langweiliges Leben führt.
Sie hat regelmäßig Sex mit mehreren Männern. Dann entscheidet sie sich für einen wirklich radikalen Akt.
Sie heiratet einen Mann aber lange hält sie diese Radikalität diese Intensität nicht aus und sie flüchtet sich zurück in ihr langweiliges Leben mit poli Amouren Sex Beziehungen.
Diese Polyamorie also in langfristigen Ehen liegt irgendwie auf der Hand dass man diesen gedanklichen Ausbruch immer mal durchspielt der Seitensprung das ist ja auch Werbemaßnahme,
Potenzial dahinter. Es ist halt so.
Diese kurzfristigen Befriedigung kompensieren diese langfristigen,
Synergieeffekte von Ehen einfach nicht. Soweit kann man diese psychologischen Studien dazu sehen.
Und wenn man trotzdem in diese Richtung gehen möchte,
dann ist es nicht kurz verknappt dass man dann so in Berlusconi Harvey Weinstein artigen Ich will aber jetzt jeden Abend eine neue Frau oder,
gar keinen anbandeln oder sonstige soziale Beziehungen mehr Staat sondern das ist reine Erpressung die da einfach praktiziert wird.
Und dann wäre da noch so ein ganzes Unternehmen drum herum aufgebaut um es zu ermöglichen also diese Sachen Arten immer aus.
Es gibt dafür sehr viele gute Beispiele die das zeigen und so richtig.
Wir reden ja auch über Einsamkeit und sterben so richtig froh ist man am Lebensende nicht wenn man wenn man mit 20 30 40 50 und 60 jeweils andere Partner hatte mit dem man das Leben geteilt hat.
Das schlägt sich am Ende spätestens am Ende dann nieder wenn man sich alleine will ich nicht sterben aber wer soll eigentlich an meinem Bett stehen.
Ein bisschen wie Elizabeth Taylor die ja acht Mal verheiratet war also die Ehe sehr liebte David Lynch hat auch mal erzählt er hat sie getroffen. Und sofort fand sie ihn sympathisch. Sie hat ihn auch geküsst denn er wollte immer mal von Elizabeth Taylor geküsst werden.
Und dann hat sie ihn auch gleich gefragt ob er denn verheiratet sei denn sie heirate ja nun mal so gerne.
Aber das führt dann auch dazu dass sie dann später auch sehr krank war und im Krankenhaus sich einer Operation unterzog.
Dass sie als sie erwachte dann niemanden neben sich stehen hatte keinen Partner und Ihre erste Frage war Wo sind meine Juwelen.
Ja ja genau. Das sind ganz traurige Geschichten die sich sehr gut aufschreiben lassen.
Aber die leider sehr zutreffend sind. Und wenn Räterepublik.
Da gibt's einiges von diesem wie in Amerika Startwert. Was wird da verhandelt worum geht es da was sind die Ursachen bis hin zum Sterben.
Das findet in diesem Kontinuum statt.
Von diesen Problemlagen und die Kernfamilie ist doch ein erstaunlich erfolgreiches Modell.
Man kann immer sagen sie wurde ja erfunden von den Industriellen die diese,
Masse mal aufbrechen wollten und sagen wollten nee hier geht es nicht in die Kneipe und verbündet euch gegen die Kapitalisten sondern es geht mal schön jeder zu seiner Familie nach Hause also hat man in so Einfamilienhäuser hingestellt.
Das hat Niklas Maak ganz wunderbar beschrieben wie man aus dieser Dorf und Verbands Struktur in die Kleinfamilie gebracht wurde.
Rein architektonisch und daraufhin die Zivilisation möglich war das Durchstarten der Kapitalisten weil sie den Widerstand gebrochen hatten aber mal am Rande erwähnt.
Der Erfolg der Kleinfamilie und der Zweierbeziehung und so weiter ist doch irgendwie,
schon deutlich gerade jetzt so und jetzt wegen Corona sondern so jetzt seit wir das iPhone haben die letzten zehn zehn Jahre ist es doch eher Erfolgsmodell als weniger Erfolgsmodell auch wenn wir,
eine große Säkularisierung haben in einer Gesellschaft aber da kommt man ja eher darauf zurück.
Um daran so ein bisschen anzuknüpfen und kurze Lebens wirklich zu werden.
Ich will mal kurz über Apps und Masken sprechen weil es ja doch so drängende Themen sind.
Aber als hinweg dazu eine Frage von Twitter nämlich von Johann.
Er schrieb vielleicht kann in der nächsten Folge noch einmal auf symbiotische Mechanismen eingegangen werden.
Habe mir eigentlich alles was es dazu gibt bei Luhmann angeschaut insbesondere die Kapitel aus soziale Systeme und Gesellschaft der Gesellschaft und so weiter.
Hat sich rein gepfiffen schreibt er. Trotzdem ist mir die theoretische Integration unklar. Also ganz konkret Was hat das jetzt mit Coruña zu tun.
Deswegen wollte ich das noch mal kurz anmerken weil es mir dann selber noch mal aufgefallen wie interessant es eigentlich ist diese symbiotischen Mechanismen,
die körperliche Bedürftigkeit die überhaupt erst den Bedarf an Funktionen System herstellt Bildung Einkaufsmöglichkeiten Wirtschaft Familie und so weiter und so fort.
Diese Kopplung an den Körper von Gesellschaft und gerade in einer Gesellschaftstheorie die sagten Ja ich brauche keine Menschen für meine Argumentation Bereich Kommunikation ist Biologie da ist klar mach ich einfach aus.
Sehen wir jetzt auch jetzt plötzlich kriegen wir biologische Aufklärung die uns wirklich staunen lässt über unsere Körper wenn wir diese Podcaster naja jedenfalls.
Der Kniff dabei ist in dieser Theorie diese Kopplung von Körper und Gesellschaft gelingt unter grösstmöglichen Umweg ums Bewusstsein.
Das ist eigentlich der Kern Wir werden nicht die ganze Zeit daran erinnert wie die Gesellschaft funktioniert und wir müssen sie auch nicht verstehen sondern sie funktioniert einfach.
Und jede Aufklärung die dazu stattfindet lässt uns staunen was wir Kinder haben fünf Millionen Mal mehr Viren als Erwachsene wie passend das alles in den kleinen Rachen rein und plötzlich hat man so ganz was anderes.
Der Körper hat mehr Bakterien als das Universum Sterne sind einfach so.
Also muss man das Wissen um in der Gesellschaft zu überleben ja oder nein. Man muss es nicht wissen es funktioniert irgendwie trotzdem.
Wir haben beim Sport geht es bei uns um das Gefühl etwas geleistet zu haben und Spaß zu haben und die ganze physischen Angelegenheiten und lebensverlängernden Maßnahmen die da auch mit beikommen sind uns im Grunde irgendwie so ein bisschen egal.
Genau wie wir beim Sex eben einfach das erleben und nicht darüber debattieren. Das kann man ihrem Podcast machen über Sex.
Auch ganz schwierig. Gerade wenn wir uns ausmalen was wirklich beim Sex geschieht.
Das Leben ist ja relativ widerwärtig wenn man sieht was man so vor Augen führt und wie Leben entsteht.
Man will die biologische Grundlagen nicht wissen genau.
Genau das war ja auch deshalb früher so.
Oder ist es auch immer noch so dass manche Sexual Psychologen sagen es ist gar nicht so gut zum Beispiel wenn der Partner anwesend ist im Kreißsaal.
Das kann gewisse Effekte auslösen. Das haben wir laufend Wir machen das die ganze Zeit und.
Ein Trauma hinterlassen.
Können ja auch ärzte oder Pfleger sehr gut differenzieren zwischen den Körpern die sie begehren und den Körpern die sie pflegen und sie sehen die Körper die sie pflegen überhaupt nicht als sexuelle Körper an.
Und vor allem können sie nach Hause und können Sexualität leben und denken nicht an die klaffenden Wunden die sie heute gepflegt haben.
Genau und so wie du das für diesen Lebensbereich sagst geht das beispielsweise auch in der Wissenschaft selbst da wo sich Menschen so richtig dafür interessieren wie es funktioniert blenden sie eigentlich fast alles aus was die Grundlage ist.
Also kein Biologe kennt die technischen Grundlagen seines Labors sondern er befriedigt dort einfach eine Neugier.
Auch da ist es vor allem ein Gefühl was antreibt und nicht das Durchdringen aller Grundlagen die man dafür auch wissen könnte aber eben nicht wissen muss.
Und es gibt ja so eine vulgäre Kulturkritik die dann immer sagt Ja die Welt ist einfach zu komplex geworden und es ist doch schlimm dass wir mit Autos fahren die wir überhaupt nicht mehr verstehen wie die eigentlich zusammengebaut sind.
Da würde ich sagen dass das überhaupt nicht schlimm.
Man kann dann in die Werkstatt fahren die lesen das aus. Ich weiß ganz viel nicht wie das funktioniert.
Wir wissen auch nicht wie ein Pferd funktioniert.
Die meisten Dinge die ich so an Bäckerei waren esse keine Ahnung wie man die eigentlich macht könnte ich auch nicht.
Ich kann auch keine Sachertorte machen.
Ich weiß in etwa was drin ist. Das reicht mir.
Wer von einem Pferd auf ein Auto umsteigt Er weiß von dem Auto so wenig wie von dem Pferd vorher weiß. Irgendwann muss ich tanken und füttern.
Und da kommen Abgase raus und da muss man halt die Pferdeäpfel Aufsammeln der Rest bleibt doch ziemlich verborgen.
Insgesamt und das schlägt sich eben wirklich nieder. Wenn wir jetzt Virologen Podcast hören.
Warum eigentlich. Weil wir uns irgendwie mitschreiben was da gesagt wird weil das später Prüfungen relevant ist.
Wir hören natürlich 50 Minuten Drosten und in Minute 28 nennt er die eine Zahl die wir uns dann für später merken.
Und warum ist sie so interessant weil wir sie weiter tratschen können.
Es ist sozusagen Wir haben durch den Zaun geguckt von diesem Walter Wünsche der Gossip vor 80 Jahren erfunden hat und wir wissen etwas über die Nachbarn was die anderen noch nicht wissen.
Also versuchen wir es denjenigen zu erklären bevor sie selbst draußen gehört haben.
Das kann man sich selber wirklich mal überprüfen wenn man so eine richtig tolle Information bei Drosten gehört hat beispielsweise drei und vierzig komma sechs Prozent der Leute tragen die Krankheitssymptome bloß weiter.
Man ist schon ein bisschen enttäuscht wenn man jemanden erzählen will dann habe ich auch gehört. Muss ich mir nicht sagen.
Der Tratsch ist wertlos. übrigens ist hören zu viele Drosten also der Ansicht sind wir kommen einfach nicht davon raus.
Egal welcher Lebensbereich es ist. Es ist die intrinsische Motivation ist irgendwie anders gelagert Wir wollen am Tratsch teilnehmen.
Wir wollen ein tolles Gefühl erleben wir sind neugierig und dulden deswegen die lange Zeit im Labor weil dann am Ende irgendwelche Ergebnisse rauskommen die noch keiner wusste und so weiter.
Der verlagert sich übrigens auch der Tratsch also der Tratsch in ganz klassisch verstandenen Sinne also das was die goldenen Blätter so schreiben.
Das ist etwas was momentan gar nicht mehr so viel getratscht wird.
Man hat den neuen Tratsch entdeckt und der ist das was du gerade beschrieben hast mit den Podcasts mit den Virologen Podcast also dann auch auf die lokale Ebene heruntergebrochen.
Hast du schon gehört da ist jetzt dies und das in im Supermarkt schon mittags um drei dicht gemacht da waren die Schlangen zu lang und solche Dinge die werden jetzt alle getratscht während wir jetzt uns gar nicht mehr so dafür interessieren was machen diese Promis jetzt gerade.
Sie haben ja vor allem dann Peinlichkeiten von sich gegeben oder haben auch einfach nur zur Vernunft aufgerufen.
Und dann fragte ich vor kurzem Freunde was ist denn eigentlich noch so passiert in diesem Monat.
Und dann schickte mir einer einen wunderbaren Link dass die Mutter von Nia ma das ist wohl ein Fußballer.
Kennst du den Nim Nima Neymar Nima Neymar Neymar.
Ach nein Neymar Naima.
Ja die hatte jetzt einen 22 jährigen Lover.
Und jetzt habe ich aber gestern gelesen dass Sie sich von ihm getrennt hat. Das waren so Tratsch Meldungen da hätte man vielleicht früher ein bisschen mehr draus gemacht.
Aber jetzt ist wichtiger was sagt Kekulé über Drosten und hosten über Kekulé. Da hat man ja auch so einen Tratsch.
Und vor allem Streeck lassen uns gerade sehr zappeln. Ich lass mal die Ergebnisse die muss ich erst mal ausarbeiten.
Das heißt irgendwelche Leute wissen nicht was sie hier noch nicht zur Verfügung haben.
Die Produktion von Tratsch auch im Sinne von Ich gehe durch den Park fotografiert die Leute auf Twitter hole die Empörung ab Guckt mal hier wie sie sich wieder falsch verhalten und so weiter.
Ist das alles diese Tratsch Produktion jetzt und jetzt kommt der Dreh in dieser soziologisch Systemtheorie.
Das Problem ist ja Wir blenden viele der Lebensgrundlagen einfach aus. Bis hin zur überstrapazierten von Luhmann das einfach sagt Menschen interessieren mich nicht das ist ja nur Biologie.
Mich interessieren nur was sozusagen an der Grenze dieser Biologie irritierend in die Sozialität einströmt.
Jetzt ist aber so das Corona Zeitalter was wir jetzt seit zwei Wochen erleben seit zwei Monaten erleben sagt uns.
Wir können es gar nicht ausblenden weil es geht um unseren Körper. Eigentlich wollen wir jetzt so viel wie möglich verstehen.
Dieses Wir gehen mal einen Bogen um das Bewusstsein herum also die ganze,
zentrale Funktionalität der Gesellschaft möglich zu sein ohne das Bewusstsein die ganze Zeit mit Schleifen zu müssen und nie mehr klären zu müssen was hier gerade passiert.
Sondern es einfach immer weiterzumachen.
Das funktioniert gerade nicht so richtig weil wir einen unbändigen Wunsch haben jetzt geradezu verstehen und zwar bewusst zu verstehen wirklich zu lernen. Was passiert mit unserem Körper.
Wir werden hart körperlich richtig in Beschlag genommen und was wir erleben dieses Wir gehen vor die Tür und erleben die ganze Zeit ein Kulturschock als wären wir in so einer als wären wir irgendwie in Nordafrika. Andere Länder andere Sitten.
Menschen haben Masken auf wechseln die Straßenseite.
Wir beobachten sehr genau im Supermarkt Wer bewegt sich eigentlich wie.
Es gibt diese interessante Szene bei Jason Bourne. Er sitzt mit Franka Potente im Café und sagt Du musst mich nicht fragen.
Hinter mir die Tür ist drei Meter weit weg und ich weiß links Da sitzen drei und so.
Das ist mittlerweile Normalzustand für viele Deutsche. Sobald sie in so ein kleines Geschäft reingehen sondieren sie das wie Jason Bourne und sie gucken Wo sind denn hier die Gefahren für meinen Körper und so weiter.
Die sind ja alle ansteckend. Also genau die richtige Herangehensweise.
Verhalte dich so dass alle anderen krank sind und du auch. Und du willst es nicht haben und will es auch nicht weitergeben.
Wir laufen jetzt alle wieso Jason Bourne total paranoid durch die Gegend.
Sobald wir einen Raum betreten sondieren wir den erstmal und diese Form des Beschlägen in Beschlag nehmen des Bewusstseins das merken wir jetzt alle die es extrem belastend.
Wir können nicht einfach mehr entspannt einer Selbstverständlichkeit nachgehen wie auf dem Weg irgendwo hin zu entscheiden.
Ich gehe nochmal kurz rein hol mir Kaugummis. Nee hab ich meine Maske dabei.
Wir sind gerade drin hat der Handschuhe an. Hab ich Bargeld kann ich mit Karte zahlen.
All das läuft jetzt durch das Bewusstsein einmal durch und dieses prozessieren ist extrem belastend weil sehr viele Antworten auf die Fragen die wir uns stellen sind einfach nicht gute Antworten.
Also lasst uns auch nochmal inhaltlich nicht nur dass wir uns die Frage stellen sondern die Antwort ist dann auch noch belassen.
Ist dieses System herangehen unter der Prämisse dass Gesellschaft eigentlich gut funktioniert wenn das Bewusstsein nicht mitgenommen wird.
Wenn man die Gedanken sind frei über alles nachdenken muss außer über das konkrete überleben bei jedem weiteren Schritt den man auf der Straße tut da kann man grad also wenn man jetzt Luhmann liest kann man das alles nochmal erleben.
Wie groß die Problematik Eigentlich ist die man da mitmacht.
Und ich meine es schlägt sich alles nieder In diesem Man verabschiedet sich von Leuten und sagt Bleiben Sie gesund und es ist erstmalig in hundert Jahren keine Floskel sondern alle meinen dass in dem Moment wirklich ernst.
Eigentlich ist die Floskel Wir verlassen jetzt das Gespräch wie keine andere Wahl nicht unhöflich sein. Also haben wir auch so eine Floskel hinterher damit für alle klar ist das Gespräch vorbei.
Eigentlich ist es der totale okey aus Verlegenheit Sagen wir es mal Mach's gut.
Aber jetzt bin ich jetzt umgeben und es ist nicht unhöflich jetzt sagen Wir bleiben Sie gesund und plötzlich wird uns in diesem Sprechakt wieder gewahr Ich meine es echt ernst. Ich will echt dass du bleibst.
Die Chancen sind nicht groß dass du bleibst weil Dämmstoff und so weiter.
Aus wie sehr grundsätzlich unser Bewusstsein gerade im Schlag mitgenommen wird.
Es hat gute psychologische Studien zum Thema geben.
Ja ich empfinde es auch als durchaus belastend diese Szenarien durchzugehen.
Beispielsweise kaufe ich ja hin und wieder noch Zeitungen gedruckt und das mache ich auch jetzt noch.
Aber ich stelle mir dann die Frage Wer könnte die Zeitung jetzt schon mal angefasst haben.
Soll ich sie denn jetzt lesen man kann ja eine Zeitung nicht desinfizieren.
Soll ich sie vier fünf Tage liegen lassen bis das Virus sich verflüchtigt hat und dann lese ich eine alte Zeitung.
Man kann ja solche Szenarien durchspielen und wird dabei nicht besonders froh.
Und ich glaube man muss dann auch in irgendeiner Weise doch wieder dieses ausstellen das abschalten dann wirklich einmal praktizieren.
Gut ich muss das jetzt ausschalten sonst kann ich auch nicht mehr weitermachen sonst muss ich auch bei jedem Einkauf sagen denen desinfizieren ich jetzt auch nochmal.
Dann kann ich überhaupt nichts mehr kaufen was irgendwo offen liegt also Brötchen Brot dann alles nur noch abgepackt. Das will auch niemand.
Von daher ist das eigentlich jetzt interessant zu erleben wie wir jetzt mit so einer Lockerung des Lock Downs,
jetzt versuchen eigentlich wieder in so ein funktionales System zu kommen dass eben nicht mehr so ist dass wir permanent reflektieren und zugleich müssen wir aber durch den gelockerten lock down,
eigentlich noch mehr Vorsichtsmaßnahmen treffen da jetzt wieder die Risiken extrem gestiegen sind.
Und ich gehe ja nächste Woche zum Friseur.
Ich habe den ersten Termin ergattert. Was heißt ergattert.
Ich wurde netterweise von meinem wirklich ausgezeichneten Friseur angerufen und der hat mir dann gleich den ersten Termin gegeben und sagte dann auch aber mit Maske und so. Ich bin gespannt wie sich das dann dort gestaltet.
Aber das ist jetzt auch das Risiko das ich eingehe.
Was ich auch eingehen will.
Ja es ist genau wie du sagst die Lockerungen werden kommen.
Schon allein weil wir sie nicht 63 Jahre durchhalten und das steigert das Risiko aufgrund einer eigenen Entscheidung die ich in der öffentlichkeit treffe.
Uns kann die minimale sein plötzlich nicht zu wissen und das ist ja dann echt blöde.
Man sitzt ja dann fünf Tage lang da und wartet jetzt in Katzenhalter oder nicht.
Und wenn man es hat ist es jetzt Kobelt. Dadurch dass immer noch dieser Zeitverzug drin ist das strapaziert das umso mehr da gibt's ja zwei Sachen die können uns das ein bisschen verhindern dass wir jetzt wirklich harte Grenzen zwischen öffentlich und privat wieder einziehen.
Diese Strapaze Man muss es ja wirklich nicht geben wird gerade diese App diskutiert und die Bundesregierung hat erst in der sechsten Woche.
Ich bleibe bei dem Begriff loggt daran weil ich in der sechsten Woche entschieden jetzt mal vernünftig zu werden und wirklich zielorientiert Wir brauchen diese App und wir machen da kein Genießens Toll Collect.
Die E-Mail aus der nicht funktioniert.
Es war ja wirklich hart an der Grenze unter anderem weil Virologen sich in die Diskussion einmischen.
Melanie Brinkmann vom Helmholtz-Zentrum hat bei Spiegel-Online Original gesagt Das erste Zitat aus einem Interview.
Jetzt stellen sich auch noch Datenschützer entsprechenden Apps die die Nachverfolgung viel schneller machen könnten in den Weg.
Daraufhin fragt Spiegel nach. Sie meinen also in diesem Fall geht die Eindämmung der Pandemie über den Datenschutz.
Wie bringt man sagt Ich finde es unglaublich dass diese Debatte überhaupt geführt wird.
Ich möchte Datenschutz komplett herausstreichen. Das finde ich an sich schon skandalös vor allem zeigt sich hier sie ist ja nicht einmal. Sie weiß ja nicht einmal was diskutiert wird.
Es geht ja gerade nicht einmal Datenschutz nicht Datenschutz diskutiert sondern,
dezentral oder nicht dezentral und man muss ganz klar sagen die zentrale Lösung mit einem Server wo alle Kontaktinformationen bei der Bundesregierung auf einem zentralen Server liegen und die dann ausrechnen wer mit wem Kontakt hatte.
Die wird es rein technisch niemals geben. Nicht einmal Apple oder Google trauen sie sich zu zu bauen.
Also braucht die Bundesregierung erst gar nicht ankommen so eine Ausschreibung zu machen weil dieses Team gäbe es so nie.
Aber es sei ja mitunter so aus als würde am Ende Erpel als würde Google mehr für uns für unseren Datenschutz tun als die Bundesregierung.
Es so geplant werden.
Dadurch dass Apple das ja sowieso immer schon so gehandhabt habe dass Daten nicht weitergegeben werden.
Es gab ja da auch mal die Auseinandersetzungen vor Gerichten in den USA.
War man jetzt ja fast froh dass es diese Großkonzerne gibt,
die dann sagen Naja wir können das hier so dezentral anbieten und wir können das so machen dass das dann auch nicht so heikel ist was die persönlichen Daten anbelangt und wir auch hier waren wir in gewisser Weise nicht prophetisch aber wir haben schon dieses Thema aufgegriffen.
Wir hatten ja über diesen Text von Agamben geredet ganz kurz in der letzten Ausgabe von 29 dass wir sagten Na ja man kann natürlich nicht behaupten dass das Virus ein Konstrukt ist.
Aber Agamben hat doch recht damit wenn er sagt so ein Virus wird verwendet dazu um so etwas wie den überwachungsstaat auszubauen.
Er sieht da schon eine Biopolitik am Werke die hochproblematisch,
ist und das können wir dann an solchen skandalösen äußerungen sehen und offenbar aber dadurch dass so viele Leute sich gerade mit Dingen auseinandersetzen die sie sonst nie beschäftigen eben mit Virologen und mit allen Fragen Wie können wir uns schützen.
Wurde der Datenschutz auch ein bisschen mehr so war mein Eindruck zumindest dann auch in der breiten Bevölkerung ein Thema es war jetzt mal nicht so dass man hörte ja Staatstrojaner und so das interessiert dann den Chaos Computer Club und da kann man was auf Heise zu lesen,
sondern es war jetzt schon ein größeres Thema,
und das hat sicherlich dafür gesorgt dass die Bundesregierung da zurückgerudert ist.
Apple und Google haben tatsächlich gemeinsam allerersten Mal überhaupt etwas gemeinsam gemacht haben.
In diesem Rahmen sonst ist das harte Konkurrenz um die Arbeit die Mitarbeiter und so weiter da wurden ja richtig krasse sagen.
Es gab früher Friedensverträge zwischen Apple und Google wo wirklich die Chefs miteinander versprochen haben.
Wenn jemand bei dir einen Arbeitsvertrag hat machen wir keinen abwehrte Versuch und dann wurde das gebrochen und so weiter. Da gab es große große Straits.
Wer hat von wem welche Designs geklaut und so weiter.
Eigentlich liegen diese Konzerne komplett im Streit und sie haben sich jetzt darauf geeinigt zu sagen Wir machen einen gemeinsamen Vorschlag von dem wir jetzt schon durchschimmert haben lassen. Das ist ein sehr datenschutzrechtlicher Vorschlag.
Darin steckt eine große Wahrheit Ja es ist ein absolut radikal Datenschutz freundlicher.
Aber es ist natürlich auch eine große Verlogenheit. Linus Neumann hat das Argument gemacht was ich da nachvollziehbar finde Apple und Google würden am liebsten auch diese Art von Bewegungsdaten zentral speichern.
Nur nicht mal die trauen sich die technische Komplexität zu denn das Ding muss im Juni spätestens sollte es mal fertig sein und praktikabel sein und das Ding wird natürlich unter Dauerfeuer von Angriffen leiden,
und man kann sozusagen den Countdown schon mal langsam hochziehen.
Den Countdown hochziehen den Timer laufen lassen.
Wann kommt die Nachricht dass die Datenbank geöffnet wurde.
Und wer ist schuld daran. Apple und Google trauen es sich zu. Deswegen glaube ich dieser große Umschwung das kann man auch.
Aber die Argumente sind ich ein bisschen langsamer gern machen weil es wirklich so deutlich wie mal bei dieser Diskussion Melani bringt man vom Helmholtz-Zentrum als Virologe und sagt Das kann ja wohl nicht sein mit dem Datenschutz und so weiter.
Und dann haben wir auf der einen Seite nicht nur eine Datenschutz freundliche sondern auch eine technisch übersichtliche nachvollziehbare ein Vorschlag von Apple und Google Man muss das nicht groß verschleiern weil es funktioniert für sich technisch einfach gut.
Man muss jetzt nicht drei Schutzzäune um diesen Teich bauen die man dann schützen will sondern er wird anders geschützt.
Und mich hat sehr beeindruckt dass bei Security Nao die seit 15 Jahren höre,
Steve Gibson der sich sehr gut auskennt in diesen ganzen validiert man eigentlich und evaluiert man solche technischen Systeme eigentlich richtig und der baut selbst an so Authentifizierung System wie man sich eigentlich ein und gibt seine Identität bekannt und so weiter.
Sehr gute Vorschläge gemacht die auch praktisch einfach gut funktionieren also nicht nur Theorie sondern auch wirklich Produkte die er verkauft.
Und jetzt schauen wir mal seine Einschätzung zum Thema Kona Tracing ab wie es von Apple und Google vorgestellt wurde.
Technisch ergänzt zu kleinen Hinweisen Man muss es ja auch unter die Leute bringen.
Social Engineering sagt Herbert Tencent Padua Technologie Sicherheit.
Biedern.
Technik kursorisch Senk.
Merk.
Das einzige was gesendet wird von diesen Handys ist das was aus dem Schmack aus dem Zufallsgenerator raus fällt es ist Zufalls Müll der sich von nichts unterscheiden lässt.
Da ist auch nicht eine persönliche Information verschlüsselt oder sowas sondern die ist einfach gar nicht da drin.
Es sind wirklich einfach Zufallszahlen und die müssen auf dem Smartphone selbst berechnet werden.
Da kommt die Sicherheit her und jetzt kommt die große Verlogenheit und ich wundere mich dass sie in der deutschen Diskussion noch gar nicht so stattfand weil wir ja eigentlich eine sehr differenzierte ausführliche tiefgehende Privacy Argumentation haben.
Das was er jetzt beschrieb ist eine perfekte Lösung bezieht sich auf den Privacy Charakter denn technisch ist es natürlich gar keine Frage dass wir seit hundert Jahren Signale aussenden und auch wieder empfangen.
Also einfach nur die Bekanntgabe wer hat mit wem Kontakt gehabt das ist ja gar kein Problem. Und da muss man jetzt wirklich mal ganz deutlich sagen Unternehmen wie Facebook oder so.
Die nicht nur selbst Daten sammeln sondern auch noch Daten zukaufen wo man sich einmal fragt.
Ich weiß ja genau wie das war Wir haben damals in der F.A.Z. Ich habe ja damals fast täglich Texte über genau diesen Sachverhalt geschrieben wie Google vor allem und insbesondere Facebook dann begann mit Daten umzugehen.
Facebook handelt ja mit Daten und dann kamen alle Ja ja die haben so viel Daten die können ja locker verkaufenden verdienen Milliarden mit und dann war die Antwort immer Nee die Handel mit Daten aber nicht als Verkäufer sondern als Käufer.
Facebook kauft noch Daten dazu die sie selbst nicht erheben können da fragt man sich welche eigentlich.
2007 hat Apple das iPhone erfunden. Es war das allererste Telefon mit WLAN.
Steve Jobs wollte es so weit treiben dass man gar kein Funknetz braucht weil es gibt ja genug WLAN. Also man geht die Straße entlang und wählt sich alle drei Sekunden ein neues WLAN ein.
So funktioniert doch auch das war so seine Idee. Und dann müssen doch 3G einbauen.
3G beim ersten Telefon gar nicht drin sondern erst das zweite iPhone 3G und so weiter.
War dieses ganz elementare funkten wie 985.
So aber WLAN war drin. Und was macht das WLAN im eigenen Handy sende die ganze Zeit zum kleinen Ping aus und fragt Bin ich eigentlich zu Hause und habe WLAN oder bin ich unterwegs hab kein WLAN.
Man ist plötzlich 2007 von heute auf morgen mit einem kleinen Funken Strahler herumgelaufen der 100 mal pro Sekunde das Signal ausgesendet hat und zwar hundert Meter weit.
Ich bin also genau so jedes Telefon das in Amerika verkauft wird sowie jedes technische System das irgendwie funkt muss er durch die FCC also diese zentrale.
Regierungsbehörde die da sagt er habe abgenommen damit darfst du Funken.
Das macht keine großen Sachen kaputt oder so..
Und am Anfang war es über Jahre so dass es dieses Telefon tatsächlich das eindeutige Kennzeichen nämlich die MAC-Adresse die ganze Zeit rum gesendet hat.
Und dann kam die Datencenter drauf und meinten Na ja aber wenn Elsa einkaufen geht und sie besucht zehn Läden und wir stellen zehn Läden so ein kleines Ding auf.
Das speichert diese MAC-Adresse haben wir gerade gesehen.
Mit dieser Signalstärke von 13 Uhr 20 bis 13 Uhr 27 Minuten später war sie im Laden nochmal drei Minuten später war sie beim Friseur und man könne plötzlich richtig nachvollziehen auch dieses Handy hat sich einfach da und da so bewegt.
Und dann kommt dieses Handy nach Hause. Facebook kauft diese ganzen Daten und sagt Ja liebe Elsa Wir haben gesehen Du warst beim Friseur so machen wir jetzt keine Frisur Vorschläge aber wir haben gesehen.
Du bist zweimal in diesen Laden gegangen was ja noch nicht sicher ist oder nicht Wir zeigen jetzt mal Uhren.
Facebook hat diesen Daten Reactor vor denen sich jetzt alle fürchten.
Vor zehn Jahren schon gebaut und in Betrieb genommen und Apple und Google haben sehr lange aus.
Muss man sagen Ahnungslosigkeit einfach mitgemacht weil die nämlich einfach das iPhone die ganze Zeit haben senden lassen.
Also das eigene Kennzeichen wurde die ganze Zeit hundert Meter weit gesendet und dann kam Apple irgendwann auf die Idee.
Eine Nachfrage stellen Verständniss Frage. Das heißt man hat diesen Gedanken gehabt Man könnte das dann von den Geschäften aus quasi überwachen. Wie ist das Kaufverhalten. Aber wie hat man das dann dort installiert.
Was wurde dann dort am Equipment als Software oder Hardware.
Einfach ein kleiner Empfänger. Die ist ja das Signal aus Hallo ich bin dieses und jenes Whelan.
Willst du dich mit ihr verbinden und dann kam die Antwort Nee ich kann mich mit ihr nicht verbinden weil ich kenne dich ja nicht und du hast auch mein Passwort nicht und diese kleine Information also die MAC-Adresse so und so hat sich bei mir gemeldet und um Zugang gebeten.
Die muss man ja nicht verwerfen die kann man ja auch einfach speichern.
Dann läuft also Lockvogel auf und da steht dann diese MAC-Adresse die haben wir heute von 13 Uhr bis 13 Uhr 27 bei unserer Nähe gesehen.
Aber wie hat Facebook darauf wieder Zugriff.
Das ist ja jetzt der Punkt. Unternehmen bauen diese kleinen Kästen einfach ein W-Lan Receiver einfach mal so wie ja auch Google bei.
Bei Google ist ja mit Streetview herumgefahren wo alle dachten es ist ja nur eine Kamera drauf macht halt Fotos stellt sich raus ne die haben auch noch alle WLANs die sie so gesehen haben mit gespeichert und da gabs großen großen ärger weil sie diese Daten eben nicht gelöscht haben.
Ich durch die Straße gefahren habe alle WLANs mit gespeichert. Das ist ja auch so wenn du dich heute irgendwo mit dem WLAN einlässt weiß dein Handy wo du bist weil es große Tabellen gibt welches WLAN ist eigentlich wo.
Darüber wird viel Ortung gemacht. Da Steve Jobs auch gedacht.
Brauchen wir eigentlich TPS. Wir wissen doch wo die WLANs sind wenn die Leute da eingeloggt sind sind sie da so und diese Daten die da anfiel diese riesigen Lokführers,
Das ist eine ganz normale Dienstleistung gewesen die konnte man kaufen Es war eins zu eins Daten Händler wie man sich das vorstellt und da hat auch keiner was dagegen gemacht.
Irgendwann kam dann ein iPhone auf die Idee Apple.
Wir müssen ja nicht immer die gleiche MAC-Adresse senden nur weil das Handy wissen will kenne ich dieses WLAN da muss man ja nicht das Kennzeichen mitschicken sondern da kann man ja auch irgendein Ping erstmal schicken und dann hat das iPhone als allererstes Google macht das mittlerweile auch.
So im Rhythmus von einer halben Stunde.
Du hast keine Ahnung immer neue MAC-Adressen bekommen neue Kennzeichen sodass man nicht mehr nachvollziehen konnte was wir beim Friseur 17:30 gesehen haben war die gleiche das gleiche Handy wie das wir eine Stunde vorher woanders gesehen haben.
Und das Einzige das was wir jetzt mit dieser App bauen wollen diese Funktionalität die gibt es seit es das iPhone gibt.
Seit 2007 seit 13 Jahren. Und wenn Melanie Brinkmann meint Wir brauchen jetzt mal schnell diese App. Ja die gibts seit 13 Jahren.
Man könnte seit 13 Jahren das einfach so machen das Einzige was jetzt dazukommt ist eben dieser Privacy Charakter und da muss man halt sagen das ist halt wirklich super raffiniert weil wir jetzt eine App von der wir wirklich dachten das geht so weiter.
Jedes Handy speichert jedes andere Handy das es sieht so das du wirklich die soziale Landkarte der ganzen Welt einmal abbilden könntest.
Und das Nee nee mal schön dezentral und plötzlich stellt sich raus.
Also weit können wir es eigentlich treiben und jetzt tauchen wir wieder in die Diskussion ein die aktuell läuft.
Das ist ja Leo Laporte der beispielsweise mit Steve Gibson seit 31 Jahren diesen Security Lopatkas macht.
Und er hat noch einen anderen er nennt sich deswegen Google Jeff Jarvis dabei und ist so die stellen jetzt plötzlich fest Ach so.
So dreht sich die Diskussion und dann macht Stacey eine ganz interessante Feststellung.
Sein Bike.
Erbte Sainz.
Das einzige Feature was Apple und Google jetzt vorgestellt haben ist dass es jetzt auch mit Privacy geht damit die Akzeptanz steigt und so weiter und so fort.
Ja das heißt aber im Umkehrschluss Na ja das geht nicht nur mit einer App die vorbeugen soll dass man zu viele Coruna infizierte trifft sondern das kann auch bei all diesen anderen Apps so laufen.
Richtig.
Wir können es überall machen.
Navigationssystem Kontakt Telefonbücher.
Das muss ja alles nicht einmal eins zu eins gesendet werden. Google muss ja nicht die ganze Zeit mit speichern. Dieser Account hat weit über Google Maps diese Route abgefragt und ist dann in dieser Geschwindigkeit entlang gefahren.
Auch da hat Apple schon die Vorschläge gemacht mit dieser Differential Privacy. Man führt also sehr viel Zufalls Signale wieder mit rein in den kompletten Datensatz der sich danach nur statistisch wieder herausrechnen lässt.
Man hat nur noch die Weisheit der großen Zahlen aber nicht mehr herunterbrechen auf das Einzelne.
Und das finde ich so interessant dass wir eben jetzt so wie du auch gesagt sagt Das stimmt da gibts den Umkehrschluss Ja wir könnten ja das Ganze.
Also wir könnten sowieso dafür sorgen dass sehr viel mehr lokal stattfindet.
Gesichtserkennung auf dem iPhone findet lokal statt. Die Verarbeitung von Fingerabdruck auch bei Google sieht das anders aus.
Da findet die Gesichtserkennung auf dem Server statt Das Foto muss erst über Google Fotos hochgeladen werden und so weiter. Lässt sich alles auch ganz anders machen. Apple und Google.
Das große Zeitalter eigentlich für Apple die Arbeiten zwar jetzt geradezu zusammen aber es ist ja Apple.
Absolut.
Das Unternehmen das doch das auch in gewisser Weise als Unique Selling Point erkannt hat dass es auch wie,
WoW schreibt in ihrem großartigen Buch überwachungs Kapitalismus das Zeitalter des überwachungs Kapitalismus das Apple nicht zu dem überwachungs Kapitalismus,
zählt also dass es nicht ein Unternehmen ist das so einen Daten überschuss sammelt verkauft und so etwas damit macht sondern erst da drin lässt.
Und da könnte man ja eigentlich jetzt von Apple aus betrachtet nochmal ganz neu nachlegen und sagen hier wir haben hier gezeigt So geht das. Und das ist doch ganz großartig.
Und jetzt haben wir hier etwas gefunden wie wir mehr Datenschutz herstellen können Kommt doch rüber zu uns.
Microsoft hat dieser Tage also genau genommen heute die Quartalszahlen vom ersten Quartal vorgelegt und es stellt sich heraus dass Nadella auch der Chef.
Ja wir haben jetzt zwei Jahre Digitalisierung in zwei Monaten erlebt beispielsweise eine Verdopplung der Nutzungszeiten von Microsoft mit der Videokonferenz und Homeoffice Lösung.
Apple macht sich natürlich auch Gedanken weil ich habe ja auch schon gesagt meine Kinder,
nutzen ausschließlich Facetime weil ich weiß das wird dann lokal verschlüsselt und wird auch nicht transportiert und auch keiner rein und es ist ein sehr abgeschlossenes Ding da kann man sich ziemlich sicher sein da findet kein Bombing statt.
Da wird sich nicht jemand in der Konferenz sein wo er nicht hingehört. Sondern die haben das unter Kontrolle.
Und jetzt kommt Apple im April 2020 und sagt übrigens wenn ihr schon immer ein iPhone haben wollte sie haben jetzt für 400 Euro ab Werk also nicht mehr tausend sondern dieses neue iPhone kostet 400 Euro.
Da denken natürlich viele so drüber nach Wunsch hatten beispielsweise durch die Privacy Diskussion ein iPhone ab Werk für 400 Euro mit dem neuesten Chip der auch im tollen großen iPhone drin ist. Warum nicht.
Apple geht gerade ganz aggressiv in diese Richtung. Dieses Argument tatsächlich auszubeuten und alle Dokumente die ich zu diesem Exposés App gesehen habe die man alle von Apple gelabert dieses ganze,
Zeug wo erklärt wird wie das abläuft ist mega lang PDF Servo so richtig erklärt wird wie es funktioniert kommen alle von Apple kann man es nicht von Google sondern Google macht halt einfach nur mit.
So mein Eindruck aber das ist alles original Apple Zeug sondern das ist ja eine Diskussion ja dieses Privacy das wird jetzt nachträglich gebaut die Funktionalität die seit zehn Jahren geregelt.
Das war gar nicht das Problem. Das zweite ist da bringt sich auch Apple und Microsoft und Google wie sie alle heißen in so eine Stellung Wer kontrolliert eigentlich grundsätzlich die Funktionalität.
Wir haben es jetzt geschafft dass der Staat nicht den zentralen Server baut.
Also haben wir die Unternehmen mal kurz rein die diskutieren. ist ja auch immer sehr ausführlich das ist hier vom 17.
Vierten aber das zeigt die nächsten Monate wird das auch nochmal sehr bestimmen was die hier diskutieren.
Jenke.
Das wird in Westwall schon mal ein bisschen vorbereitet aber am Ende ist es irgendwo ein Zentralcomputer und derjenige der ihn noch kontrolliert der die Welt regiert und die Politiker gut finden Halt im Fernsehen,
werden hier nicht mehr viel zu melden haben wir sind da völlig raus und haben sich jetzt noch selber mehr ins Hintertreffen gebracht.
Durch diese Art der diskussionswürdige die sie hatten bei dieser Hinsicht wäre es eine wichtige Machtverschiebung Microsoft diese Aktien gehen jetzt einfach nach oben bei denen die die leiden nicht unter Corona sondern genau das Gegenteil.
Richtig ab jetzt kommt natürlich trotzdem gefahren denn man muss ja nicht in die Privacy Richtung gehen wenn die Funktionalität wie wir sie diskutieren weil es uns so sehr betrifft so sehr im Vordergrund steht und da hat die Stasi hier nochmal einen Gedanken und da denken wir wieder dran.
Das Arbeitsrecht hat sich bisher immer sehr schwergetan mit Datenschutz Grundsätzlich haben in Deutschland keinen beschäftigten Datenschutz obwohl er schon vor zwei Legislaturperioden mal hätte kommen sollen wir haben die allgemeine Datenschutz-Grundverordnung aber die gilt halt nicht am Arbeitsplatz.
Ein Arbeitsvertrag unterschrieben ist gelten andere Regeln und da kann man natürlich mal über so etwas nachdenken.
Erste Mal hieß.
Es
Da
Geht's mit den sechs CS in Sao,
Paulo.
Die Deutschen super Marktbetreiber sind in der Verantwortung dafür zu sorgen dass die Regeln eingehalten werden.
Die haben zum Beispiel die intrinsische Motivation Wir lassen hier keinen Diebstahl zu.
Also ist jede Ware gesichert zumindest die hochpreisiger und sobald man sie verlässt ohne bezahlt zu haben.
Die wollen natürlich auch nicht dass ihnen der Laden zugemacht wird weil die Leute da drin völlig durchdrehen könnte man sich vorstellen dass einfach jeder so ein kleines Umhänge denkt kommt am Eingang und das fängt an zu piepsen wenn der Abstand nicht eingehalten wird.
Das ist sozusagen freiwillig Man muss ja nicht einkaufen gehen Was ist aber tatsächlich am Arbeitsplatz.
Hier werden doch diese ganze AVV Möglichkeiten.
Menschen haben eine Karte in der Hosentasche weil sie damit ihr Mittagessen bezahlen.
Gleichzeitig registriert jeder Tyra mit dass sie da durchgehen das ist ja auch Realität in einigen Unternehmen.
Wir gehen auch für ein Panoptikum Zeitalter zu als wir es jetzt schon haben und ich glaube auch wir müssen darüber nachdenken diese ganze Biopolitik vonUnternehmen.
Die könnte jetzt auch nochmal Aufwind bekommen dadurch muss man dann jetzt sagen dem neuen Unternehmen bei dem man arbeitet das man schon covert hatte das man sich schon immunisiert hat.
Und wie schnell ist das auch ausgeweitet auf andere Infektionskrankheiten das man jetzt sagt na gut aber wir hätten da gerne noch ein paar Informationen.
Es gibt ja viele Dinge die man dem Arbeitgeber nicht sagen muss genauso muss man ja auch nicht.
Sagen dass man vorhat schwanger zu werden also muss man ja auch noch einmal ins Gedächtnis rufen das wird immer wieder mal versucht das Einstellungsgespräch und versucht wird rauszufinden möchte die Kandidatin vielleicht in naher Zukunft schwanger werden.
Das wird dann vielleicht nicht so ganz direkt gefragt und man sagt dann Ach und schon über Familie nachgedacht und so. Und damit möchte man das wissen.
Ja und jetzt ist eben diese große Frage wie das hier ausgeweitet wird das eben viel mehr bekannt wird dass man sagt wir müssen ja Risiken gering halten,
und deswegen haben wir dann eigentlich da eine sehr sehr ungute Konstellation und die andere Frage ist dann,
man kann ja sagen Ja gut aber so einen Schutz der Mitarbeiter hat ja auch was für sich.
Wir können dann auch wieder so diese Grundfrage stellen die wir schon bei diesem Risiko haben.
Gehen wir dann eher die Gefahr ein und müssen aber dann auch selbst.
Damit meine ich jetzt auch wir nicht nur der Arbeitgeber damit leben dass es dann vielleicht ein paar mehr covert Infizierte in kurzer Zeit gibt.
Dann kann man sagen Okay das ist der Preis den wir zu zahlen bereit sind ehe diese Rechte jetzt derart beschnitten werden.
Es ist genau die Unterscheidung die Luhmann so beeindruckt hat zwischen Risiko und Gefahr erdulden wir eine Gefahr gegen die wir nichts machen können.
Oder versuchen wir alles Menschenmögliche daraus ein Kontrollierbarkeit Risiko zu machen also auf eigene Entscheidung zurückzuführen.
Und die Frage die du stellt ist völlig berechtigt.
BWL mäßig geht man lieber dieses Risiko Schiene so und wenn man jetzt weiß Okay die durch Deutschland hat zu 20 Prozent stattgefunden.
Erlaubt man Kneipen aufmachen zu dürfen wenn sie das Risiko in Kauf nehmen.
Oder wenn Sie die Gefahr abwehren dass bei ihnen ein Infektionsherd stattfindet indem sie die Gefahr in ein Risiko umwandeln und sich einen Ausweis zeigen lassen in dem steht covert Veteran hat es schon durchgemacht.
Hier besteht keine Gefahr oder am Arbeitsplatz.
Wie groß wieviel ökonomischen Nutzen hab ich davon dass ich die allgemeine Gefahr.
Mein Unternehmen ist ein Infizierung Heerdt umwandeln in ein Risiko dass ich mich selbst darüber entscheiden kann.
Ich möchte wissen Wer hat denn hier wen infiziert. Deswegen hänge ich am Halsband um sodass ich in dem Moment wo klar wird Hier gibt's einen covert Fall nachvollziehen kann.
Wer hat denn hier die Grenzen überschritten. Wer hat denn die Regeln nicht eingehalten.
Weil das steht dann einfach im Lockvögel da kann man einfach nachgucken. Das war vor drei Tagen der Peter und wir hatten damals im Vergleich der Name des Unternehmens nicht ein,
Mitarbeiter von diesem amerikanischen Unternehmen gesprochen der hat E-Mail Auswertung gemacht wo seine Aufgabe war herauszufinden.
Wer hat denn hier gerade so Business laufen zu Ungunsten des Unternehmens.
Wer verkauft irgendwelche Materialien Wer klaut Klopapier und was nicht.
Es war ein Original so dass die sich den Datenschutz Amerika gibt's ja derart nicht von den Unternehmen alle E-Mails in zentralen E-Mail-Server einmal komplett kopiert haben.
Und dann haben die mit so Maschinenbauern Sachen dass einmal durchtrainiert was sie da für Fragestellungen hatten und am Ende vor Gericht gab es dann nicht mehr das Verhör im Sinne von.
Hören Sie mal Peter Was haben Sie denn da. Wieso haben Sie denn die Gießkanne immer geklaut und jeden Tag zehn verkauft was soll der Quatsch.
Sondern die Fragen der Anwälte des Unternehmens vor Gericht.
Wir haben gesehen dass sie Mitte April aufgehört haben freitags immer mit Peter essen zu gehen.
Wieso die nächste Frage.
Im März sind sie mittwochs immer eine Stunde zu spät auf Arbeit gewesen.
Wieso der Angeklagte fragt ich die ganze zeit Woher soll ich das wissen.
Wissen Sie mehr über mich als ich selber. Ich weiß nicht was ich im März immer mittwochs gemacht habe.
Und man fragt sich Was hat die Frage jetzt damit zu tun. Was hatten die Frageder als mitzutun.
Die Anwälte von der Gegenseite die wissen natürlich genau worauf Sie hinauswollen. Weil die wollen dass er schon mal bestätigt was sie später noch mit dem Datensatz untermauern können.
Aber nur sie kennen den Datensatz der Betroffenen nicht.
Der weiß also gar nicht welche Antwort bringe ich mich jetzt eigentlich nicht in die Bredouille.
Mit welcher klaren Antwort oder mit welcher zögern denn und so weiter. Und diese Verdrehung von Machtverhältnissen allein durch den Einsatz von Technologie.
Den sehen wir jetzt Gesellschaft weit. Wir haben jetzt diesen Weg hin zu Google und Apple.
Akzeptanz. Gerade das muss man wirklich sagen.
Auch in der breiten Bevölkerung sehe es auch mit Erschrecken bei vielen Freunden die sagen Na ja gut aber jetzt wollen wir nicht die vielleicht nicht ganz so sind,
wie das Interview das du aus dem Spiegel zitiert hast aber es gibt doch solche sehr sehr erschreckenden äußerungen schon dass man dann sagen Hey jetzt ist aber alles was irgendwie das Risiko,
klein hält was die Kurve flach hält ist auf jeden Fall gut und das müssen wir unterstützen.
Das ist eine ganz problematische Entwicklung hier würde ich wieder sagen Na ja nicht dass wir am Ende nochmal uns entschuldigen müssen alle bei Agamben und sagen Ja klar das war zwar nicht gesteuert von irgendwo,
aber dieses Dispositiv das ist ja ein Fukuoka Begriff.
Das hat sich eben breitgemacht dieses Biopolitik und das sorgte dann zu solchen Dingen.
Wir können auch mal darüber nachdenken wenn wir jetzt über diese digitale Auswertung wissen was das gerade mit dem E-Mail-Verkehr angesprochen.
Es ist ja vielen Arbeitnehmern gestattet private Korrespondenzen über Facebook oder E-Mail während der Arbeitszeit zu führen oder in der Mittagspause macht man das von dem Büro Laptop aus dann,
hat man ja nicht nochmal seinen privaten Laptop dabei.
Wie ist es denn damit wird dann da auch noch versucht das auszuweiten das man sagt Okay jetzt gucken wenn man nicht dass der sich heute Abend zum Grillen mit 20 Leuten verabredet und dann morgen wieder in die Firma kommt.
Da gibts ja auch skandalöse äußerungen von Unionspolitikern schon vor vielen Jahren Michael Fuchs von der Union aus Koblenz der hat ja da Auffassung vertreten da kann man eigentlich sagen Gut dann ist der,
Arbeitnehmer komplett ausgeliefert da kann er sich ganz nackt ausziehen und solche überlegungen werden alle kommen.
Bis jetzt waren es ja eher wie ich das so mitbekommen habe aus bekannten Kreise und Kreisen freundliche Hinweise von Arbeitgebern dass man sagte Bitte achten Sie auch privat darauf sich nicht mit vielen Leuten zu treffen und so weiter.
Da war noch nicht eine Regel formuliert die der Arbeitgeber auch jetzt noch nicht formulieren kann wenngleich sich da manche ja doch auch schon anders geäußert haben man muss ja auch mal an diesen Becca Busemann denken wie,
der dann auch so seinen Angestellten gegenüber sich verhält während er erst ein weihnachtliches Video macht.
Aber das ist wirklich etwas was wir jetzt in den nächsten Monaten ganz verschärft erleben werden und dann mehr glaube ich werden wir auch wenn wir dann noch kritische Geister bleiben wollen auch Abrücken von diesem,
Modus der die ganze Zeit nur darauf schaut wo sind die Regelverstöße.
Na ja genau. Und wie kann man ihnen schon vorbeugen.
Dieses Schreiben war wieder auf wenn du am Wochenende so getroffen hast. Ja wirklich soll ich das machen. Du weißt doch Kontakt Verfolgung damit wir es schneller haben.
Oder dass der Porsche-Chef sagt Ja oder Zugriff auf die Mitarbeiter beginnt jetzt morgens nach dem Aufstehen. Die sollen erst einmal Fieber messen.
Wir sagen Ihnen jetzt was sie in ihrem Badezimmer machen sollen und diese Akzeptanz wird natürlich umso mehr gesteigert umso mehr Erfolg verspricht.
Wenn Unternehmen durch solch eine Praxis wirklich Geld sparen wie zum Beispiel diese E-Mail Auswertung. Diese Typen suchen die sich auf Kosten des Unternehmens bereichern.
Umso mehr die damit Geld sparen umso höher ist die Akzeptanz in der Politik. Erleben wir genau das Gleiche.
Ja doch gut funktionieren. Die Akzeptanz steigt dann damit.
Wir haben eine Techno-Club eine Hinwendung zur Technologie die gleichzeitig immer attraktiver wird weil sie immer erfolgreicher wird.
Und jetzt ist der China Korrespondent vom ZDF bei Markus Lanz zugeschaltet und er redet ja mal zwei Minuten lang über zum einen.
Was macht China gerade. Und warum können sie es machen.
Was mich eigentlich am meisten Angst gemacht hat und das ist vielleicht auch ein Thema was die deutschen Zuschauer sehr interessiert ist,
mit welcher Lichtgeschwindigkeit allein in der Zeit in der wir da waren in den 100 Tagen der überwachungsstaat sichtbar geworden ist.
Es gibt in Wuhan aber jetzt auch in Peking in ganz China ein woran besonders für jede Bewegung die man machen will muss man quasi eine App runterladen wenn wir in unser Hotel wollten die ersten Tage ging das noch ohne.
Und auf einmal mussten wir eine App runterladen und dann hat man so einen Code gescannt und dann werden quasi so hab ich das erklärt Unsere Handydaten abgeglichen und es wird in Lichtgeschwindigkeit,
ein Bewegungsprofil erstellt wen man getroffen hat und wo man gewesen ist.
Und nur wenn dann dass dieser Code und diese App quasi ein grünes Signal gibt durften wir mehr oder weniger rein in unser Hotel.
Selbst bei banalen Dingen wo wir etwas einkaufen wollten.
Ich wollte mir ein Paar Sportschuhe kaufen. Da musste ich eine App runterladen um in diesen Laden überhaupt reinzukommen.
Und dies findet jetzt quasi unter dem Vorwand des Gesundheitsschutzes würde ich sagen,
findet die etwas statt was sowieso schon sehr massiv beim chinesischen Staat vorhanden ist eigentlich die Totalüberwachung über das Handy der Leute man wollte das sowieso einführen.
Der chinesische Staat dieses Jahr mit einem sogenannten sozialen Benimm Kodex den man einführt und dann nutzt man natürlich auch diese Gesundheits Angst der Leute um diese Macy überwachung stattfinden zu lassen.
Vielleicht auch eine Sache die ich sehr sehr faszinierend fand.
Die meisten Chinesen mit denen wir gesprochen haben finden das super finden das wunderbar.
Die Angst die sie vor einer neuen Infektionsquelle haben ist so groß und die wird auch staatlich gelenkt dass sie eigentlich keine,
Einschränkung ihrer Freiheit sehen oder ihre Freiheitsrechte abgeben sondern sie sehen die Freigabe der Daten eigentlich etwas was positiv ist weil das sie schützt.
Das ist eins zu eins das was man im Spiegel gesagt hat aber eben nicht in China sondern hier.
Wir fragen uns dann eigentlich mit Stefan Zweifel werden wir chinesisch.
Werden wir Chinesisch. Da stecken einfach große Gefahren drin weil diese Technologisierung Technisierung so erfolgreich ist,
wird sie so viel Akzeptanz mitbringen und sich dann dagegen kann natürlich sehr froh sein dass sie den ersten großen drey den Apple Google jetzt gemacht haben Privé Sie ist.
Aber der Dreh war da wirklich nur gemacht weil nicht mal die sich zutrauen ein zentrales Datenlecks zu bauen.
Das muss nicht bei allen anderen Fragen die jetzt noch anstehen genau so sein.
Es wäre genauso gut möglich dass die Unternehmen sagen Das können wir Ihnen gerne bauen das kriegen wir auch abgesichert.
Und zack geht's in die andere Richtung als die Privacy Richtung Privacy die ist jetzt aus Verlegenheit gemacht worden das muss man ganz deutlich sagen.
Aber sie ist natürlich trotzdem technisch erst einmal perfekt wie sie sagte.
Und da wir beide da nicht reingucken können würde ich mich erst mal anschließen.
Der Typ lag doch bisher zumindest in meiner Wahrnehmung immer ganz gut bei solchen Einschätzungen dann behandeln wir noch schnell die maskenhaft nur weil ich die Diskussion so albern finde denn es ist auch interessant finde ich wie auf der einen Seite die Technologie.
So drückt und so raffiniert ist dass wir alle sagen Wir sind beeindruckt davon was so geht aber wir können es nicht alle nicht verstehen.
Bei den Massen ist das natürlich ganz anders denn wir halten uns vor den Mund pusten und Steinfest jaja die Luftfahrt da abgelenkt oh Wunder. Komplizierter wird es nicht.
Sozusagen die ganze Raffinesse in diesem Ding. Man kann natürlich noch irgendwelche Nanometer großen Löcher nachmessen oder so.
Aber die Luft wird abgelenkt und damit auch die Viren die in dieser Luft drin sind.
Und dass wir so eine zähe Diskussion haben jetzt immer noch nicht so eine richtige Markenpflege in Berlin kann man auch ohne Maske einkaufen gehen.
Unglaublich finde ich aber gut so wird es dann halt gemacht nur ein paar kleine O-Töne Drosten.
Das finde ich so bezeichnend dass es jetzt auch schon eine Weile her dass es ein 28 Podcaster ist ja auch schon ein bisschen drüber.
Was die Zahlen angeht so ist es schon drei vier Wochen ist es jetzt her Drosten zum Thema Masken referiert ja mal aus dieser Studie.
Da waren elf Patienten die Waren Coruna infiziert und hatten eine Maske auf.
Bei keinem dieser elf Patienten konnte aus dem Gerät später so ein Virus noch nachgewiesen werden.
Weder über 500 Mikrometer Tröpfchen Größe noch unter fünf Mikrometer auch nach 30 Minuten nicht mehr summiert über die gesamten 30 Minuten also man hat 30 Minuten alles eingesammelt und in ein Töpfchen getan was man ansaugen konnte,
und in der anderen Gruppe wo ebenfalls 30 Minuten gesammelt wurde.
Aber wo keine Maske getragen wurde da waren es zehn Patienten und bei diesen zehn Patienten hat man in beiden Größen Dimensionen der Tröpfchen Virus gefunden in einem Fall 3 und im anderen Fall vier Patienten. Der Unterschied ist nicht relevant.
Hier ging es darum andere Corona Viren die mit Schnupfen zu tun haben aber die sind von der Größe und von der Art der Oberfläche absolut vergleichbar mit den aktuellen die uns so beschäftigen Crooner Viren,
und wie solche Wissenschaft gemacht werden kann ohne dass jeder Politiker sofort am nächsten Tag sagt Leute die Masken sind irgendwie,
Wir könnten da 30 Minuten lang nichts nachweisen und die Menschen gesprochen und gesprochen uns war kein einziger Tropfen auffindbar.
Dass man immer noch so rum.
Leider können wir es ja nicht verordnen wenn wir sie nicht gleichzeitig zur Verfügung stellen können.
Nee da muss man jetzt einen anderen schnelleren Weg. Irgendwie haltet euch irgendwas vor den Mund. Die Masken werden schon irgendwann kommen mehr.
Aber wie kann das sein dass dann doch solche Erkenntnisse so lange gebraucht haben bis sie dann auch in den Virologen Podcasts angekommen sind.
Oder ich erinnere mich auch an Aussagen von Lauterbach der inzwischen ja für die Maske ist dass er sagte Das sind ja Viren schleudern möglicherweise sogar und das ist ja auch erst einmal etwas was sich dann in einem festsetzt.
Jetzt weiß ich dass empirische Wissenschaft damit auch arbeitet was sie neue Erkenntnisse sammelt und dann den Kurs justiert neu justiert.
Aber es ist doch erstaunlich bei so etwas ganz profanen würde ich mal sagen Es gibt ja doch wahrscheinlich wesentlich komplexere Fragen hinsichtlich Covic 19 als diese Masken Frage.
Dass da auch die Virologie offenbar so lange uneins war oder zum Teil ja auch ganz vehement davon überzeugt.
Nein auf keinen Fall Masken.
Alles lächerlich. Ich erinnere mich auch das muss ich jetzt mal sagen um dem auch Luft zu machen und mir da auch Luft zu machen das bei Twitter mir viele Leute die inzwischen alle ihr Maske auf Foto haben und ihren Namen auch mit Maske auf und was weiß ich geändert haben,
im Februar noch täglich auf Twitter verkündeten wie idiotisch Menschen sind die Masken bestellen.
Statt bei mir. Ich habe ja auch Marietta Slomka geglaubt als sie sich darüber lustig machte.
Sie hat eine Halbsatz Moderation gehabt und dass jetzt jeder glaubt sie könne sich mit der Maske auf der Straße schützen während sie im Krankenhaus fehlen scheint ja nicht der richtige Weg zu sein.
Aber stellt sich heraus nee da wurden wir doch alle neu belehrt.
Allerdings Es gab halt.
Es gab natürlich die Forschung zu diesen Massen die nun nicht auf selbst Infektionen sondern wirklich auf.
Vor mir habe ich so ein Operationsfeld und das ist einfach ungeschützt. Da ist der Körper aufgeschnitten.
Und dann nützt ja diese Maske anscheinend was sonst hätte man sie nicht auch sonst hätten da alle auch diese etwas festeren Masken auf oder vielleicht sogar richtig mit Filtern. Da scheint dieser Feldt tatsächlich zu helfen.
Aber es gab eben noch keine richtige Forschung zur Alltagswissen weil die Frage ist Hat sich Jenny gestellt.
Aber jetzt ist sie halt mit dieser Pandemie plötzlich da. Wie sicher ist eigentlich ein Fußball Schal der seit 20 Jahren im Schrank liegt.
Der Bürgermeister von Frankfurt Peter Feldmann hat sich mit seinem Frankfurter Schal den er als 15-Jähriger geschenkt gekriegt hat fotografieren lassen um zu zeigen Das funktioniert auch in der Straßenbahn.
Es ist sozusagen eine neue Forschungsfrage. Sie ist nicht besonders raffiniert aber sie ist wahnsinnig neu.
Und dann gibt es auch ärzte die sich wirklich schwer überzeugen lassen wir hören ihr mal diesen Montgomerie Frank Montgomery der,
Vorstandschef der ärztevereinigung weltweit ist irgendwie sowas der im Deutschlandfunk ein sehr streitbarer Interview zu geben das aus doppeltem gründen streitbar ist nämlich nicht nur aus diesem Club.
Gucken Sie sich mal beim Robert-Koch-Institut die Hinweise zum Anlegen und Abnehmen einer Maske an.
Das ist ein hochkomplexer Vorgang wenn sie nicht selber dabei Gefahr laufen wollen sich ebenfalls zu infizieren. Das ist nicht einfach nur so ein Schamlippen vor dem Gesicht den man so tut wie manche Politiker das darstellen.
Und deswegen ärgere ich mich darüber wenn man uns gesetzlich verpflichten will etwas zu tun was wissenschaftlicher Unsinn ist.
Er ist noch nicht wissenschaftlich aufgeklärt denn diese Aussage war einfach falsch.
Aber ist es nicht so dass es tatsächlich schwierig ist dieses Maske auf und absetzen.
Man beobachtet ja Leute beim Supermarkt. Die setzen die Maske auch mal auf die eine oder andere Weise auf die eine mal die andere sei so hoch und dann wird die nochmal schnell umgedreht da denke ich gut.
Aber,
aber genau das ist ja Kekulé hat er sehr gute Aufklärungsarbeit geleistet finde ich immer wieder diese Anrufe.
Was ist denn jetzt wenn jemand die Türklinke angefasst hat und so weiter oder die Fensterscheibe oder irgendwie die Kinder sich so verhalten.
Mein Kekulé immer die Viren auch wenn die irgendwo sind die werden sie nicht anspringen wenn ich auf der Oberfläche sind bleiben die auf der Oberfläche und mit der Maske ist ja so Jeder soll sich den anderen schützen.
Das heißt wenn man davon ausgeht dass man selbst covert hat und man pustet auch nur zehn Minuten in die Maske ist diese Maske verseucht.
Wenn ich jetzt aus dem Supermarkt rausgehe und ich nehme die Maske ab dann kann ich natürlich noch mal komplett drüber streichen weil dann hab ich die Viren alle in der Hand stecke ich in meiner Hosentasche und dann wird es da schön warm und nicht besonders schnell trocken. Also vermehren die sich auch nochmal.
Nur diese ganzen Szenarien. Ich bin ja jetzt schon infiziert und ich krieg auch nicht nochmal eine Infektion durch Viren.
Aber ich habe trotzdem in dem Moment wo ich im Laden geatmet habe haben diese Viren niemanden erreicht Sie sind der Maske kleben geblieben.
Deswegen finde ich dieses Argument aber eine kontaminierte Maske abzusetzen ist super schwer.
Ja das gilt für die Viren lasst jemals anderen den ich.
Unterminierung von außen kommt die.
Genau. Aber es ist ja genau nicht das Problem das hier zu lösen ist sondern man soll ja davon ausgehen dass man selbst kontaminiert ist und nur die anderen schützt.
Ich fand es besonders bezeichnend dass sich alle über diesen Montgomerie Club aufgeregt haben wo ich finde der nächste Montgomerie Club aus dem gleichen Gespräch da ist eigentlich noch viel skandalöser denn jetzt widerspricht er sich komplett.
Zum einen hat er eben gesagt Wozu soll ich eine Pflicht haben für so eine Maske die nichts bringt.
Dann wurde eben so berichtet Montgomerie es gegen Massenflucht und hält das für blöd. Aber jetzt vergleichen wir das mal mit dieser zweiten Aussage.
Wenn sie mit ihren Kollegen telefonieren diskutieren wie auch immer sagen Sie denen dann ganz klar Sie sind seit Jahrzehnten auf dem Holzweg.
Nein wir sind nicht auf dem Holzweg. Erstens haben sie funktionierende Masken zweitens haben sie dort eine gesellschaftlich ganz andere Einstellung.
Dort machen sie das ja nicht um sich selbst zu schützen sondern um andere zu schützen. Schon bei einer ganz banalen Erkältung und schließlich Mir geht es um die gesetzliche Masken Pflicht für eine nicht funktionierende Maske.
Hätten wir alle funktionierende Masken dann fände ich es sogar vernünftig uns zu verpflichten sie immer zu tragen wenn wir uns draußen bewegen.
Jetzt ist er plötzlich für eine Massenflucht sogar unter freiem Himmel.
Was nun wirklich Quatsch ist weil die Viren stehen nicht wie Zigarettenrauch in der Luft sondern die Fallen wirklich rapide runter und die paar die stehen bleiben okay.
Das Risiko aber ist für eine Masken Pflicht außer Haus aber eben die richtigen Masken GP2 von denen auch Drosten schon gesagt hat.
Naja wenn man die aufsetzt muss man erst eine gesundheitliche Untersuchung machen weil das Arbeitsrecht vorschreibt.
Also wenn ich so eine Maske aufsetzt die dich so am Atmen hindern soll dann dann genau das ist ein Sportswear.
Dann werden sich meine Zigaretten bemerkbar machen die ich momentan.
Das ist dann grundsätzlich Sport da kommt die Lunge dann richtig. Da muss ich dann richtig.
Sagen wir mal so wie vor Wochen da musst du wieder bewusst atmen das kannst du dann nicht so nebenbei machen sondern muss,
durch die Maske ziehen und da ist Montgomerie dann dafür dass wir,
auch älteren Menschen und so weiter die das nicht aushalten weil die sowieso schon mit einer Kamera sich nur zu Reeve schleppen und denen dann noch seine Atmung hinter der Maske aufzusetzen da ist er dann dafür,
da muss man sich echt sagen Liebe Leute was ist da los.
Zwei kleine Kekulé Clips zum Thema Masken auch weil ich das wirklich gut finde.
Zum einen der Look down hat viel gebracht aber hat auch keine Ausrottung des Virus gebracht. Wie kam das eigentlich.
Wir sind mit diesem massiven lock down nach den Zahlen die jetzt vorliegen die aber den Zustand von vor 14 Tagen wiedergeben.
Sind wir nicht so weit gekommen wie es eigentlich erhofft gewesen wäre.
Ehrlich gesagt ist mein Verdacht dass man das ist eine gute Idee gewesen wäre diese Masken früher einzuführen die einfachen Gesichtsmasken,
in Alltagssituationen wenn man im Geschäft oder im öffentlichen Verkehr ist und sich in geschlossenen Räumen befindet und die zwei Meter Abstände nicht einhalten kann.
Ich glaube da wäre es eine gute Idee gewesen das früher einzuführen weil das natürlich einen zusätzlichen Effekt gegeben hätte.
Die Masken haben eventuell gefehlt. Er formuliert es vorsichtig Ich bin ja kein Virologe Ich kann einfach eine These raushauen aber wir hatten loggt hauen ohne Masken.
In Taiwan haben sie Masken aber kein Look down nicht mal Social dispensieren.
Und ich finde auch wenn die Kausalität und Korrelation ja immer auseinanderklaffen kann aber ich sehe hier Eindeutigkeit irgendwie,
diese Masken scheinen unglaublich viel zu bringen im Vergleich zu allem anderen was wir so versuchen. Und deswegen finde ich das immer.
Wir haben es im März schon angesprochen. Sind wir immer noch in dieser Situation dass wir nicht wissen wo wir unsere schönen Filz Masken haben während gleichzeitig echt gute Sprüche gemacht werden.
Hier der letzte Kekulé wirklich sehr gut.
Ich würde es fast so formulieren Das ist der Preis für unsere Freiheit. Wir müssen ja irgendwie.
Wir können nicht einfach weitermachen wie vorher. Wir wollen aber unsere Freiheit zurück haben wirtschaftlich und sozial.
Und der Preis den wir zahlen müssen ist eigentlich an mehreren Stellen und einer davon ist das mit der Maske.
Die Maske ist der Preis für unsere Freiheit und umso länger wir das machen umso mehr Wissenschaft wird es geben die das bestätigt.
Ja es ist der Regenschirm Es ist der Gurt Es ist das anders wir uns auch schon bei anderen Dingen daran gewöhnt haben.
Ich glaube nicht dass wir dauerhaft Masken tragen werden. Wir werden nicht in drei vier Jahren ständig laufend mit Masken irgendwo unterwegs sein.
Ich möchte auch nicht eine Fahrt von fünf Stunden hinlegen mit Maske.
Das glaube ich ist nicht besonders angenehm.
Ich bin sehr gespannt ob sich dann solche dionysischen Ereignisse noch einmal ergeben werden bei denen man ja auch keine Maske tragen wird weil dann ist das Dionysische nicht möglich also Rammstein Konzert mit Maske Stephan Da sehe ich dich dann auch nicht.
Das ist aber eine Frage die jetzt noch sehr sehr in weiter Zukunft liegt die man sich jetzt nicht stellen kann.
Und ich finde es deshalb auch so erstaunlich dass diese Maske doch so einen großen Streit entzündet beim Menschen dass sie.
Sich in ihrer Freiheit so besonders eingeschränkt fühlen während sie absolut akzeptiert haben dass Konzerne sie laufend überwachen.
Snowden hat sie nicht interessiert Assange hat sie nicht interessiert.
Es interessiert sie auch nicht was eigentlich mit diesen ganzen Gesundheitsdaten passiert und sie tragen dann eben auch diese smarten Uhren.
Und sie haben sich auch nicht damit beschäftigt was Jens Spahn mit der Patienten mit der digitalen sofort hat.
All das interessiert sie überhaupt nicht und auch sonst halten sie sich brav an alle Regeln und verpetzen jeden der bei Rot über die Ampel spaziert.
Auch wenn kein Auto in Sicht ist.
Jetzt aber sind sie da an ihrer Ehre irgendwie gekratzt wenn sie das jetzt machen müssen.
Das ist ganz erstaunlich dass das so ein Feigenblatt der Empörung eigentlich ist.
Und die großen Empörung haben nicht stattgefunden bei den eigentlichen Ereignissen da hat man das alles immer so durchgewunken und akzeptiert.
Ja das ist das Paradox glaube ich das was am wenigsten invasiv ist aber am sichtbarsten wird abgeblockt und das was völlig unsichtbar ist aber krass invasiver bis hin zur durchkalkuliert ganzer Biografien,
über Verhalten das angreifbar ist.
Keine Ahnung. Da scheint mir das Bewusstsein außer man sieht halt eine Maske und da kommt unser Bewusstsein in Fahrt und zack.
Stelle mir vor wir würden die ganze digitale überwachung sichtbar machen können denn den Daten chatten. Man spricht also vom Datenschutz.
War toll.
Was man so einfach als sowie Camara die Nummer zwei das digitale Ich der Hofstadter genannt irgendwas mit Zombie der virtuelle Zombie oder sowas.
Wenn man die Begleitungen tatsächlich immer bei sich trüge wenn die übereignen begleiten würde so ein Meter hinter einem läuft immer so das digitale Ich an.
Aber die Masken sind sichtbar und deswegen ein großer Streit so bevor ich dann gleich über Einsamkeit und Sterben reden kannst du uns noch mit einem Thema auflockern.
Ja und zwar mit Google Exotik. Das ist ein Phänomen ein Phänomen das es eigentlich schon ganz lange gibt aber jetzt ist es wirklich ein globales Phänomen.
Wer ist dieser Jovan.
Viele die uns zuhören werden ihn kennen denn er hat jetzt eine Berühmtheit erlangt durch eine Netflix Doku-Serie,
vielleicht einmal ganz schnell ein paar Zahlen zu Netflix im ersten Quartal da hatte man gerechnet dass man sieben Millionen neue Abonnenten bekommen wird.
Vor Corona hat man eine solche Prognose herausgegeben.
Es sind dann doch ein paar mehr sind fünf und zehn komma acht Millionen neue Abonnenten und jetzt hat Netflix insgesamt zwei und achtzig komma neun Millionen Abonnenten.
Der Umsatz gegenüber dem Vorjahr im Quartal ist dann auch um 28 Prozent gestiegen.
Man hat zwar immer noch vier und zehn komma eins Milliarden Schulden aber die Wachstumsprognosen sind ja doch sehr schön.
Netflix Aktie hat übrigens gar nicht so toll darauf reagiert.
Man hat dann gesagt Na ja wir haben sogar mehr als doppelt so viele Abonnenten als ursprünglich gedacht. Aber offenbar haben die Aktionäre das schon eingepreist gehabt.
Das erlebt man ja immer wieder an der Börse dass eine Gewinnerwartung sogar übertroffen wird und man sagt ja ja haben wir damit gerechnet.
Und da hat die Aktie jetzt nicht nochmal einen neuen Höhenflug bekommen aber sie ist ja konstant sehr weit oben.
Und sicherlich wird auch diese Serie Taiga King heißt die Serie dazu beigetragen haben dass Netflix jetzt viele neue Abonnenten hat und viele jetzt auch dabeibleiben werden.
Also wer ist dieser Joe. Exotik Exotik ist jemand der einen privat Zoo in Oklahoma betrieben hat Josef schrieb Vogel heißt er eigentlich.
Echt oder was. Ich hab noch nichts davon gehört.
Es ist eine Doku-Serie. Aber Donald Trump hat wie wir gleich merken werden schon was von jener Exotik gehört und dieser Exotik hatte einen Privatauto dazu muss man wissen.
Weltweit leben etwa 4000 Tiger in freier Wildbahn.
In den USA aber sind doppelt so viele Tiger wie in freier Wildbahn leben eingesperrt.
Denn da sind privat Zoos beliebt. Du kennst ja auch das aus Hip-Hop Videos dass man sich damit Tigern Löwen und so weiter schmückt Geparden.
Und eigentlich wollten die Dokumentarfilmer dieses Thema Tierschutz und alles aufnehmen und wollten dann diesen sehr illustren Joo Exotik porträtieren.
Aber das Ganze entwickelte sich noch sehr viel anders als gedacht.
2001 hat er diesen Zoo gegründet 2003 hat er dann angefangen mit der Züchtung erst hat er mal nur so Wildkatzen und sowas aufgenommen.
Und er hat dann auch gemerkt Na vor allem Tiger Babys gehen sehr gut aber die können nur so zwischen vier und zwölf Wochen alt sein dass man die streicheln kann sonst wirds eben zu gefährlich.
Und dann hat er das immer weiter ausgeweitet Er hatte dann mehr als hundert Tiere dann nachher aber 2003 gab es dann auch schon etwas nämlich eine Rivalen Carol Baskisch.
Das ist die zweite Protagonistin in dieser Doku-Reihe.
Die hat auch eine große Tier Farm Sie will das natürlich nicht so nennen.
Sie behandelt die Tiere viel besser sagt sie sie züchtet auch nicht beziehungsweise sie hat früher mal gezüchtet tut es jetzt nicht mehr und steht PETA und anderen Tierschutzorganisationen nah.
Und die hat einen Streit angefangen mit oder die haben untereinander sich angefangen zu bekriegen Man weiß gar nicht mehr wer da der Aggressor war und das ging immer und immer weiter über die Jahre und zwar ausgetragen in den sozialen Medien.
Also Kalebassen war ganz aktiv auf Facebook beispielsweise.
Exotik hat schon in den Nullerjahren angefangen Live-Streams von seinem Zoo von seinem Büro von überall aus machen sich rund um die Uhr filmen lassen erstellt dann auch sehr viel Archivmaterial zur Verfügung gestellt worden.
Zumindest das Material was nicht verbrannt ist es gab da auch einen Brand wo man auch denkt Na ja das könnte auch Brandstiftung gewesen sein.
Na ja und das war eigentlich schon eine ganz frühe Form von dem was wir heute erleben diesen viral ausgetragenen BIW.
Also wer hier wen und wir wissen dass solche Toys Video Videos bei Peterson oder so konnte man das ja auch erleben.
Enorm viele Klicks produzieren dass die Aufmerksamkeit mit jedem Eskalationsstufen erklommen wird steigt und das haben die eigentlich schon sehr früh exerziert das wurde dann auch zum Teil in regionale Fernsehsender ausgespielt.
Exotik wurde laufend interviewt er hat dann noch ein großes.
Vorbild bei dem ganzen Dok Anteil der hat einen noch viel größeren Zoo und dieser Dokumente der hat.
Buddhastatuen in seinem Garten in seinem großen Landgut stehen,
junge Frauen die er gerne hat wenn sie jungfräulich zu ihm kommen dass sie die erste Nacht mit ihm erleben und dann verehren sie ihn Guru Haft und sprechen ihn mit Mein Meister an.
Und sie leben in so einer merkwürdigen Kommune deren Oberhaupt er ist.
Nun muss ich dir sagen der Terrorexperte könnte jetzt so der klassische Billy sein.
Ist er zum einen auch ein Waffennarr.
Er ist immer mit der Pistole am Halfter unterwegs zugleich aber ist Exotik schwul macht das auch ganz ganz explizit dass er quasi der schwule Cowboy ist.
Und er hat immer Beziehungen gehabt mit mehreren Männern mit jungen Männern,
mit heterosexuellen Männern sehr viele also irgendwelche Zwanzigjährigen die er aufgegabelt hat denen er dann sagte Na ja du kannst aber bei mir leben und Drogen kriegste auch wenn du welche brauchst und so.
Und er hat dann mehrmals geheiratet hat auch Ehen zu dritt geführt.
Man könnte auch sagen hier ein sehr postmoderner Lebensentwurf und Disagio Exotik wurde also schon früh ein Phänomen und das ging dann immer weiter.
Auch diese Hochzeiten wurden dann inszeniert er hat CD's,
eingesungen und immer angriffslustiger wurde aber gegenüber Carrel Basken Auch wird gemutmaßt von ihm dass Carel Basken ihren zweiten Ehemann hat von Tigern fressen lassen damit sie an das Erbe kommt.
Auch das ist etwas was dieser Do&Co in einem in einer Folge dann unglaublich aus badet ausbreitet wie das dann gewesen sein könnte.
2016 kandidierte dann Joe Exotik als freier Präsidentschaftskandidat gegen Clinton und Trump.
Und wir hören vielleicht erst einmal um mal so einen Eindruck zu bekommen für die die noch gar nicht erlebt haben mal in eine kleine Passage rein wie er sich so überhaupt äußert.
Wir hören mal ein was er über Carel Basken zu sagen hat.
Aber wieso ist er nicht Präsident geworden. Es ist ja der gleiche wie Trump mit Rosie O'Donnell.
Ganz ganz wunderbar dass du das sagst und wir können noch den zweiten Clip über Basken.
Denn es hat sehr etwas davon dass wir eigentlich hier so einen Präsidenten haben aber wir haben noch den zweiten Clip.
Dass schon Zivilisation am Limit.
Americans da sind sie wieder.
Wir haben hier selbstverständlich ein Pesce Figur und wir haben hier eine Figur die Verschwörungstheorien verbreitet die Fake News verbreitet.
Wir haben aber auch eine Rivalen Carel Basken die auch überhaupt nicht sympathisch rüberkommen. Der man auch nicht über den Weg traut die eine unglaubliche Arroganz ausstrahlt die jetzt auch entsprechend gehasst wird im Internet.
Also Carel fucking Basken gibt's ohne Ende.
Selbstverständlich hat sich da jetzt auch diese ganze Old Rite Bewegung angeschlossen.
Da passiert bei ratet und bei all diesen Foren Unglaubliches.
Beide sind jetzt zu den wahrscheinlich am meisten verbreitetsten Miriams geworden.
In dem Monat April und.
Komme aber beide gleichrangig vor oder ist es.
Exotik ist sicherlich noch etwas dominanter aber Carel Basken als ewige Rivalen vor allem auch deshalb weil jede Exotik inzwischen im Gefängnis sitzt.
Denn er soll einen Auftragskiller angeheuert haben der Schluss machen sollte mit Carel Basken und deswegen ist er jetzt gerade verurteilt zu 22 Jahren Haft.
Und noch ist ungewiss wie das Ganze ausgeht.
Wir hören dann auch immer wieder Anrufe aus dem Gefängnis in der Doku und er lässt sich auch für irgendwelche Sendungen immer wieder mal zuschalten und brüllt dann ins Publikum ins Telefon.
Wie das alles war und dass oder wieso er glaubt gewesen zu sein scheint und das ist alles so absurd.
Wir hören noch kurz in das Election Video rein von Joe Exotik um einen Eindruck zu bekommen wie es hätte mit ihm werden können.
Du kennst doch bestimmt auch Logan Paul. Diese beiden YouTube Brüder die jeder für sich irgendwie vor 20 Millionen Leuten da auch so das eine oder andere. Ich hab mir die ganze Hechingen gefragt.
Im Grunde sind das ja die beiden YouTuber für das Trump Zeitalter. Man sieht nur noch über die Stränge schlagen nur noch Blödheit nur noch bescheuert aber gut abgefilmt und relativ schnittig gemacht.
Und vielleicht ist das die Antwort von Netflix auf diese Entwicklung.
Genau also Netflix geht ja ganz auf diesen Hype drauf sie haben dann sogar noch mal was sie ja sonst auch nicht so machen ganz schnell was nach produziert wird.
Und dann hat man jetzt noch einen achten Teil gemacht. Dort wird einfach nur mit einem Moderator Nochmal Der eine oder andere zugeschaltet der Protagonist oder Nebendarsteller dieser Sendung dann auch wahr.
Und die dürfen sich ja nochmal äußern Busquin ist nicht dabei und jede Exotik auch nicht.
Aber dann andere äußern sich dann schon dazu wie jede Exotik war und wie sich das wohl alles entwickeln wird.
Inzwischen ist es so dass wir es hier auch mit einem viralen Phänomen zu tun haben.
Das ist wirklich etwas was sich extrem verbreitet hat in den letzten Wochen,
so sehr dass sogar Donald Trump Junior darauf in einem Podcast angesprochen wurde und einmal kurz darin denn er steht natürlich da vielleicht eher auf der Seite.
Kein Chronist darf Grey Justins Joey Salk.
Nur mal kurz angemerkt Am Anfang das wird gerade untergebuttert unter diesen Corona Stress was eigentlich.
Vielleicht humoristisch sein Podcast von Comedians.
Aber man hat mitunter den Eindruck dass das jetzt fast wichtiger ist hat Carrel Baskisch.
Das wäre ja vor fast 20 Jahren gewesen ihren Mann von Tigern fressen lassen oder ist er einfach so verschwunden abgehauen Man weiß es nicht.
Coruna.
Über Presidential Pfaden.
Unglaublich.
Meisinger.
Rising.
Nennen.
Die.
Neue.
Ja es ist unglaublich Man muss aber sagen dass diese Netflix Doku Genau das aber auch befeuert hat.
Es ist keineswegs so dass man jetzt einfach nur jemand hat der ein bisschen weiter spekuliert hier in seinem ganzen Wahnsinn den wir jetzt auch nicht schmälern wollen.
Aber es ist auch so dass die Netflix Doku einfach mal so durchexerziert Wie könnte das dann gewesen sein wenn die wirklich da an die Tiger verfüttert hat,
und Unschuldsvermutung und auch einen gewissen Respekt vor der Person und auch davor dass eben Gerüchte oder die Polizei Dinge nicht klären konnte.
Hat diese Doku auch nicht das heißt sie ist schon darauf angelegt dass das Ganze eben in einem solchen Maße eskaliert ist es also hoch fahrlässig eigentlich sowas zu produzieren.
Und doch ist es eben auch etwas was,
gerade durch diese Eskalation überhaupt erst eine Aufmerksamkeit erregt denn wenn man das jemand erzählt da gibts jemand der es ein bisschen exzentrisch der hatten privat so und er hat immer wieder wechselnde Männer und,
ist auch libertär drauf.
Das ist aber erst mal nicht so interessant Man sieht aber auch dass diese,
Filmemacher offenbar erkannt haben dass es hier darum geht dass es immer noch eine Steigerung von Verrücktheit geht übrigens auch bei Carol Busquin Sie ist mit 17 verheiratet.
Will sich dann von ihrem Mann trennen läuft einsam nachts eine Straße entlang weinend dann hält ein Mann der mehr als doppelt so alt ist an und sagt Fahr doch mit.
Und dann sagt sie nein und dann kommt er nochmal wieder und sagt Fahr doch mit Guck mal ich habe hier auf dem Beifahrersitz eine Pistole liegen die ist geladen die kannst du einfach in die Hand nehmen und auf mich richten. Dann bist du sicher.
Und was würden wir jetzt tun wir würden natürlich beide Beine in die Hand nehmen und wegrennen. Nein Karl sagt Ja und dann habe ich mich sicher gefühlt und bin eingestiegen.
Du hast alle drei Minuten solche Episoden dass du sagst ist das Amerika ist das unsere neue Wirklichkeit mit der wir konfrontiert sein müssen.
Ist das vielleicht eine wirkliche zivilisatorische Entwicklung zurück.
Du hast ja schon gesprochen mit Blick auf Großbritannien. Wie modern ist denn eigentlich so ein Land noch.
Wie modern ist eigentlich hier so ein Land das dann eben nicht nur der Thompson sich dazu äußert sondern jetzt geht es noch eine Stufe weiter.
Ein Journalist hat es mal wieder um die Lage.
Wir bleiben kurz bei dieser Szene weil Modernität drückt sich ja auch dadurch aus wie die funktionale Differenzierung funktioniert also schafft es ein Rechtssystemen sich zu bewähren und zu Urteilen zu kommen die dann auch befolgt,
und akzeptiert werden unabhängig davon was im Fernsehen darüber berichtet wird.
Und wenn dann Junior irgendwie meint Ja ich habe eigentlich Moeglichkeit ins Rechtssystem so rein zuarbeitet Ich müsste nur zu meinem Vater ins Büro gehen und sagen aufgrund der Mimo in den Massenmedien könnten wir ja eigentlich die,
Urteilskraft des Gerichts anzweifeln.
Und dann diese Geschichte dass sie über die Straße läuft und ihr dieser Mann im Auto anbietet.
Also ich weiß dass es hier gerade grenzwertig und so weiter und wir müssen das unter uns klären ob du mir vertraust aber ich gebe dir hier die Möglichkeit zur Selbstjustiz als ob damit das Problem gelöst wäre.
Weil selbst wenn er übergriffig wird und sie erschießt ihn.
Ist ja damit nicht die Situation im Sinne von ok jeder übergriff fand nicht statt sondern dann ist es eine Tötung die ich dann auch wieder zivilisatorisch nachgab.
Da blendet man auch diese moderne funktional differenzierte einfach mal aus und sagt Das können wir aus der Situation lösen.
Da gibts auch nichts drüber oder so da ist keine Gesellschaft und nichts das können wir hier allein in dieser Situation lösen.
Falls du frech wirst erschießt ich dich einfach. Und dann muss ich halt doch wieder zu Fuß nach Hause gehen.
Das ist wirklich Grenze das ist Zivilisation am Limit. Das muss man sagen.
Und jetzt hören wir noch was denn Trump Senior dazu zu sagen hat.
Da wird selbst zum Setting Was sagen.
Er wurde bei,
einer Pressekonferenz und es ging eigentlich mal wieder um die Lage der Nation. Und da ist ja auch wichtig wie geht's zur Exotik.
Die.
Großbürger.
Das soll es auch dann nochmal um das Coronavirus gehen im Anschluss. Es ist unglaublich oder.
Ja sowie die Journalisten sitzen ja gerade alle dann überlegen wie machen wir die Frage so dass Trump darauf reagiert und seine Entscheidung war.
Es gibt ja da gerade eine sehr erfolgreiche Sendung gleichrangig mit dem Briefing was sie aber machen Herr Präsident Sie werden ja gerade bedroht.
Und das soll der Trick sein damit Trump dazu war sagt er dann macht er dieses spontane denken dazu.
Ich schaue mir das mal an ja ja und ich habe ja die Möglichkeit hebt sozusagen auch wieder die eigentliche Gewaltenteilung auf.
Ich habe davon nichts mitbekommen. Was ist Amerika wirklich. Es ist unglaublich.
Tromp.
Kinojahr.
Aber ganz ehrlich dargestellt wird ja Wieso finden Sie das interessant mögen sie auch wilde Tiere.
Das ist ja auch sehr schön. Wir haben ja dieses Phänomen Cat Content nun Seite ist das soziale Seite die sozialen Netzwerke gibt.
Und wir können hier eigentlich auch nochmal so ein Cat Content beobachten.
Mit diesen Raubkatzen. Und tatsächlich ist es ja ein unglaubliches Phänomen in Amerika dass man sich mit diesen Katzen,
mit diesen kleinen Tigern oder so fotografieren lässt auch Ehepaare Hochzeitspaare kommen dann und machen Fotos dort Man möchte dann diese,
Tierchen sich mal ausleihen für einen halben Tag und mit ihnen spielen zu können und zahlt dafür horrende Beträge.
Das ist dann auch zugleich noch gekoppelt an einen perversen Jugendwahn denn es deutet sich so ein bisschen anders Einige dieser Züchter,
wohl diese Tiere zum Teil auch erschießen wenn sie älter werden weil sie dann nur noch Kosten produzieren und nur die jungen Tiere kann man streichen und nur die jungen Tiere sind auch so süß.
Man sieht hier noch einmal im Mikrokosmos den Wahnsinn dieses Jugend Bans und den Wahnsinn der sozialen Medien.
Und ich glaube auch was sich hier zwischen Basken und Joho Exotik abspielt ist auch so ein bisschen so dieser Schmutz Wahlkampf zwischen Trump und Hillary Clinton.
Und es gibt selbstverständlich auch schon Memes die Carrel Basken als Hillary Clinton darstellen und ich habe auch bei Youtube ein Fake gesehen.
Dort wird dann einfach das Gesicht von Hillary drauf auf das Gesicht von Kerry Basken während sie dann dort erzählt dass sie von all dem nichts wusste was da eigentlich läuft.
Und zwischendurch werden dann immer noch solche in Schlagzeilen eingeblendet.
Also man hat das auch eigentlich sehr gut erkannt. Wie das alles miteinander zusammenhängt.
Und was mich da nochmal so besonders fasziniert hat war dass wir,
wirkliche Postmoderne Lebensentwürfe haben insofern als hier nicht mehr irgend ein Wert eines alten Amerikas beschworen wird sondern hier ist wirklich anything goes.
Das ist ja auch schon etwas was wir bei Trump gesehen haben wir haben es ja hier nicht mit einem tief religiösen Menschen zu tun der für irgendetwas steht sondern wir haben da es mit einem.
Vollkommen wahnsinnigen Entwurf zu tun was wir übrigens ja jetzt in rechten Kreisen immer wieder erleben wir sehen ja jetzt auch dann Yogamatte bei irgendwelchen Nazi Aufmärschen und sonst was das passt jetzt alles irgendwie zusammen oder auch nicht.
Man hat eine so große Man hat eigentlich so ein ambivalentes Gewitter dem man da ausgesetzt ist während man diese Serie guckt und sie sagt glaub ich wirklich viel über unsere Zeit auf.
Und inzwischen haben das auch die Comedians aufgenommen.
Wer zu nennen Der hat ja auch jetzt seine Show ins Homeoffice verlagert und der zieht dann noch einmal ganz direkt Parallelen zum Fall Trump und zum Fall Joe Exotik.
Egerkingen.
Team.
Reading in,
Amerika.
Japan Schmuck.
Only.
Live.
States.
Commander in Chief.
New York Times.
Higher.
Point.
New York.
Times Street,
Times.
Aber das wäre auch meine Frage gewesen. Er hat jetzt nicht explizit gemacht aber,
du fragst dich ja auch immer über die Handlung hinaus bei solchen Medien geschehen was kann es uns noch mitteilen was teilt uns mit was ist so latent was schwingt damit hier eine extreme Resonanz.
Es ist aber nicht der reine Til Schweiger Plot Wahnsinn dass einfach alle drei Minuten so ein neuer Dreh irgendwie passiert da das sich lustig macht sondern es ist doch noch irgendwie sowas Pesce,
steckt da drin es schon ganz gut herausgearbeitet.
Es liegt glaube ich auch daran dass wir hier so eine Frühformen von Trump erleben.
Es ist ja nicht so dass jetzt jemand kommt und spielt uns mal so Trump.
Man hat ja jetzt auch ein bisschen so was dann in der Comedy Szene probiert und jeder hat jetzt auch mal seine Trump Imitation hingelegt und jetzt könnte man sich auch noch vorstellen Man produziert Filme die zeigen wie das so im Weißen Haus mit Trump ist.
Aber eigentlich wissen wir das ja schon fast alles das haben wir ja auch so schon gesehen. Ob wir da jetzt noch durch das ein oder andere Schlüsselloch blinzeln können.
Wir werden wahrscheinlich überrascht dass es zum Teil dann noch irrer ist. Manches wird vielleicht auch ganz reibungslos funktionieren Man weiß es nicht.
Was hier aber interessantes ist Wir haben es mit einer Figur zu tun die tritt eben.
Man kann sagen nach dem 11. September auf. Dann beginnt eine neue Zeit und dann tritt diese Person zum ersten Mal in die öffentlichkeit und sagt Ja ich mache nicht einfach nur so.
Ich möchte berühmt werden. Und wie mache ich das. Ich muss irgendwie mediale Kanäle nutzen. Jetzt ist der Fernseher nicht mehr vielleicht bald so wichtig.
Wichtig ist dass ich im Internet vorkomme. Ich muss in den sozialen Medien sein warum Filme ich mich eigentlich nicht die ganze Zeit und ich bin aber doch auch irgendwie ein Country Star. Deswegen singe ich Songs ein.
Ich bin aber auch exzentrisch deswegen lebe ich wie ein Popstar eben mit mehreren Partnern.
Ich mache mir nichts draus aus irgendwelchen Gepflogenheiten aus Konventionen aus Bürgerlichen. Ich lebe in antibürgerliche.
Ich Paare das dann noch mit so einem libertären Geist dass man sagt ja Waffen für alle und auch Tiere für alle wer meine Tiere mir verbieten will der beschneidet mich in meiner Freiheit.
Und das alles wird dann ebenso vermischt mit diversen Diversity Aspekten.
Ich komme bei einer Sache hat gar nicht recht dass er sagt Man sieht da bei solchen leuten dann was daraus wird wenn man keine schwarzen Freunde im Umfeld hat.
Er hat ein relativ diverses Umfeld er hat keine schwarze bekannte oder oder Mitarbeiter tauchen dort tatsächlich nicht auf.
Ich würde aber eher sagen das ist wahrscheinlich Zufall denn da ist.
Das ist nicht mehr in irgendeiner Weise an Identitäre in dem Sinne sondern alles ist einfach möglich und das ist an nichts mehr eigentlich gebunden.
Wir haben es nicht irgendwie mit einem Rassisten oder sowas zu tun sondern wirklich mit einem der ist dann Rassist wenn es ihm jetzt gerade auch passt das zu sein und morgen vielleicht nicht weil dann gerade was anderes für ihn sinnvoll erscheint.
Genauso ist es dann eben auch mit den Männern dass er denen dann auch klar macht jetzt ist es doch mal sinnvoll wenn man mal zu dritt heiratet.
Ich glaube das ist tatsächlich heruntergebrochen alles auf Spektakel Spektakel ja oder nein alles Inhaltliche es codiert sozusagen das Stefanos. Diesen Witz macht.
Ich glaube das ist hier auch wieder zu verstehen als das extravagante haben wir so ein bisschen Exklusivität.
Und wenn das dann mal bei den Weißen sichtbar wird dann ist es immer gleich eine Sensation für uns ist es aber eigentlich total normal.
Aber was wir eben auch sagtest das gilt ja auch für Deutschland ich zeigte hier ein Tweet der von Sandra Zizek,
ist ein junges Mädel mit einer Sprechblase oben und die Sandra Zizek ist die Virologie Chefin hier in Frankfurt.
Die macht gerade mit Blutspendedienst so recht viel Kohle Cove Zeug Kona Zeug.
Und so eine Karikatur abgefilmt als eine junge Frau die das Handy vor sich grinst hinein und sagt Ich will Mega berühmt werden und krass viele Follower haben und voll oft in Shows sitzen und im zweiten Bild sagt sie dann und deshalb werde ich Virologen.
Es ist der gleiche Effekt wieder in Amerika. Nur dass wir eben und es ist wirklich erstaunlich.
Diese Art von massenmediale Prominenz Zuschreibung Wir erklären ja wer massenmedial gut funktioniert und sei es nur durch viele schalten ein.
Und dass wir in Deutschland den Trumps keine Chance geben sondern plötzlich Christian Drosten.
Das ist wirklich so erstaunlich das ist so sonderbar und auch so gut einfach inhaltlich weil uns das als Gesellschaft eine wirklich sehr viel hilft. Aber wir kommen nicht drumherum.
Und wir diese Solidität dann auch feiern. Auf eine eigenartige Weise dass man dann erfährt Christian Drosten fährt Fahrrad und man tut.
Das kommt dann alles dazu.
Man tut so als würde jede Exotik sagen Ich habe mir zehn Rolls-Royce gekauft.
Aber ich finde Christian Drosten ist unser Exotin. Wir haben unsere massenmediale macht die wir nun nur in Summe haben.
Deswegen kann man nicht steuern kann man einfach nur ausdrücken oder nicht.
Die haben wir Christian Drosten spendiert und nicht nur mit seinem Podcast Podcaster wirklich sehr viel mehr Reichweite als alles andere was irgendwie mit der Alda stattfindet.
Man kann aber auch sagen deswegen ist das deutsche Showgeschäft nicht so glamourös. Wir haben da nicht viele Figuren.
Das kann man sagen.
Schauen wir einmal auf die Figur die am meisten zieht der alles weg moderieren kann das ist ja Günther Jauch und Günther Jauch ist ein wahnsinnig unglamourös Mensch.
Weil er so besonders klug eingeschätzt wird.
Das stimmt.
Bei Gottschalk hat man das irgendwie ihm verziehen oder es gehörte etwas dazu.
Er durfte auch mal im Schottenrock auftreten und er hatte immer noch diese blonden lockigen langen Haare. Aber eigentlich haben wir von solchen Figuren relativ wenige.
Während das in Amerika gang und gäbe ist dass da gerade mehr mehr ist. Und dass es dann hier bei so einem Phänomen wie dem Talker King auf die Spitze getrieben.
Ja selbst bei Alltags Comedians in der ARD haben wir den Anspruch dass der Herr Hirschhausen aber auch ein echter Arzt ist.
Ja ja genau.
Erstaunlich Deutschland ist da wirklich muss man einmal sagen ein ganz besonderes Land im Vergleich zu vielen anderen guet.
Jetzt wird es ernster.
Thema Einsamkeit.
Wir haben uns ja bei der kurzvor verständigt dass wir noch einmal in Manfred Spitzers nicht allzu umfangreiches aber doch recht Naja es ist halt nicht nur ein Zeitungsartikel oder so.
Sondern es ist schon eine ordentliche Abhandlung zum Thema ein.
240 Seiten lassen sich aber schnell lesen.
Auch relativ gut geschrieben. Er achtet ja auch immer darauf dass er am Anfang einen guten Einstieg hat und das Ganze die harten Zahlen die erst in der zweiten Hälfte also wenn man sich sozusagen für die,
psychiatrische Dimension interessiert und den Forschungsstandort Nun kann man in die erste Hälfte weglegen.
Das macht allerdings finde ich die erste Hälfte umso interessanter weil da eben doch ein bisschen freimütige auch als Privatperson ans Thema herangeht und sagt Das interessiert mich jetzt aus Gründen die euch nicht so fern sind.
Lieber Leser hinten raus kann ich dann den Psychiater raushängen lassen.
Aber vorne gehts erst einmal Es ist ein Buch für die Allgemeinheit das ist jetzt kein Fachbuch oder so und deswegen würd ich sagen fangen wir auch mal vorne an.
Er hat ja beginnt ja tatsächlich mit einer Definition von Einsamkeit indem er erstmal ausschließt was er nicht meint und er schreibt ganz explizit.
Einsamkeit ist nicht einfach die wahrnehmbare soziale Isolation.
Weil das ist Alleinsein also wenn man jetzt beim Thema Einsamkeit daran denkt ein Menschenleben alleine die Versicherungen der Haushalte und so weiter.
Ja das ist so eine Dimension die müsste man aber erst einmal durch exerzieren wie weiter Einsamkeit eine Rolle spielen denn erst einmal geht es um nicht nur die soziale Isolation sondern es ist der Einsamkeit ist der Gegenentwurf zu Empathie.
Empathie ist dieses gefühlige umgehen mit anderen wie folgen ja ganz unbewusst einfach mit,
Urteilen über andere Menschen hantieren und danach ebenso die eigene soziale Landkarte aufbauen und den empathischen Herangehensweise.
Man mag Menschen gerne unter Leuten man hat keine Angst vor ihnen Man geht taktvoll miteinander um und so weiter. Oder das Gegenteil. Man ist einsam.
Man sich lieber im Wodkas in die Ohren setzen dunkle Sonnenbrille auf und ist ganz froh dass man jetzt eine Maske tragen darf. Das geht dann sowieso Richtung Einsamkeit.
Deswegen fand ich das auch für Rentner sehr interessant und auch wichtig es ist ein Gemütszustand über den er argumentiert und das macht es immer schwer.
Man kann es auch lesen und sagen er hatte mal wieder hier und so einen rausgehauen aber das interessiert mich nicht.
Es ist eine Argumentation am Gemütszustand und ich finde die erste Hälfte besonders gut weil dieses Spitzer Erklärungsmuster ganz ganz gut zu Andreas Requests Säkularisierung passt.
Die Gesellschaft der Singularitäten ein soziologischer Bestseller.
Genau da findet man so eine Beschreibung Grundlage die auch nahe der Empirie ist und die auch sehr spekulativ mit dem einen oder anderen sichtbaren Phänomen umgeht.
Spitzer und Requests ergänzen sich da ganz gut.
Da hat man dann natürlich so alberne Datengrundlage wie z.B. dass Spitzer mit Google Anagramm einfach mal aufzählt welche Wörter kommen denn wie häufig und wann in welchen Büchern vor.
Alles was Google jemals digitalisiert hat und sie dann ja das Wort ich häuft sich das Wort Familie nimmt ab oder sowas.
Also solche Sachen irgendwie aber daraus kann man eben dann doch so Trends ablesen wie z.B man konsumiert heute vermehrt alleine und das betrifft Essen und Medien,
und manchmal sogar beides in einer Situation Man sitzt zu Hause vor seinem Fertiggericht und das Tablet steht auf einem Tisch und während man isst guckt man irgendwas bei Netflix,
vielleicht sogar während andere noch mit in der Wohnung anwesend sind.
Das ist so Einsamkeit aber eben nicht nur als soziale Isolation sondern man hat schon so ein umfassenderes umfassendes Phänomen Bereich der sich eben nicht nur körperlich.
Das sind Psychiater anders als die Psychologen. Was passiert wirklich chemisch sondern auch geistig niederschlägt.
Wir haben es bei Einsamkeit mit körperlich und geistig ausbleibenden oder anderen Stimuli zu tun als wenn wir eine empathische.
Wenn wir Menschen haben die mehr Empathie haben als sie unter Einsamkeit leiden.
So glaube ich kann man diesen einfangen der Anfang irgendwie hindeuten.
Und dann stellt sich natürlich relativ zügig die Frage die wir uns alle stellen,
wenn es so Sensing das politische Programm ist von dem wir wissen laut Ranga Yogeshwar Das ging schon zwei Wochen vor der politischen,
normativen Rechtssetzung los dass wir diesen erwehrt so weit unten hatten durch Einschränkung der Mobilität und so weiter und so fort da kann man sich ja durchaus die Frage stellen und dafür ist dann Spitzers Buch besonders gut.
Wieviel Empathie erlernen wir eigentlich gerade,
und zwar in dem Maße dass es auch goutiert wird dass wir ein Lernen Anreiz hinsichtlich da hast du dich aber gut verhalten Du hast jetzt eine Woche nicht unter Menschen gut Schulterklopfen dafür. Das ist ja gerade was wir so erleben.
Einsamkeit ist politisches Ziel und wir erlernen jetzt ganz bewusst Empathie Lässigkeit,
kommen einfach weniger unter Menschen Wir setzen uns weniger dem Druck aus anderen mit anderen Menschen eine gemeinsam geteilte Situation gestalten zu können zu sollen wie auch immer man das.
Und zugleich gibt es ja einen Bescheidenheit Stolz der dann auch so hinzu kommt der sich sicherlich auch koppelt mit so einem Narzißmus dass man sagt Ich bin der der am wenigsten Menschen getroffen hat in den letzten vier Wochen.
Und ich gehe schon seit März nur noch mit Maske und ich hab auch dies und das nicht mehr gemacht und selbst die gute Freundin nicht besucht zum Geburtstag und solche Sachen gibt's dann auch.
Und das sieht man dann auch das ja auch narzisstische Persönlichkeiten sich jetzt besonders gerade austoben in den sozialen Medien auf Instagram und sodass sie jetzt nochmal an.
Das ist nochmal an Fahrt aufnimmt. Wenn man dann auch noch mal mehr die Möglichkeit hat sich mit sich zu beschäftigen.
Ich fand noch einen Aspekt zu diesen Worten ziemlich am Anfang.
Da sagte er Manche Wissenschaftler sprechen mit Bezug auf den zunehmenden Narzissmus auch von einer Epidemie.
Das finde ich auch interessant dass er das bringt diesen Begriff der Epidemie dass man denen auch auf etwas übertragen kann was man erst einmal sagen kann Das ist ja eine Charaktereigenschaft die mehr oder weniger ausgeprägt ist.
Und genauso ist Einsamkeit ja auch ein Zustand der ja auch nicht erst einmal wie eine Krankheit wirkt weil man sagt Gut,
da hab ich mich ja nicht gestern angesteckt dadurch dass ich an dem Klars getrunken hatte dass der andere eine Hand hatte meint man.
Genau diesen diesen Epidemie Begriff so früh fand ich auch.
Jetzt stolpert man natürlich so drüber weg gelesen aber hat ja dann auch dieses dritte Kapitel soziale Ansteckung.
Da geht er nochmal ins Detail was es elementar bedeutet und anschließend an was wir vorhin besprachen.
Netflix geht jetzt durch die Decke. Microsoft verdoppelt einfach mal die alle Sachen die man so verkaufen kann für Homeoffice.
Und wir erleben jetzt schon dass sich neue Kulturtechniken einfach bewähren entweder mit Stolz vorgetragen werden oder Menschen die einsam leben können so ein bisschen. Zum Glück habe ich schon immer richtig gemacht.
Ein kleines Aufatmen steckt da auch drin und die Frage ist natürlich bewährt sich das ja. Kehren wir aus dem Homeoffice mal wieder zurück.
Gehen wir noch ins Kino wenn im November dann James Bond kommt oder Warten wir einfach drei Monate und gucken es dann bequem zu Hause weil wir irgendwie gelernt haben Das funktioniert ganz gut.
Und dann macht er bevor dann soziale Ansteckung thematisiert kommt dann noch einmal über den Schmerz zu sprechen und das ist natürlich die Klammer.
Da wird sozusagen körperlich wie vorhin schon mal bei Luhmanns Systemtheorie Man braucht natürlich diesen körperlichen Haken.
Irgendwann muss das Ganze die ganze Argumentation ja verankert werden und Schmerzen.
Sind wirklich wirklich erleben wir da bewährt sich dann auch zu sagen Es ist eine Argumentation über Gemütszustände das kann man nicht 1:1 nachrechnen.
Bei Menschen Schmerzen haben kann man sie allerhöchstens Fragen so zwischen eins und zehn. Wo sind denn die Schmerzen ungefähr.
Das lässt sich dann auch nicht standardisieren oder sonst irgendwas. Aber das ist das Einzige was man hat Schmerzen können nur erlebt werden und dann sagt der Juval zum Beispiel auch real ist überhaupt nur was leiden kann.
Also es können durchaus Banken einfach pleitegehen. Real wird es erst wenn Menschen die damals Mitarbeiter waren dann anfangen zu leiden weil man die nicht raushaut oder ohne aber Schmerzen sind die eigentliche Wirklichkeit um die es geht,
hat man wenig Zugriff das wird über das Erleben reguliert.
Mit der Dramatisierung von Harari wie man es machen kann und dann sagt Spitzer Schmerz und Einsamkeit wird im Gehirn an derselben Stelle verarbeitet und es ist ihm sehr wichtig und das macht er sehr ausführlich.
Wie man das sichtbar macht was das bedeutet und so weiter. Das Ganze Kernspintomografie und so weiter geht richtig ins psychiatrische kleine Einmaleins und erklärt das von vorne bis hinten durch das zentrale Nervensystem behandelt.
Körperliche und soziale Versehrte. Ziemlich ähnlich.
Weshalb und das fand ich das erstaunlichste sogar man herausgefunden hat dass Schmerzmittel gegen Einsamkeit helfen.
Genau das Ibuprofen kann wirken gegen das Gefühl der Einsamkeit.
Man hat ja was nicht bedeuten soll wenn man sich mal einsam fühlt.
Einfach Ibuprofen reinwerfen aber man hat das erkannt und hat auch diesen Medikamentenmissbrauch von dem immer wieder gesprochen wird na ja da gibt es nur ältere Leute vor allem die schlucken da dann einfach mal so auf Gutdünken,
Ibuprofen einfach um sich besser zu fühlen.
Da sagt er Na ja das ist nicht einfach nur Medikamentenmissbrauch oder so.
Da sind gerade Leute dabei sich selbst zu kurieren.
Ja genau. Ob das als Medikament brauchbar ist weil man die langfristigen Wirkungen und so weiter. Wir sind das in Amerika.
Genau.
Wenn 90 Prozent aller Schmerzmittel in Amerika verkauft werden.
Da wird eben nicht kalkuliert sondern zählt einfach ob man bereit ist eine Apotheke zu bezahlen oder nicht.
Da spielt der Arzt dann keine große Rolle und das kann natürlich sehr nach hinten losgehen. Wie man.
Ja aber man sieht das Symptom hier dann noch einen ganz anderen Blickfeld weil bei Medikamenten Abhängigkeit denkt man die haben halt irgendwie so eine Sucht aber man denkt dann nicht,
die haben auch in gewisser Weise eine Krankheit nämlich die Einsamkeit,
die sie irgendwie versuchen zu kurieren und bei ihnen hat sich das ja gar nicht so überlegt herausgestellt dass das so ist haben wir nicht gesagt Ach so ich bin einsam ich probier mal aus wenn ich das Einnehmen gehts mir dann besser.
Sondern das hat sich so als invisible hand Prozess eingestellt.
Und dann haben Studien das hinterher bestätigt was erst mal interessant ist dass das überhaupt möglich ist das hält man ja nicht für denkbar.
Aber das ist auch interessant Spitzer geht ja da auch immer mal wieder so punktuell drauf ein dass der Volksmund der das eine oder andere schon in Sprüche gepackt hat sich dann tatsächlich wieder zeigen konnte.
Und er markiert eben ganz klar da sozusagen Bine das einmal verständlich zusammen eine verletzte Hand ist wie eine verletzte Beziehung.
Was die Verarbeitung im Gehirn angeht wenn Menschen die man mag plötzlich nicht mehr zur Verfügung stehen und sogar mitteilen dass sie das bewusst machen dann könnte man sich genauso gut in den Finger schneiden. Ja das ist so.
Das wird dann im Gehirn an derselben Stelle verarbeitet und da kann man wieder den Umkehrschluss zu dem machen was du eben nicht nur können. Medikamente gegen Einsamkeit Gefühle helfen sondern Sozialität selbst kann wieder gegen körperliche Schmerzen helfen.
Sehr viele Therapien gegen alles Mögliche haben,
einfach unter Freunden sein Nähe zur Familie mit in der Ellsworth verschrieben wie ein Medikament Sagen wir so soziale Nähe wird verschwiegen wie ein Medikament.
Und was du gerade ansprichst dass Worte auch verletzen können in Beziehungen oder bei Trennungen. Und auch das weiß quasi der Volksmund wenn wir mal den Schlager und die Popwelt dazunehmen.
Worte wie Steine gibt es ein Lied von Dalia Lawinky. Und dann gibt es von Schaer Eva Kottan Back Time und da gibt's die Zeile Words Alice Weapons zum Times.
Ja und diese Sozialität kann man durchaus dem Gehirn auch so ein bisschen faken.
Es gibt für kurze Momente Brücken beispielsweise hängen sich Kinder gerne Poster von ihren Stars ins Kinderzimmer weil da sind sie dann zwei Stunden und für zwei Stunden fühlen sie sich dann weniger alleine.
Genauso wie alte Menschen Fotos der eigenen Familie mit ins Krankenhaus nehmen weil sie dann für die drei Tage oder für eine Woche.
Das kann man nicht strecken auf ewig ja gerade jetzt mit diesem Kontaktsperre im Altersheim das ist halt,
das eine ernsthafte Probleme aber für so eine kurze Invasion die im Krankenhaus stattfinden muss da kann man durchaus durch die Familienfotos mitnehmen und dann stehen sie da und dann fühlt man dass auch sie da sind weil man weiß ja.
Der Countdown läuft nach drei Tagen ist man zurück sondern hatte dieses schöne schöne Kapitel über soziale Ansteckung und er beginnt mit der Hysterie.
Und weil die Hysterie aber eben auch Jucken Kratzen gähnen wir mit vollziehen das Verhalten anderer beim Gähnen ist es ganz berühmt. Menschen fangen an zu gehen und plötzlich gehen alle.
Das schlägt sich nieder in ganz witziger Fahrstuhl Soziologie in Bielefeld gemacht wurde.
Wie fährt man eigentlich Fahrstuhl. Immer so wie alle anderen Egal wie albern Fahrstuhl gefahren wird.
Und wenn alle nach links zur Wand gucken dann stellt man sich ja und kommt auch links der Wand. Man weiß gar nicht wieso.
Das ist ein sehr ansteckendes Verhalten einfach durch zu sehen was andere machen da macht man es auch.
Das Abstimmung war zu anstrengend genau so sagt es sehr gut und das kann man natürlich mega hoch dramatisieren das streift er nur kurz erwähnt sind ganz minimal aber man kann das nachvollziehen.
Wird zur Ansteckung so formulierte es.
Herdentrieb in der ökonomie.
Was wir jetzt gesehen haben im Börsenhandel und so weiter.
Man orientiert sich aneinander genauso wie man auch Toilettenpapier genauso kauft der Hamster Kauf ist ein selbst verstärkenden Phänomen durch soziale Ansteckung.
Man spekuliert ein bisschen was die anderen da gerade machen im Supermarkt und dann denkt man sich besser mal mit.
Entweder die wissen mehr als ich. Oder wenn jetzt alle so handeln und ich nicht dann haben alle Klopapier und ich nicht aus irgendwelchen Gründen macht man dann einfach mit.
Und da kann man natürlich anschließend in den letzten Salon Meme und Gene.
Das ist so wie sich Gene Verhalten falten sich eben auch Meme.
Es entstehen so Ideen und die sind virulent.
Man sagt nicht ohne Grund spricht man vom Influencer der die Krippe weitergibt und von viralen Videos sozusagen die ganze Viren Lustigkeit mit drin.
Und er betont noch mal besonders ansteckend ist die Angst dass der physische Vollzug wenn man sieht wie andere plötzlich die Augen aufreißen,
und Panik wissen wir Das kommt genau daher Man weiß gar nicht warum man mit flüchtet aber man flüchtet erst mal mit Die Aufklärung kann ja immer noch.
Kann man dann auch sagen gesagt mir nachher warum wir flüchten aber jetzt retten wir erst mal alle unser Leben ganz genau. Ganz genau.
Kann man bei der Börse ja immer ganz wunderbar sehen und da sitzt dann auch oft solche Tiere die flüchten zuerst und dann oh Buffet das jetzt gerade macht.
Keine Ahnung er wird schon wissen warum und da hänge ich mich mal dran.
Es gibt ja jetzt auch gerade wieder diese Angst nachdem die Börsenkurse erst einmal im Keller waren sind sie ja nun wieder etwas nach oben gegangen Der Dax ist wieder über 10 000 und jetzt sagen manche.
Nein die Angst die müsste jetzt noch viel größer sein denn es hat sich schon damals bei der Dotcom-Blase mal gezeigt die Kurse die Kurse erholen sich nochmal und dann merkt man wie furchtbar die Situation wirklich wirklich ist.
Und dann gehen Sie nochmal richtig runter. Und jetzt kann auch allein das auszusprechen und verbreitet sich dieses Narrativ Narrative Wirtschaft heißt jetzt ein gerade erschienenes Buch verbreitet sich dieses wieder.
Dann kann auch ohne dass sich vielleicht zeigt dass es wirklich furchtbar ist das auslösen dass es wieder runtergeht.
Hinzu kommen bei der Börse noch diese ganzen technischen Sachen die man auch nicht mit dem Blick hat die aber auch nochmal verunsichern. Da ist einfach sehr viel Angst.
Ich habe dann auch beim Lesen gedacht Ja das ist so..
Warum gucken Menschen Reaction Videos. Warum gucken Menschen bei anderen zu wie sie was gucken ohne selbst zu sehen was die sehen.
Warum ist eigentlich die Reaktion von anderen. Das kennen vor allem Eltern.
Wenn die eigenen Kinder Geburtstag haben freuen sich die Kinder über die Geschenke und die Eltern freuen sich noch mehr darüber wie sich die Kinder darüber freuen was sie für Geschenke kriegen.
Es ist völlig egal was das für ein Geschenk ist das Geschenk selbst als Auslöser dieser sozialen Verkettung.
Es ist absolut egal Hauptsache es ist da und trifft vielleicht zu Nerv.
Bei dem ersten aber danach wollen die Eltern und die Großeltern sehen wie die Freude ist und so weiter und das kann Kinder auch sehr unter Druck setzen. Da muss man auch ein bisschen aufpassen.
Das sollte man wissen dass es so ein bisschen Naim.
Du hast dich gar nicht richtig gefreut. Dann der Vorwurf.
Ja aber auch dieses grundsätzliche dieser Moment.
Und jetzt zeigt der Tante auch noch mal wie sehr du dich gefreut hast. Ja.
Genau schon Danke gesagt. Wie sagt man es dann rein.
Wie soll man sagen dass was für eine medikamentöse medikamentöse Verabreichung von sozialen Verhaltensnormen in diesem Moment eine soziale Ansteckung ist und für mich als Soziologen ist dann sehr interessant wie er über das Dialogue Verhalten spricht Da kommt nämlich,
dieser Abstimmung Ansteckung durch Abstimmung Menschen begegnen sich und wir Soziologen würden sagen Ja da begegnen sich zwei die voneinander wissen dass sie hier eine gemeinsame Situation aber jeder für sich der doppelten Kontingenz auflösen müssen.
Man weiß nie so richtig wie verhält sich der andere also geht man aus Verlegenheit in Höflichkeiten Form über weil man weiß Man kann wenig passieren oder man ist beim Militär da ist aber klar geregelt Wer salutiert wem und so weiter.
Wer geht wem aus dem Weg das ist dann sehr einfach für die Menschen im Alltag mit den Nachbarn die man nur alle drei Wochen mal trifft.
Da weiß man nie so richtig in welche Richtung geht das eigentlich genau.
Duzen wir uns eigentlich habe ich schon wieder vergessen und muss sich jetzt nach den Kinder fragen Darf ich einfach auch mit einem kurzen Gruß sofort in mein Auto steigen muss ich den Smalltalk jetzt machen.
Man weiß noch nicht was ist unhöflich und was nicht und was wir als Höflichkeit auch übertrieben denn Höflichkeit wird sehr schnell unpersönlich.
Das kennt man so von Stewardessen oder eine Flugbegleiterin wenn man da angesprochen wird dann sieht man merkt man so richtig die würde mit mir zu sprechen.
Die reagiert auf mich hier gar nicht sondern das ist einfach nur höfliches Protokoll.
Da muss man bei sowas sehr aufpassen und da greift dann dieser fortlaufende Abstimmungsprozess da muss man dann taktvoll sein erzählt Intuition und Erfahrung wenn man denn schon welche hat oder wie,
Spitzer dann sagt die Empathie,
in diesen Momenten ist einfach wichtig dass man mit Menschen umgehen kann und dass man auch mal eine kleine riskante Situation aushält und nicht dann panisch und sozial ängstlich diesen Situationen lieber aus dem Weg geht.
Irgendwie Vermeidungsverhalten zeigt dass dann Einsamkeit bei Dialogue verhalten wird.
Besonders gut beschrieben finde ich wieso Empathie und Einsamkeit eigentlich sich gegenüberstehen auf der gleichen Dimension und da kommt eben dieser Abstimmung diese Abstimmung die schlüsselt einfach um in Ansteckung. Da findet Ansteckung statt.
Es begegnen sich Individuen die sich jeder für sich verhalten.
Aber die gemeinsame soziale Situation entstehen lassen und die selbst ist infektiös wenn es auf dem Schulhof lustig zu Geld geht es für alle lustig zu.
Wenn es auf dem Schulhof brutal zugeht dann kann man auch nicht eine Ecke stehen und plötzlich einen tollen Witz erzählen oder so. Sondern es ist für alle brutal da greift sozusagen Dieses Herdenverhalten sich orientieren nachahmen Achtung erwidern.
Auch in unterschiedlichen Abständen wie auf Dialoge reagiert wird beziehungsweise etwas Gesprochenes reagiert wird,
die Reaktion mit der ich auf das was du sagst reagiere ist in unseren Breitengraden glaub ich ein wenig schneller als in anderen Ländern.
Da gibt es auch ein paar interessante Studien die er da aufführt die dann gemessen haben.
Wie lange braucht man dann eigentlich in dem üblichen Dialog in großen philosophischen Debatte oder wo man vielleicht nochmal eine halbe Minute sogar nachdenken würde und dann die große Antwort präsentiert sondern eben im alltäglichen sprechen.
Wie ist da die Reaktion und wer infiziert sich da am schnellsten.
Geht dann ein paar Zahlen durch. Man ist auch erstaunt was so alles erforscht wird wenn man das da sieht.
Das hat einen unglaublich dicken Anhang dieses Buch aber das ist sehr erstaunlich wenn man mal darüber nachdenkt und da sind wir ja dann gerade du hast es ja eben schon beschrieben in einer ganz guten Zeit.
Diese grundsätzliche das Funktionieren selbst einmal zu thematisieren was wir sonst immer als vorausgesetzt.
Wir haben es ein bisschen vielleicht so im Podcast Geschäft ohnehin das wir gucken wie reagiert man aufeinander wird das auch richtig übertragen rechtzeitig übertragen.
Oder wie wäre eigentlich jetzt unser Gespräch wenn alles fünf Sekunden verspätet ankäme weil die Leitung hier nicht gut wäre oder so.
Dann wäre das schon ein ganz anderes Gespräch Es hätte eine andere Tonalität sicherlich.
Ganz genau. Es gibt gerade die große Frage auf Teck Seiten diskutiert. Warum sind Videokonferenzen so belastet.
Eine Antwort die immer gegeben wird ist weil man sich die ganze Zeit selber sieht und das ist finde ich die und überzeugendste Antwort überhaupt.
Viel überzeugender als das was du angesprochen hast wenn man gemeinsam in der Konferenz sitzt da gibt's diesen und da gab es ja große Unterschiede zwischen den Kulturen in Mexiko fängt man sich die ganze Zeit ins Wort.
Da redet man schon bevor der andere aufgehört hat weil man irgendwie so setze während man in Skandinavien so ewig wartet. Dann ist erst mal Stille und dann kommt die Antworten.
Und in der Videokonferenz sind diese Millisekunden völlig durcheinander geworfen und man muss die ganze Zeit das Bewusstsein mitlaufen lassen. Kann ich jetzt jetzt hat ja schon angefangen.
Und dann ist schon wieder zehn Sekunden hängen dazwischen und verhindern diesen ordentlichen Wortwechsel der dann nicht stattfinden kann.
Also wer sich für sowas im Detail interessiert andere kaiserliches Dissertationen Interaktion unter Anwesenden geht da wirklich so wahnsinnig ins Detail was diese ganze Abhängigkeit und die Funktion von T und so weiter,
angeht da kann man sehr gut nochmal nachlesen.
Und man kann mal Filme vergleichen Man soll sich ruhig mal einen mexikanischen Film ansehen und dann guckt man mal einen Film von Aki Kaurismäki wieder auf Dialoge Regie geführt und der badeten aus,
der DDR der der der badet so sehr da drin dass das alles so zögerlich kommt dann lässt man mal eine Minute jemanden antworten Der sagt dann nur Ja,
und zwar als sehr schön.
Da kann man auch die unterschiedlichen ich nenne es mal Mentalitäten sehr anschaulich präsentiert finden.
Ja es gibt auch eine sehr interessante Studien aus der Soziologie zum Thema Psychotherapie.
Und wie bringt eigentlich der Therapeut das Selbstgespräch bei seinem Patienten zum Laufen ohne zu viel intervenieren aber trotzdem Interesse zu zeigen.
Wie minimal darf denn so ein sein um Anleihen zu sein aber ohne die Richtung des Gesprächs vorzugeben.
Da gibt's ganz viel Praxis wissen dass sie jetzt auch in der Coaching Szene immer mal wieder so für ein tolles Gespräch so Wie verhandle ich richtig um mein Gehalt,
soll ich bettelnd auftreten oder lieber ganz nett von mir reden oder den meinen Beitrag und wie gebe ich eigentlich dem Chef an Futter und wieviel lasse ich aber auch von ihm kommen wieviel Fragen stelle ich ihm nicht.
Da gibt's ja mittlerweile so sehr ins Detail geht.
Jedenfalls ist dieses Dialogue Verhalten oszilliert zwischen Empathie und Einsamkeit.
Und je nachdem was da überhand gewinnt oder ausbleibt hat das Einfluss auf alle weiteren Gespräche die darauf folgen Entweder man selber beginnt oder die woanders beginnen.
Menschen kommen nach Hause und sind erleichtert dass sie jetzt ihre Familie treffen weil sie endlich mal wieder drauflos plaudern können weil sie in Zusammenhängen sind wo die ganze Einsamkeit gefordert wird.
Man soll nicht stören die Hierarchie der Unternehmer die Hierarchie gibts überhaupt nur um Kommunikation zu vermeiden damit nicht jeder mit jedem quasselt sondern Klars.
Wer hat hier wem was zu sagen und vor allem wie viele Leuten haben eigentlich wieviel nichts zu sagen das regelt eine Hierarchie.
Einsamkeit wird in erheblichem Maße in Modernität gelernt.
Und je nachdem wie tiefgreifend dieser Lernprozess ist findet dann eben diese Singularity statt.
Da gleichen sich. Da kann man jetzt nachlesen was der Spitze eigentlich meint.
Auf sozialer Ebene und man kann das dann sozial soziologisch wieder strapazieren indem man sich ganz einfach die Frage stellt an einer Kasse bezahlen in einen Bus einsteigen.
Ist das eigentlich eine Situation die man gemeinsam meistert.
Schaut man sich in die Augen wartet man höflich bis jemand rausgeht gibt's eine Abstimmung zwischen. Ich muss diesen Kinderwagen schieben oder nicht.
Oder sitzen wir alle in unserer eigenen Situation fest mit uns selbst weil wir gerade Podcast hören weil wir gerade noch auf dem Smartphone etwas gelesen haben und stimmen uns mit niemandem mehr ab sondern warten bis der Weg frei ist und gehen dann rein.
Das ist diese Einsamkeit der Einsamkeit überleben unter Menschen. Man ist nicht sozial isoliert aber man ist trotzdem einsam.
Man beginnt gar nicht erst ein Gespräch mit jemanden weil man müsse sein Podcast unterbrechen Man müsste vom Smartphone aufschauen. Man weiß gar nicht was kommt dann als Antwort.
Es gibt gerade über das Smartphone Man fragt nicht mehr nach dem Weg weil man hat ja jetzt Google Maps und das sind alles Erlernte Einsamkeit Funktion die eben auch ansteckend sind. Diese Ansteckungsgefahr kommt ja immer wieder durch.
Nun muss man ja sagen dass Spitzer hoch umstritten ist.
Er ist jemand der sobald er ein neues Buch veröffentlich dann viele viele Verrisse erntet im übrigen auch bei diesem Buch ist das so Wenn man ein bisschen mal dann schaut zum Beispiel in der Süddeutschen Zeitung gibt es einen fundamentalen verriss er würde,
wissenschaftliche Studien nur ganz selektiv wahrnehmen er würde verkürzen er würde,
mit einer These reingehen und sie dann nur,
bestätigt irgendwo suchen und sich ansonsten auch zum Teil Forschungsergebnis so zurechtbiegen dass sie dann auch stimmen mit seiner These abgestimmt sind.
Ich muss jetzt sagen Ich bin ja nicht beschlagen in diesen ganzen Studien die er da zitiert bzw. kenne ich nicht.
Die 300 400 anderen Einsamkeit US-Studien die mir das sagen.
Was mir aber auffällt ist Es gibt ja bei Spitzer doch eine ganz große Ablehnung der digitalen Medien grundsätzlich.
Also es gibt ja auch dieses Buch das hatte ich glaube ich damals gelesen.
Digitale Demenz. Und da frage ich mich schon ob er nicht auch diese unmittelbare Begegnung etwas zu sehr.
Als absolut setzt wo ich sagen würde naja die meisten Menschen die mir heute etwas bedeuten die heute meinen Freundes und Bekanntenkreis bilden die habe ich.
Durch das Internet kennengelernt die habe ich dann auch mal getroffen und die treffe ich auch hin und wieder.
Aber da nun viele Leute sehr verstreut leben und Deutschland ein großes Land ist und auch noch manche über die deutsche Grenze hinaus sind,
kann ich die ja nicht laufend besuchen halte also fernmündlich Kontakte oder dann über die entsprechenden Nachrichtendienste und was man alles so nutzen kann.
Und dann würde ich sagen Ohne diese Leute und angewiesen auf meine direkte Umgebung wäre ich ein ziemlich einsamer Mensch,
denn ich lebe in Koblenz und dann kann man sich in etwa vorstellen dass da grundsätzlich schon nicht so viele Menschen leben mit Interessen wie ich sie habe.
Das wäre jetzt in Berlin etwas leichter vielleicht. Aber andererseits wenn ich in Berlin bin habe ich dann mit denen in München nicht so viel Kontakt.
Was ich damit sagen will ist dass er so sehr ignoriert dass eben diese Kommunikationsmedien natürlich nicht eine Liwni ersetzen können.
Was er jetzt auch ganz viele Theaterleute und so merken die sagen auch Wir machen man Live-Stream.
Naja gut Theater konnte ich schon immer Filmen zumindest in den letzten Jahrzehnten.
Aber aus gutem Grund hat das sehr wenig stattgefunden und Theater lebt davon dass Leute dort präsent sind auf der Bühne wie im Saal.
Und ich würde auch sagen Das ist nicht möglich dass man eine Freundschaft rein virtuell führen kann aber zugleich ist doch eben diese Distanz überwindung durch die sozialen Medien und all das,
ein ganz großer Vorteil dass eben Leute nicht einsam sind oder dass auch viele Leute die gerade.
Speziellere Interessen haben überhaupt erst mit anderen in Kontakt treten können.
Ich sage mal wer sich zum Beispiel jetzt für Theologie oder so interessiert des Mittelalters,
der sich gerne mit Leuten darüber austauschen möchte der kann ja schlecht bei sich mal in der Stadt in Koblenz oder in Trier oder sonst wo man gerade nachfragen und sagen,
Hallo ich würde da mal gerne drüber reden.
Da hat er natürlich immer wieder das gleiche sehr raffinierte Gegenargument gegen diesen Einwurf wie du hingebracht hast denn beispielsweise Hier kommt er ja auch im Buch wieder darauf zurück.
Kann man nicht Fernuni einfach machen.
Bei der Bildung geht es doch nur um Inhalte gerade im Studenten Alter da will man doch einfach nur Inhalte vermitteln da wird abgefragt. Sehr gut.
Und da hat man dann irgendwann diese Massen Vorlesungen Veranstaltungen gemacht die natürlich erstmals von den Early Adopter angenommen wurden und die fanden das natürlich super.
Diese Kurse durchlaufen dann sagte irgendwann der Alltag ein und auch die Allgemeinheit.
Und zack waren die Abbrecherquoten 90 prozent 95 prozent 97 prozent 98 prozent.
Und irgendwann läuft sich das tot. Es hat keine Dauer. Es ist ein.
Spektakel auf Zeit und es machen.
Man muss glaube ich schon gerade beim Internet sehr unterscheiden zwischen Menschen die ganz bewusst damit umgehen,
und andere die sich wirklich treiben lassen und als Think-Tank eine der besten Apps überhaupt die einen alle 15 Sekunden in eine neue Sozialität vermeintlich wirft weil man sieht ja die ganze Zeit Menschen,
aber im Gehirn findet nicht die doppelte Kontingenz statt weil man erwartet nicht von den Bildschirmen dass er sich die ganze Zeit so verhält dass man irgendwie darauf reagieren muss oder man weiß Ich kann jetzt einfach erleben und es fühlt sich dann an wie unter Menschen.
Aber es spiegelt sich im Gehirn nicht wider.
Und dann kommt er auf die ganzen Folgeerkrankungen zurecht da einsame Menschen werden grundsätzlich kränker und das kann man zwar gefühlsmäßig irgendwie verdrängen aber auch der Bäcker das tolle Argument wenn man.
Vermittelt übereinen Computer kommuniziert dann führt man per Video Gespräche ein echtes Gespräch Man sieht sich man hört sich und so weiter.
Aber sobald das schriftliche Kommunikation ist kommuniziert man mit einer Maschine und nicht mit den Menschen dahinter Samer schwer zu akzeptieren dass es dann tatsächlich so ist aber die Entscheidungsfreiheit zum Thema Wann antworte ich auf die E-Mail.
Ich kann den Satz nochmal umbauen ab und so weiter nimmt so viel an Sozialität raus,
dass das Gehirn das gar nicht mehr als soziale Interaktion verarbeitet sondern nur noch als reine Verarbeitung von allerlei bis hin zu.
Es findet vielleicht gar nicht mehr im sensorischen Register Es ist so weit zurückgedrängt dass es gar nicht mehr.
Ja tick tack das sind ja Leute die ich nicht kenne.
Aber wenn ich jetzt daran denke um einmal was Persönliches zu sagen dass wir ein paar Freunde. Ich sage jetzt keine Namen.
Wir haben bei Facebook eine Coruna Rom eröffnet.
Wir sind da zu fünft und wir schreiben dort täglich ein paar Dinge immer mal rein oder irgendjemand macht man Sprachnachrichten und sagt Ich war gerade beim Edeka Mensch die Leute aber immer noch nicht die Masken an.
Solche alltäglichen Dinge irgendwas Witziges senden uns auch mal den einen oder anderen link.
Ich würde sagen dass das doch uns allen irgendwie so durch den Tag sehr hilft.
Also wir sind jetzt auch nicht alle furchtbar einsam. Ja aber es ist irgendwie ganz schön auch dass man morgens schon mal gucken kann was so jemand geschrieben. Also Dinge die ich auch sonst nicht so mache.
Ich bin wirklich niemand der da aktiv ist und ständig Nachrichten verfasst hab dafür keine Zeit.
Aber jetzt genieße ich das schon auch gerade abends noch beim Gläschen Wein mal rein zu schauen und auch nochmal was dann zum Besten zu geben was man am Tage erlebt hat.
Da würde ich sagen ist auf jeden Fall diese Komponente doch gegeben dass man dort gerade miteinander allein aber nicht einsam ist.
Ja aber das macht er jetzt wieder seit acht Wochen. Ich will mal wissen was nach acht Jahren ist.
Das.
Ob das dann immer noch von dir so beschrieben wird als.
Dann wollen wir das natürlich nicht mehr machen. Wir haben ja jetzt schon konkrete Pläne wenn dann wieder dann müssen wir uns da und dort treffen und dann machen wir unbedingt dann mal das was wir immer tun.
Ja aber,
genau das wird ausgeblendet. Diese Quarantäne die wir jetzt gerade erleben die Einsamkeit sehr unsichtbar macht also sehr viele Menschen leben ja schon in dieser vielleicht nicht selbst gewählten aber man hat jedenfalls wenig Antrieb sich daraus zu befreien.
Zurück in den Weg zur Empathie zu suchen und diese Quarantäne die sehr unsichtbar ist ist jetzt Massenphänomen.
Sie betrifft uns jetzt irgendwie auch verordnet.
Und die Frage die man sich immer stellen muss es klingt albern. Aber die Frage die Mitchell muss kann man eine Woche machen ein Monat ein Jahr 100 Jahre und die Probe aufs Exempel ist kann man es bis zum Lebensende machen.
Ich kann ein Beispiel anführen Marlene Dietrich zog sich 1975 von der Bühne zurück lebte dann in ihrer Pariser Wohnung die letzten zehn Jahre verbrachte sie sogar im Bett.
15 Jahre im Exil hat niemanden mehr zu sich gelassen.
Ich glaube bis auf ein zwei Angestellte die dann dort mal gewischt haben oder so und sonst hat sie telefoniert und damals war telefonieren noch teuer.
Sie hat dann pro Monat auf 100 000 Franc zahlen müssen.
Sie war sicherlich aber eine Ausnahme Persönlichkeit grundsätzlich schon,
die so ungewöhnlich gelebt hat wie niemand von uns es sich vielleicht auch nur vorstellen kann von ungeheurer Disziplin war sie und sie hat in,
einem Dokumentarfilm da durfte Maximilian Schell sie besuchen.
Parton durfte er dann auch ein Interview mit ihr führen er durfte sie aber nicht mehr filmen.
Sie hatte damals diesen Satz gesagt Ich bin zu Tode fotografiert worden.
Und da sagt sie dann auch ich kenne keine Einsamkeit. Ich Lesebücher wer Bücher liest der ist nie einsam.
Das hat sie auch tatsächlich gemacht Sie hat telefoniert und Bücher gelesen.
Aber es muss schon furchtbar gewesen sein wenn man sich 15 Jahre zurückzieht und ich glaube dass kaum einer das aushalten würde und es ist eigentlich fast ein medizinisches Wunder,
dass ihr Körper offenbar so robust war dass er das so lange mitgemacht hat.
Das ist sozialer Suizid. Das Phänomen kennen wir aus Japan Akiko Māori.
Wenn sich Menschen zurückziehen und nicht einmal ihre Familie sich noch zeigen weil sie keine Belastung sein wollen in ihrem Fall ist es ja ich möchte Erinnerungen bleiben aber das würde mir nur ein tatsächlicher Selbstmord erlauben nicht mehr gefilmt zu werden also schließt sie sich sozial zurück.
Das ist halt so wie du es schon beschreibst erkennt man schon das ist so einzigartig als historisches Datum dass sie das so gemacht hat dass wir daran ablesen was eigentlich der Regelfall wäre.
Genau. Ganz genau.
Es fällt völlig aus dem Rahmen.
Bevor wir jetzt übers Sterben reden. Ich rede nochmal über Stress Stress chronischer Stress.
Wenn man Einsamkeit messen wollte dann wäre das chronischer Stress weil der schlägt sich so physisch nieder dass man es einfach ausrechnen nachmessen kann was da passiert.
Und dieser Stress wird befördert durch ein dauerhaftes Gefühl sein eigenes Leben nicht unter Kontrolle zu haben.
Das haben Experimente mit Tieren gezeigt. Ja man kann Tieren und,
Menschen ja aber bei Tieren hat man es gezeigt Schmerzen aussetzen,
und wenn sie die Schmerzen nicht selber unter Kontrolle haben sondern wenn sie darauf angewiesen sind dass jemand anders bei Ertönen eines Alarmsignal schnell einen Knopf drückt und sie wissen aber nicht schafft es dieses andere Tier dann erleben Sie den Stress viel höher als wenn sie.
Mal wieder daran gescheitert sind nicht rechtzeitig zu drücken weil da wissen Sie ja ich bin selber schuld.
Da habe ich ein bisschen wacher und dann schaffe ich es auch den Knopf zu drücken.
Dieser Kontrollverlust Heftigkeit die löst die Macht aus diesem Stress in chronischen Stress der als überforderung gefühlt wird.
Und da hat er die Erkenntnis dass es eben nicht nur um die Umstände geht in denen man lebt sondern auch über das Ausmaß der Kontrolle über diese Umstände.
Das ist vor allem da kommt da ganz viel auf den Chef zu sprechen also Organisationen soziologisch und psychologisch ist das natürlich sehr weitreichend da kann man viel draus ziehen.
Und dieser Corona lockte und den wir jetzt haben ist im Grunde auch so eine Situation wo die Umstände radikal sind.
Gesprochen Es kommt jetzt sehr viel Bewusstsein muss kommt muss jetzt wieder rein.
Gleichzeitig haben wir nicht so richtig die Kontrolle die Politiker kommen immer mit anderen Maßstäben.
Zuerst ist die Verdopplung die sagt wann es zu Ende ist. Dann ist es plötzlich diese Quote und dann ist es plötzlich die absolute Häufigkeit an Fällen die das Gesundheitsamt verarbeiten kann und das hat alles nichts mit uns zu tun.
Wir sitzen zu Hause und leiden unter diesen Gegebenheiten unter diesen Umständen und wissen nicht wann drückt hier irgendwer mal irgendwo ein Knopf um es für uns leichter zu machen.
Das ist dieser chronische Stress gekoppelt mit Einsamkeit Gefühl durch die politischen Forderungen die im Raum stehen dies strapazieren es gerade aufs maximale und,
das ist natürlich besonders interessant wenn er dann sagt ein Ausweg ist ehrenamtliches Engagement,
Menschen zu treffen die auch mal ein bisschen rotieren sind nicht immer die gleichen Es ist nicht die Familie denen man nicht ausgeliefert.
Aber es ist Sozialität und es ist zeitlich begrenzt.
Ist diese Form von.
Form von Sozialität die sich da ganz deutlich epi genetisch niederschlägt also die eigenen Gene die man hat werden anders ausgelesen und verarbeitet sie schlagen sich anders nieder,
als wenn wir wenn wir diese Form von Sozialität erleben als wenn wir sie nicht erleben.
Die Frage ist wie Wie lange kann der Körper einen Krebs aufhalten.
Wie lange kann das Herz Kreislaufsystem aufrechterhalten werden bevor es dann so abbaut. Ja man kann den Tod den Tod hinauszögern.
Damit ist vor allem gemeint alle zivilisatorischen Krankheiten vor allem die uns so ab 60 das Leben schwer machen.
Übergewicht und Herz-Kreislauf. Er hat die falschen Sachen gegessen wie Harari sagt. Tödlicher als das Schießpulver ist heute der Zucker.
All diese Sachen kann man hinauszögern umso länger man und umso intensiver man diese spezielle Form von Sozialität erlebt.
Die Spontanität zulässt die ein bisschen von Pflichten freihält sondern die wirklich reine situative erleben ist.
Und das fand ich dann hochinteressant weil er dann dem gegenüberstellt die Pflege von Angehörigen während des ehrenamtliche Engagement und der Weg zur Empathie ist.
Ist die Pflege von Angehörigen das wirklich schicksalhafte Ausgeliefertsein von Menschen die die Hilfe brauchen die nicht einmal mehr mitteilen können dass Du bist der sie retten muss sondern du weißt dass durch diese,
familiäre Verbindung und du siehst gleichzeitig wie dieser Mensch immer weiter abbaut dich immer weniger erkennt und dann wenn es um Demenz geht vielleicht auch gewalttätig dir gegenüber wird sodass du dann auch mit Gewalt reagiert.
Die Pflege von Angehörigen ist der sichere Weg in die Einsamkeit.
Es hat also als knallhartes Urteil am Ende zu reingeschrieben und es gibt uns Deutschen natürlich wirklich zu denken.
Dabei macht er dann auch diese Kernfamilie sehr stark.
Es ist ja auch ein fast konservatives Weltbild das er hier noch einmal ausbreitet auch das er zum Beispiel empfiehlt man soll als junger Mensch zu den Pfadfindern gehen.
Da zucke ich natürlich sofort zusammen weil ich denke nichts wäre für mich schlimmer gewesen als in einer solchen Gemeinschaft wie der der Pfadfinder zu sein oder so.
Das weißt du ja nicht.
Das glaube ich schon. Ich habe Gemeinschaften immer gescheut. Das ist glaube ich ich.
Ich sehe das und würde überlege und das ist dann aber auch ein eigenartiger Blick darauf.
Dann sagen Ja ist das jetzt ein Buch geschrieben für den Otto-Normalverbraucher und muss ich einfach sagen Ich bin so nicht was ich z.B.
Verwunderlich finde ist dass er sagt er Einsamkeit hat auch eine positive Kraft und es ist aber gut wenn man sie beispielsweise im Wald auslebt also den Waldspaziergang also das Analoge das liebt er schon sehr und die Natur.
Ich muss sagen ich gehe ja jetzt gerade doch am Rhein des Häufigeren des öfteren spazieren und muss sagen Ich hasse es wie die Pest.
Ich hasse es in der Natur rum zu gehen. Mich langweilt die Natur wenn sie nicht ein Gemälde ist oder so. Dann interessiert mich Natur eigentlich nicht.
Ich gehe gerne durch Shopping-Malls und Innenstädte wenn ich gehe weil ich dann irgendetwas kaufe und sonst gehe ich halt nicht durch die Gegend. Und ich mag keine Naturerfahrung.
Und ich glaube dass es einfach. Und das setzt sich aber auch nicht absolut und ich finde dass er dann doch an einigen Stellen sehr eigenartig absolut sitzt sagt er.
Und das sind dann die guten Einsamkeiten die man dann mal hat.
Zumal ich ja auch eine Tätigkeit ausübe die meiste Zeit des Tages die so unglaublich auf Einsamkeit angewiesen ist nämlich das Lesen,
das Lesen ist ja sogar so dass man jede Art der Störung nicht gebrauchen kann.
Da kann man auch nicht sagen Ich setze mich mit einem Buch irgendwo hin und nebenher spielender Kinder oder machen sonst irgendwas das vielleicht mit einem Groschenroman machen.
Aber das wird jetzt zum Beispiel mit einem Buch von Luhmann schon eher schwierig.
Das heißt die meiste Zeit ist doch bei der Lektüre ist doch etwas was man sagen muss Das kann man nur mit sich allein machen und man kann jetzt auch mal.
Den anderen was vorlesen aber in der Regel liest man allein.
Und da würde man doch auch nicht sagen dass das schädlich ist.
Man dann sind wir wieder so im 18. Jahrhundert da hat man dann auch davon gesprochen.
Ja die Frauen die haben jetzt so eine Lese Sucht entwickelt um Gottes willen was wird das mit ihrem Psyche machen.
Da frage ich mich dann ob das nicht auch übertragen ist.
Ob sich das übertragen lässt auf diese Diskussionen die Leute sind so viel spielen Computer und so etwas wird das aus ihren Seelen machen.
Diese Kritik würde ich sagen hat er gleich am Anfang eingefangen als er nämlich die Einsamkeit vom Alleinsein so scharf unterschied.
Denn es macht einen großen Unterschied wie eben auch schon gesagt ob du die Kontrolle über die Umstände hast oder nicht.
Wenn du ein Leben in Einsamkeit führst weil die Nachbarn in deinem Haus überhaupt nicht zu deiner Peergroup gehören sondern alle 30 Jahre älter sind,
oder wenn du einsam bist weil du umgezogen bist aber so an Arbeitslast erstickt dass du es nicht schaffst,
selbst am Wochenende noch einmal unter Leute zu kommen und spontane Zusammenhänge,
dann fällt dir auch das sonst immer so geliebte lesen Mittwoch abends vorm Schlafengehen nochmal schwerer,
schwerer als wenn du gerade sozusagen vom Sport nach Hause Kommens da von zwei Stunden müssen nicht deine Freunde sein aber der Sportverein wo du so unter Leuten dann auch wirklich mobil bist körperlich.
Dann liest du natürlich nochmal anders mit einem anderen Gemütszustand und was ich mit diesem Wald,
Ich kann diese Sache erst einmal komplett nachvollziehen nicht nur weil ich jetzt so wie du eine Romantik aufbauen würde und sagen würde mir tut der Wald unendlich gut.
Und ich verstehe immer noch nicht warum selbst jetzt noch daran geglaubt wird dass die Innenstädte Konsum über alles stellen sollten.
Das finde ich sollte man schon seit zehn Jahren anders drüber nachdenken jetzt ist man bereit darüber nachzudenken.
Ein wichtiges Argument Kinder die man fragt Wollen wir wandern gehen.
Nee ich will lieber was gucken. Da setzt man sich zwei Stunden vor den Fernseher oder drei oder man nimmt die Kinder mit in Wald obwohl sie das nicht wollten.
Am Abend das Abendessen ist tatsächlich das kann ich jetzt gefühlte Empirie von mir aber ich habe noch kein Gegenentwurf gehört.
Das Abendessen läuft sehr viel geselliger entspannter und so weiter ab wenn du nicht drei Stunden vorher Fernsehen geguckt hast sondern wenn alle gemeinsam im Wald waren,
und ich fand dieses Argument mit dem Wald und dass ich zum Beispiel hier beim Petersburg oder lese ich gerade ein Buch übers schlafen.
Der argumentiert auch viel übers Licht. Man denkt so Buba schlafen geht die ganze Zeit ums Licht.
Wie viel Licht trifft eigentlich aufs Auge den ganzen Tag. Im Wald kriegt man nur mal viel indirektes Licht es ist hell aber es blendet selten und es ist dieses Grün was auch einfach einprogrammiert ist in unsere DNA.
Und ich habe dieses Kapitel vor allem unter diesem Karoo Kona Experiment das wir jetzt alle machen noch einmal mit besonderem Interesse gelesen am Ende weil er ebenso diesen Punkt macht.
Nichts sagt er ganz explizit Nichts ist so gesund wie mit anderen Menschen gemeinsam im Wald zu sein.
Und was wir jetzt gerade erleben ist dass die Menschen eigentlich Quanten eine Verordnung bekommen.
Sie dürfen aber noch außer Haus anders als in Frankreich und England. Und sie können sich für fast nichts anderes entscheiden weil alles andere zu haben man kann selbst wenn man es Geld hätte kann man die Ressource jetzt nicht einbringen sondern die Menschen entscheiden sich für Geselligkeit im Grün.
Sie sitzen in Parks Sie gehen in den Wald die Wälder in Frankfurt sind unglaublich voll.
In Berlin die Fotos Menschen im Park. Sehr viele sind jetzt empört wenn sie so viele Menschen im Park sehen aber ich denke mir Das ist das Gesündeste was die Menschen jetzt machen können.
Gemeinsam in kleinen Gruppen zu zweit zu dritt zu viert im Park aber um einen herum ist so viel Sozialität und es ist so ansteckend in Verbund mit der hellen Sonne im hellen Licht.
Es gibt da richtig Rezeptoren im Auge die nicht nur Farbe und Kontraste sondern auch Helligkeit messen und das Weitergeben an €200 Botenstoffe im Körper die einfach für Gesundheit zuständig sind also die gemeinsame Geselligkeit im Grünen.
Damit meine ich wirklich im Grünen nicht das gemeinsame bummeln durch die Stadt. Mit der überlegung Wer hat hier am meisten Geld und wer gibt hier gerade an vor dem anderen und kauft sich nochmal irgendwas,
sondern das gemeinsame alternativlose rumhängen im Grünen unter freiem Himmel im Grünen,
ist die beste Antwort die wir jetzt kollektiv auf die verordnete Quarantäne geben können und Spitzer bekräftigt es nochmal und es bestätigt mein Gefühl und deswegen finde ich das auch absolut gut dass es da so.
Gut für Coruña Zeiten würde ich meine Kritik ein bisschen zurücknehmen und sage Ja es ist sicherlich sehr sinnvoll dass das jetzt gerade passiert.
Und ich bin ja auch froh auch wenn ich jetzt gesagt habe dass ich das hasse ich hasse es dass es momentan nicht ist so wie ich mir sonst vorstelle.
Aber ich finde das vollkommen richtig dass es jetzt gerade so ist.
Aber ich finde es auch sehr schön dass ich jetzt gerade mit Menschen spazieren gehe und dass wir so gemeinsam unsere Zeit verbringen.
Es ist ja auch doch bemerkenswert dass das intuitiv auch dann geschah dass man gleich sich einig war man geht mit zusammen spazieren am Rhein,
und sagt nicht gleich Na ja wir setzen uns einfach auf einen Garten und warten ab oder wir telefonieren nur miteinander.
All das wäre ja möglich oder wir könnten auch in den Autos und gegenüberstehende oder was auch immer.
Nein wir gehen schon spazieren und es ist vielleicht da hast du recht auch ein ganz schöner Blick wenn man da sieht da sind immer so zwei Paare da und dort und gehen da spazieren und da sonnt sich mal jemand.
Das ist absolut in Ordnung. Was aber bei mir sicherlich so sein wird ist sobald irgendwann wieder die sogenannte Normalität da ist dass dann der Rhein mich wieder sehr lange nicht sehen wird und dann wieder für sich fließt.
Aber ja es ist aber auch etwas was man dann sehen kann dass auch viele ältere Leute sehr alleine sind und alleine dort spazieren,
bei denen man denkt Gut da ist vielleicht auch die gute Freundin im Altersheim die kann nicht besucht werden oder man hat sich in einem der berühmten Omer Cafés getroffen,
sonst immer donnerstags oder immer dienstags in der Woche. Auch das geht dann nicht.
Das siehst du dann auch und du siehst auch da glaube ich vielen Menschen an wie sehr sie gerade dann auch psychisch darunter leiden und vielleicht auch körperlich darunter leiden dass sie jetzt gerade so alleine unterwegs sein müssen.
Deswegen reden wir jetzt am Ende noch einmal übers Sterben dass die alten Leute angesprochen und,
dieser Podcast hier ein bisschen Safe Space für die eine oder andere Fragestellung die ich mir im aufwachten Podcast zum nicht trauen würde weil ich da weiß ich dass kriege ich nie eingefallen ist was diese Frage jetzt auslösen würde.
Oh Gott mach es jetzt so einen Auftakt Ich habe schon Angst dass.
Die Frage ist ganz einfach. Also dieses Virus dieses Virus das uns gerade heimgeholt heimholen zu Gott.
Ich darauf reagieren.
Das ist sehr brutal. Also die Panik die entsteht wenn man Lauterbach so hören das alles.
Das ist ja alles nicht falsch nur dieses Virus ist auch unglaublich diskriminierend.
Es sind jetzt beispielsweise die europäischen Zahlen Es ist die europäische Gesamtlage aufgeschlüsselt von Fakten in der Tagesschau.
Bei den EU 65 alle Menschen unter 65 Jahren europaweit sind die Hotspots Frankreich Spanien und sogar alle mittleren liegt.
Die liegt die Sterblichkeit für 65 30 Prozent unter,
dem Grippe Niveau also Grippe Jahr 2018 hatten wir so eine Grippe oder Impfstoff falsch ausgewählt wurde hat Rosner erklärt Es passiert immer mal dass man es nicht genau trifft und dann sterben so ein paar mehr Leute,
so und Corona ist für die unter 65-Jährigen derzeit noch weniger gefährlich.
Was also was konkrete Sterblichkeit jetzt echte Zahlen angeht.
Als die Grippe 2018 gleichzeitig ist aber Crooner schon ein bisschen weiter fortgeschritten als die Grippe denn es ist eine Epidemie. Niemand ist.
Es gibt weder soziale Immunität weil alle im Umfeld das schon haben oder man hat es vielleicht selbst schon sondern jeder der erreicht wird ist sozusagen von der Krankheit betroffen für die 65 liegt die Sterblichkeit aber um Faktor 10 und höher.
Wir haben ein tausend prozentigen Anstieg. Diese ganzen Kurven die man jetzt immer sieht über Sterblichkeit rot markiert für 2020.
Das betrifft 65 in Hammer harter Weise Es ist wirklich unglaublich dieses Virus ist was Generationen angeht absolut brutal. Richtig unfair also.
Das kann man so hat man noch bei keiner anderen Krankheit so gesehen und es ist wirklich atemberaubend.
Wir wissen aber auch die Epidemie ist erst mit 0,2 Prozent in Deutschland durch in den anderen Ländern schon ein bisschen mehr.
Aber trotzdem Das ist schon eine Stichprobe bei der man sagen kann Okay das zählt jetzt und man kann es ja nochmal ein bisschen strapazieren.
Die 65 haben in Deutschland ein Sterben Anteil von fünf Prozent also alle von denen die jetzt gestorben sind 106 000 Leute,
sind 40 Prozent 65 und von diesen 5 prozent 65 sind wiederum 84 Prozent Männer.
Das heißt Frauen sagen wir mal so unter 38 sind unerreichbar für dieses Virus.
Der Zufall ist so groß so gewaltig dass man tatsächlich mit vierzig oder fünfzig weiblich an diesem Virus stirbt.
Dass da sehr viele Fragen entstehen.
Wie gehen wir jetzt wirklich mit den Jungen um. Können wir jetzt noch 63 Jahre so Social dispensieren machen unter jungen Frauen obwohl die eigentlich da ist selbst die Grippe Vergleich falsch einfach weil das ist einfach für die wirklich nicht gefährlich.
Denn dieser New York Times Artikel den ich vorhin angesprochen habe da sind vier von fünf Krankenpfleger reden sind Frauen die da abgebildet werden alle zwischen 25 und 35 Jahre alt.
Die erleben jetzt richtig Trauma weil sie dieses Virus vor Augen sehen was das macht mit den alten Leuten um die sich kümmern während sie selbst völlig raus sind aus diesem Geschehen.
Von wegen hier. Wir hatten ja auch entsprechende Ausschnitte im März.
Das Virus ist der große Gleichmacher. Das stimmte schon nicht in Bezug auf die Einkommensungleichheit und all diese Dinge und auch die das Nord-Süd-Gefälle das es gibt aber es stimmt auch hier.
Genau. Absolut falsch.
Also jetzt einfach mal auf die Generationen bezogen auf die Geschlechter bezogen muss man hinzufügen stimmt es einfach nicht es ist kein Gleichmacher.
Ja wenn wenn eine Frau mit 45 Jahren,
ihre Mutter besuchen möchte die sagen wir mal 8 ist oder so 80 also 30 35 Jahre älter,
dann betrifft die absolut absolute Sterberisiko für die Mutter wenn das Virus sie erreicht 1 zu 6 und selbst in den Fällen wo sie sie überlebt ist das einfach Tortour,
für die Tochter ist es kein Problem sein.
Es wird statistisch überhaupt nicht auffallen dass das Virus einmal durch ist 43 Prozent vierzig komma sechs Prozent aller Infektionen bleiben Symptome freier Drosten zuletzt die Hochrechnung gemacht wenn man eine richtig junge Kohorte hat,
wie so ein Flugzeugträger der überwiegend männlich aber trotzdem bleiben 60 70 prozent Symptome.
Also dieses Virus ist extrem unfair. Was Alter angeht Es ist also eine wirkliche Frage Wie gehen wir jetzt mit Sterben um.
Und zwar nicht im Sinne von Wer wird hier geopfert für wen oder so sondern wie wird eigentlich gestorben und vor allem deswegen wieder Spitzer.
Wenn man die Leute an den Umständen beteiligt ihnen Kontrolle zurückgibt Wie entscheiden Sie sich dann eigentlich zwischen. Und das ist jetzt die Frage.
Lieber einsam noch ein Jahr zwei Jahre oder fünf Jahre leben also die Lebenserwartung Grundsätzlich ist 80 80 Jahre aber für 80-Jährige ist natürlich nicht null sondern da kommen schon noch drei vier fünf Jahre drauf.
Lieber einsam noch länger leben.
Oder unter Freunden und Familie sterben.
Wenn es dann soweit ist noch ist es nicht überall aber man weiß wenn.
Wenn sich jetzt die ärzte den ärzten in Hamburg Folge geleistet wird dann weiß man die Kindergärten gehen demnächst auf und dann findet eine Seuche statt bei denen erst mal kontrolliert versucht wird.
Diejenigen die sie nicht betrifft junge Kinder zu durchleuchten.
Aber sobald sie ihre Großeltern sehen und die zurück ins Pflegeheim kommen oder so hätte da so ein Ausbruch der einfach 60 70 Leute betrifft so stellt sich die Frage Wie wird eigentlich gestorben wie geht man jetzt nicht kurzfristig.
Aber wie geht man langfristig die nächsten zwei drei Jahre mit dieser Frage um.
Und da fand ich wirklich Augen öffnen und auch so ein bisschen rührend wie Thea Dorn über ihren eigenen Vater gesprochen hat bei Markus Lanz.
Es geht nicht mal zwei Minuten aber da steckt im Grunde ganz schön viel drin und vielleicht gibt's auch eine kulturelle Begleitung.
Vielleicht wird einfach demnächst auch anders geschrieben. Selbst wenn man jetzt schon mal recherchiert zum Thema Sterben was gibt's eigentlich für Bücher.
Es gibt jetzt eins das heißt sterben lernen Erscheinungsjahr 2020 Ja vorher war sterben und Palliativmedizin in Deutschland gar nicht so richtig noch nicht angekommen man hat es total verdrängt aber hier kann man ja mal Thea Dorn konstruieren.
Ich gehöre auch zu diesen erstmal eher strukturell trostlosen Menschen die sich nicht daran aufrichten können dass sie denken Ach kommen lasst das ganze Zeug hier mal fahren im Diesseits das bessere Jenseits wartet. Ich glaub ich nicht.
Deshalb Ich habe sehr intensiv die letzten Wochen darüber nachgedacht worin für mich der Tod so furchtbar die Vorstellung für mich auch so beängstigend so etwas ähnliches wie etwas Tröstliches kriegen kann.
Ich glaube es sind zwei Punkte die ganz ganz wichtig sind das eine ist die Aussicht nicht einsam sterben zu müssen,
die Aussicht zu haben zu wissen die Menschen die mir am liebsten sind oder der Mensch den mir am allerliebsten ist darf und kann bei mir sein wird bei mir sein und die andere Aussicht ist die zu sagen Ich muss nicht elend sterben.
Die Erfahrung habe ich auch gemacht wenn ich mit alten sehr alten Menschen rede.
Mein Vater ist eben meine Mutter ist gestorben sagte ich ihr Vater und die zweite Hälfte 80..
Gott sei Dank bei bester Gesundheit aber wir fangen in diesen Tagen natürlich an darüber zu reden und viele meiner Freunde sind über 70 oder einige sogar über 80.
Natürlich rede ich mit denen und ich höre immer wieder den Satz dass sie sagen Nein ich möchte jetzt im Augenblick nicht sterben und zwar gar nicht weil sie sagen Ich muss um jeden Preis noch die 90 schaffen oder so.
Was mir sehr suspekt ist dieser merkwürdige Ehrgeiz dass man ja manchmal in dieser Welt neuerdings den Eindruck hat jeder der unter 80 stirbt ist irgendwie ein Versager weil er irgendwie diese 80 nicht geschafft hat was ich gesehen habe falsche Sicht halte.
Ich möchte jetzt nicht sterben weil ich mir jetzt nicht sicher bin in diesen beiden Punkten werden meine Liebsten bei mir sein können.
Ich habe gerade von einem Journalistenkollegen einen Artikel gelesen von Jan Fleischhauer der beschreibt wie er nicht bei seinem Vater sein konnte der jetzt starb was für mich wirklich das Grauen schlechthin ist,
und dass Leute auch Elend zu Hause sterben weil sie keinen Zugang zu palliativ medizinischen Möglichkeiten haben.
Es eins zu eins das Bitzer schreibt.
Sie hat einen tollen Essay übrigens auch dazu geschrieben in der Zeit.
Ja sehr gut den werde ich nochmal lesen weil das ist für die Rentner Republik jetzt eine wahnsinnig wichtige Diskussion.
Sie hat als hätte sie selber jetzt nochmal.
Diese Menschen wollen am Ende ihres Lebens zwei Sachen nicht Schmerz und Einsamkeit.
Genau die Sachen die bei Spitzer so wichtig waren.
Man hat Angst jetzt zu sterben weil man dann weiß die gesetzlichen Vorgaben sagen Ich bin dann einsam.
Im Moment des Todes und ich werde Schmerzen erleiden weil die maximale Medizin so durchgepaukt wird in Deutschland weniger.
Ich war sehr überrascht als er bekannt gab dass ein Drittel aller Todesfälle tatsächlich nicht im Krankenhaus stattfinden sondern vielleicht sogar schon palliativ betreut aber zumindest außerhalb des Krankenhauses in den Pflegeheimen.
Es kann alle Gründe dafür geben Entweder man hat es nicht beobachtet und dann ist es zu schnell passiert das war natürlich katastrophal oder. Es kann natürlich auch.
Diese Menschen wussten Bescheid und haben auch schon Abschied genommen und haben eine Kontaktliste.
Und zwar nicht im Sinne von Wen habe ich getroffen sondern bin will ich jetzt noch schnell treffen jetzt wo ich covert habe.
Und dann ermöglicht man das man hat jetzt in New York selbst in New York Der absolute Mega Hotspot hat man jetzt entschieden Frauen die ein Kind bekommen dürfen jetzt wieder einen.
Und es ist dann meistens der Vater Angehörigen wieder mit in den Kreißsaal bringen weil das absolut nicht verhältnismäßig war.
Die Frauen in diesem Moment so alleine zu lassen und man hat in Deutschland jetzt wieder auch auf Intensivstationen Besuchsrecht zurückgebracht.
Ja das ist für alle super anstrengend Die Leute müssen eingekleidet eingewiesen werden für eine Stunde Kontakt ist es eine mega Prozedur drei Stunden alles anziehen drei Stunden alles wieder ausziehen.
Aber auch da lässt man das Besuchsrecht wieder zu. Und mit fragt man sich ja ist die Thea Dorn da so ein bisschen romantisch unterwegs ist das ein Einzelfall geht's allen Leuten so.
Und da gibt's vom Deutschlandfunk sehr interessante Podcast Reihe das sind sehr kurze Podcast aber nur eine Viertelstunde,
zum Thema Alltag einer Pandemie und die rufen dann so an bei Pflegediensten Gesundheitsämtern und so weiter und da gibt es eine Frau die sie immer mal wieder anrufen Waltraut kann.
Das ist die Pionieren in Deutschland die gesagt hat Ja ich verstehe dass das mit diesem Corona lock down so ist aber ich werde jetzt Tages Gruppen wieder einführen denn es ist zu viel Gewalt mit dementen Leuten zu Hause.
Die pflegenden Angehörigen brauchen zumindest mittwochs mal eine Stunde Entspannung im Sinne von jemand anders kümmert sich 24 Rundumbetreuung sowie Betreuung im Kindergarten ist genauso.
Dieses Modell hat jetzt auch für die Altenpflege gemacht und sie wird war dieses Gespräch verwickelt.
Wie es den alten Leuten eigentlich gerade mit der Aussicht wenn die Krankheit da ist führt sie in 15 20 30 prozent zum sicheren Tod und der Rest ist ein überleben als schwerbehindert.
Wenn man einmal irgendwie einen probiert wurde ist natürlich alles brutal und sie nennt hier mal eine sehr sehr interessante Zahl.
Das was wir jetzt an sozialer Distanz aufgebaut haben wirkt sich dieses.
Ich gehe vom Bürgersteig runter wenn mir jemand entgegenkommt oder Wir sind vorsichtig im Umgang miteinander wir wenden uns ab wenn wir sprechen.
Ich glaube diese Dinge die hinterlassen bei uns haben und die werden auch künftig wirken.
Die alten Leute ich sag mal zu 90 Prozent der Menschen es gibt auch die anderen aber 90 Prozent unserer Klienten sagen meine Schwester ich habe so ein schönes Leben gehabt und wenn ich denn daran sterben soll dann ist das so.
Das war jetzt auch als der erste Hausbesuch mit Schürze gemacht wurde dass eine alte Frau mit Leuze sagte der Swayze hat mir jetzt schon Kuroda am Bauch oder oder weshalb machen Sie das.
Irgendwie müssen wir uns doch auch mal verabschieden und da merke ich Die sind ja recht gelassen und ich denke auch man sollte ihnen nicht ihr Sparziel hier verwehren.
Das finde ich das sollten wir nicht tun. Ich glaube nicht dass wir sie schützen indem wir sie einsperren sondern da glaub ich eher daneben bei ihnen Lebensqualität.
Ja das ist aus der Erfahrung ganz richtig und was will man da auch dagegen sagen.
Wo Leute dann nur Probleme mitbekommen bei solchen Aussagen ist wenn sie in Verbindung auftreten mit neoliberalen Wirtschaftskonzept die sagen das Bruttoinlandsprodukt muss nach oben und wir können jetzt nicht auf jeden Rücksicht nehmen.
Ich will den Namen dieses grünen Provinz Bürgermeisters jetzt hier gar nicht in den Mund nehmen.
Das ist ja dann die ganz andere Perspektive die sagt Wir sind der Homo oeconomicus das ist unsere Weltanschauung und wer sich diesem Prinzip nicht unterwirft der muss dann eben sterben aber das hier ist eine ganz andere Denkweise.
Das müssen wir einfach voneinander differenzieren und das passiert glaube ich auch was du ja auch so zaghaft angesprochen hast.
Im medialen Diskurs und auch besonders nochmal Twitter Facebook Diskurs zu wenig dass das eine vom anderen getrennt wird und dass man eben auch sieht wie solche Maßnahmen natürlich,
Einsamkeiten Schmerzen produziert aber auch Tote produziert die eine Sache.
Ich habe diesen Bericht rausgesucht noch aus der Rhein-Zeitung.
Momentan findet ja der interessanteste Journalismus vielleicht im lokalen statt wo man dann mit Menschen spricht die gerade seit acht Wochen in irgendwelchen Kliniken stehen oder so.
Und so ist es dann auch hier. Es sind ja nicht die Kommentarschreiber die noch vor vier Wochen vor Masken warnten dann zwei Wochen später sagen Maske auf und jetzt wieder irgendwas Neues verkünden.
Das hat ja mit Journalismus relativ wenig zu tun und zwar gab es hier einen sehr tragischen Fall Es gab einen Herzpatienten in Neuwied bei Koblenz.
Der sollte eigentlich ins Krankenhaus und sollte der war 81. und sollte da eine Operation bekommen.
Dieser 81-Jährige der hatte aber unglaubliche Angst vor Corona.
Die ärzte. Der Chefarzt hat ihnen versucht zu überreden trotzdem diese doch dringend notwendige Operation zu machen.
Dieser Mann hat sich aber nicht überreden lassen. Dann hat er vier Wochen gewartet.
Dann kam er mit Klappen Thrombose und so weiter dort an.
Und sie beschreiben dann hier ist quasi im Krankenhaus umgefallen und war tot.
Und das ist so erschreckend wenn man das eben liest dass jemand hier sagt Ich habe so Angst vor Coruna Ich mache das nicht.
Und dann passiert das eben. Und dann sagte eben dieser Arzt der hier der Chefarzt da interviewt wurde.
Das war bei uns der erste Fall in dieser Radikalität aber es war kein Einzelfall.
Ich lehne mich nicht zu weit aus dem Fenster wenn ich sage dass am Ende mehr Patienten an Unterlassungen gestorben sein werden als an Corona.
Ob das jetzt stimmt weiß ich jetzt wiederum nicht zu beurteilen.
Aber das ist eben reales Leid das da entsteht.
Um die Zahl nochmal zu nennen Ich habe sie schon mehrfach bei Twitter und beim Aufwachen genannt.
Deutschland hat pro Jahr hunderttausend Herzinfarkte davon verlaufen die Hälfte tödlich.
Ein Herzinfarkt ist nicht irgendwie aber wahrscheinlich bei 0,3 Prozent oder so sondern 50 Prozent der Herzinfarkte sind in diesem Moment.
Ich würde mal sagen in Tagesverlust dann einfach tödlich. Und das heißt 50 000 müssen irgendwie über Notrufe dann doch,
im Krankenhaus ankommen und dafür haben wir die Intensivstation weil da weiß man Der Typ kommt sofort auf die Intensivstation sind vor allem Männer die das betrifft und zwar in diesem Alter wie du eben auch schon beschrieben ist. Die haben dann einfach.
Sie sind im Alter wo sie dann doch mal Angst vorm Krankenhaus macht das natürlich nicht so gut von diesen 50000 sind im ersten Halbjahr.
Das hat sich ja nun auch schon in der zweiten Hälfte des ersten Halbjahres.
Und die Krankenhäuser verzeichnen einen Rückgang um 50 Prozent von Meldungen von Herzinfarkten und Herzinfarkte sind nicht so situativ auftretende sondern das sind langwierig sich ankündigenden Verkalkung und Verengung und Blut Veränderungen und so weiter.
Das ist nicht im Sinne von Ja die Leute leben ja auch gerade alle total entspannt und so Ja und deswegen passiert das nicht.
Das ist wirklich das Ende eines langen chronischen Prozesses.
Einfacher Schlaganfall oder Herzinfarkt finden nur die Hälfte der Zeit den Weg ins Krankenhaus.
Aufs Jahr hochgerechnet reden wir über 25 000 Fälle.
Hinzu kommt dass die leichteren Fälle die im Krankenhaus erfolgreich behandelt werden wenn die auch im Krankenhaus landen dann sind die langfristig auch dann steht da gleich der zweite Schlag aus dem Körper gegen das eigene Leben an die Hausärzte.
Zum Beginn des Aprils bis zu 70 80 prozent Reduktion von Hausarzt Besuche beim Hausarzt festgestellt.
Da geht es um Krebsvorsorge da es um das Anbahnen von Prozessen die man möglichst früh eigentlich mit Interventionen behandeln sollte.
Das ist eine ganz dramatische Situation auf der anderen Seite klar Es sind bisher nur 6 000 Tote anders als in anderen Ländern wo diese Rechnung eben anders ausgeht.
Und da würde ich doch vorschlagen Machen wir als Auto..
Darf ich noch eine Sache denn ich würde ich hatte nämlich diesen Text eigentlich rausgesucht von Thea Dorn und hatte ihn dann doch nicht gebracht jetzt hast du aber Thea Dorn gespielt und jetzt dachte ich.
Lese ich doch noch den Auszug den ich rausgesucht habe gerade weil das so wunderbar passt und es war in gewisser Weise auch den Kreis schließt zu dem was wir anfangs hatten mit dem Risiko mit dem infektiösen Körper und ob wir,
alles nur auf Distanz weiter halten können.
Zum Beispiel wie Ray Kurzweil meinte den Sex und Thea Dorn schreibt in der Zeit.
Ich weiß nicht was mich mehr erschüttert die Berichte von der schieren Zahl physisch qualvoller Todes Kämpfe die sich seit Wochen auf der ganzen Welt ereignen.
Die Berichte von Schwerstkranken die in überfüllten Krankenhaus Fluren oder in Zelten vor den Hospitälern stranden oder die Berichte davon wie diese Menschen verenden denen auch die avanciertesten Hightech Medizin nicht zu helfen weiß.
Die Berichte von Sterbenden deren letzte Gefährten einzig Astronautin gestalten. sind von Kopf bis Fuß in Plastik gehüllt.
An dem Tag an dem ich die Schilderung einer italienischen Krankenschwester las,
wie sie in ihrem Krankenhaus versuchten den Sterbenden ein Tablet oder Smartphone in die Hand zu drücken,
damit sich jene wenigstens per Video Anruf von ihrem Liebsten verabschieden könnten erreichte meine Verzweiflung erreichte meine Wut auf das Netz Zeitalter ihren bisherigen Höhepunkt.
Dennoch und dann bringt sie noch einmal einige Einwände wie wichtig diese Schutzmaßnahmen sind.
Dennoch frage ich mich wie wir das menschliche Elend.
Indem wir uns bereits befinden und das uns noch bevorsteht verkraften wollen wenn wir weiterhin allesamt in erster Linie auf Zahlen starren.
Wenn wir unser Heil vor allem in einer überstürzten Flucht ins digitale nach vorne suchen wenn wir glauben unsere Menschlichkeit,
die nicht zu trennen ist von unserer unmittelbaren Leiblichkeit ließe sich mittels Smartphones bewahren.
Genauso diese Diskussion nimmt hoffentlich ein bisschen Fahrt auf.
Es gibt noch sehr viel Angst so eine Diskussion zu führen weil ich sage jetzt Boris Palmer und andere Idioten einfach,
die Situation ausnutzen für ihr neoliberales ist eigentlich so ein Kampfbegriff verwendet aber in dem Fall ist es halt wirklich als Sammelbegriff für als Sammelbegriff für die ganze Idiotie verwendet.
Man kann auch sagen marktradikale.
Da wird das halt in Anschlag gebracht.
Davon sollte man sich nicht erschüttern lassen und im Kontrast dazu. Und wir sparen jetzt immer ein paar Wirtschaftsthemen aus denn ich empfehle euch einfach.
Es gibt immer noch so viele Leute die leiden unter Staatsschulden und so weiter. Entspannt euch es ist genug Geld da für alle eigentlich ja man muss nur aufpassen dass jetzt nicht die Ideologie greift das der Bund der Steuerzahler sich durchsetzt mit,
Neee die Steuern müssen zurückgezahlt werden durch die Staatsschulden also müssen wir jetzt den progressiven mal ein bisschen Einhalt gebieten.
Das ist die einzige Funktion die das ganze Zeug hat einfach Adam ist tot.
Das ist der Typ der gerade. Finde ich so sehr gute Vorschläge gemacht und die Diskussion anführt kann man sich dranhängen.
Wir hören stattdessen acht Minuten lang aus einer Pressekonferenz.
Das ist nicht irgendwer sondern es gibt in Hamburg ein sehr großes Krankenhaus das UKE.
Dort arbeiten 2800 ärzte. Da gibt es Tausende von Betten. Hamburg war einer der ersten Hotspots der nach Bayern mit Coruña zu tun hatte.
Und dort gibt es einen klinischen Direktor der medizinische Chef Ansgar Lohse und er steht zusammen mit dem Vorstandschef der Klinik bei einer Pressekonferenz am 22.
Und bröselt mal die Argumente neu auf zum Thema Herden Immunität über Impfungen durch solche.
Belastung nach unterschiedlichen Alter und auch,
wie viel versprechend und wann ein Impfstoff den man tatsächlich spritzen kann und der dann auch wirkt,
bei einer Krankheit bei der wir wissen wenn die Leute daran sterben dann ist das die zweite Welle der Symptome die gar nicht mehr vom Virus verursacht und hervorgerufen wird sondern von der Antwort des eigenen Körpers.
Und da will man echt nicht rumspielen mit Antworten des Körpers die man noch über Umwege.
Also ich bin kein Impfgegner sondern ich orientiere mich einfach an Ansgar Lohse der diese Zusammenhänge noch einmal beschreibt dass der Körper selbst zum Feind werden kann Bei Erkrankungen dieser Art und das habe ich zusammengeschnitten auf acht Minuten.
Es ist jetzt eine Woche und einen Tag alt vom 22..
Und es ist im Vergleich zu Lauterbach und was die Politik angeht oder Drosten was die Labor Wahrheit angeht ist dieser Blick ins Krankenhaus und was man so an Schlüsse daraus zieht zum Thema Schulschließungen und zum Thema.
Vielleicht schützen wir die Alten besser wenn wir die jungen kontrolliert durch Seuchen und so weiter.
Das sind alles überlegungen die werden jetzt kommen und die werden auch 2022 noch eine Rolle spielen denn diese Hoffnung die jetzt immer so gemacht wird dass es irgendwie einen Impfstoff gibt in anderthalb Jahren oder so.
Das sind Firmen die jetzt die Zulassung haben für Impfstoff Wirkungen am Menschen zu testen die haben noch nie einen Impfstoff hergestellt.
Das ist für all diese Firmen diese kleinen Biotech Startups irgendwas.
Es ist alles Pionierarbeit die greifen nicht auf Erfahrung zurück Weder ökonomischer Natur noch wissenschaftlicher Natur noch praktischer Natur das ist alles.
Diese Impfstoff Hoffnung Das kann man jetzt im April 2020 schon mal sagen die werden wir vielleicht auch im April 2021 noch genauso,
ohne Wunscherfüllung thematisieren. Es ist wirklich dramatisch was das angeht. Verabschieden wir uns an dieser Stelle Wolfgang.
Mit hoffnungsfrohen grüßen. Ja ich habe schon die Hände im Gesicht Ich kann ja jetzt noch weiterreden.
Welche Hoffnungen will er uns noch rauben. Aber damit machen wir dann im Mai weiter aber wir haben dann auch noch andere Themen wir blicken dann auf jeden Fall wieder auf Facebook da wird sich einiges tun.
Das war auch schon ein bisschen angedacht diesmal aber es geht da jetzt so rasant weiter.
Das haben viele nicht geglaubt.
Facebook wird bestimmt mein Thema und vieles weitere und irgendwie wird es dann auch wieder um Coruna gehen.
Zwischendurch lesen wir euch noch im Salon vor. Kommt in den Salon und unterstützt damit auch diesen freien Podcast hier und jetzt sagen wir Schau und die acht Minuten Ansgar Lohse die wir jetzt hören sind gar nicht so hoffnungslos.
Genau.
Sie kommen nicht nur auf den Impfstoff zu sprechen sondern sie haben noch andere Rehse Jensen zum Thema haut rein.
Bleibt gesund.
Drosten hat nach meiner Wahrnehmung sehr klar und deutlich richtig formuliert dass wir wissenschaftliche Meinung haben dass wir harte Daten sammeln und die präsentieren auch den Entscheidungsträgern.
Aber wir machen nicht für die Politik das müssen Sie schon selber machen können.
Die Politik muss das letztendlich entscheiden. Wir meinen aber wir müssen differenzierter in unserer Redaktion sein.
Da ist immer wieder eingeforderte ganz Deutschland muss überall zum gleichen Zeitpunkt genau das Gleiche machen,
passt nicht unbedingt zu Infektionen geschehen,
die typischerweise wellenförmig sind,
die lokal regional sich ausbreiten und durch lokale und regionale Maßnahmen häufig sehr viel effektiver,
bekämpft werden können als durch globale Maßnahmen die eben auch globale Nebenwirkungen haben und die Nebenwirkungen der jetzigen Maßnahmen machen uns allen zunehmend Sorgen.
Wir merken dass Patienten sich nicht trauen die Notaufnahme zu kommen obwohl sie Angina pectoris haben und die möglicherweise einen Infarkt zu Hause haben der übersehen wird und dann auch tödlich sein kann.
Wir machen uns Sorgen dass durch die Angst wegen Coruna und Maßnahmen wegen Coruna eventuell mehr Schaden entsteht als durch das Virus selbst.
Das Virus steht so im Fokus unser aller Aufmerksamkeit dass wenn das erstmal komisch vorkommt es so etwas zu sagen.
Wir werden es letztendlich erst wissen in einigen Monaten Zigi Situation nachdenken müssen wie kommen wir irgendwann aus dieser Pandemie wieder raus Virus.
Wir wissen nicht genau wie schnell verbreitet sich wir aber jetzt sind wir in einer Situation wo wir ein bisschen mehr gelernt haben wo wir mehr differenzieren können Wer hat eigentlich ein hohes Risiko ein niedriges Risiko.
Wie wieviel intensiv Kapazitäten haben wir die Fallzahlen die jedes jeden Tag über den Ticker gehen und aufeinander addiert werden sind nicht wirklich aussagekräftig,
weil wenn ein fünfundzwanzigjährige eine Infektion hat dann braucht die mit allerhöchster Wahrscheinlichkeit kein intensiv bitt.
Wenn aber zunehmend in Altenheimen Ausbrüche entstehen dann brauchen wir zunehmend entweder intensiv Betten oder manchmal auch nur eine palliative Versorgung. Aber eine ganz andere Situation.
Was wir eben intensiv gelernt haben ist dass Kinder und Jugendliche aber auch junge Erwachsene entweder gar nicht erkranken oder nur symptomatisch und sehr im Bild erkranken.
Mit sehr wenigen Ausnahmen. Und selbst wenn sie erkranken eine exzellente Prognose haben wie können wir überhaupt durch ein so relativ ansteckend ist und vor allem so unglaublich inzwischen teilte das Virus.
Wie können wir aus dieser Ausbruchs Situation mittelfristig und langfristig wieder herauskommen.
Bisher gibt es in der öffentlichen Diskussion vor allem ein einziges Paradigma das ist es kommt irgendwann der Impfstoff wenn dieses Problem gelöst,
Wir können entweder die Strategie erhoffen dass wir einen Impfstoff haben der so effektiv ist dass selbst die älteren immun defekten eine gute Immunantwort machen.
Aber wir wissen dass ältere schlechtere Immunantwort machen.
Also entweder muss er extrem effektiv sein oder er muss extrem sicher sein weil wir müssten wenn wir durch einen Impfstoff eine sogenannte Herden Immunität also eine Immunität der ganzen Bevölkerung hervorrufen wollen,
dann müssen wir ja die jungen Menschen impfen die von diesem Virus gar nicht so sehr bedroht sind.
Und wir wissen welche Zurückhaltung viele Eltern und junge Menschen haben wenn sie sich gegen irgendwas impfen sollen und dann sagen auch für mich selber ist das gar nicht so gefährlich.
Wenn wir jetzt einen Impfstoff entwickeln der möglicherweise bei jedem Hundertausenden so unangenehme Nebenwirkungen hat,
dann sind wir nicht sicher ob es uns gelingen wird wirklich diesen Impfstoff weit in der gesamten Bevölkerung anzuwenden.
Es ist schwierig einen wirklich effektiven Schutz vor Infektionen für die Risiko Population zu organisieren.
Ja ich bin der Meinung und viele von uns sind der Meinung,
dass es sinnvoll wäre dass wir,
Infektionen bei denjenigen die kein hohes Risiko haben zulassen um dadurch Immunität in der Bevölkerung zu schaffen ohne dass wir impfen müssen weil das könnten wir jetzt schon machen das ist sozusagen eine natürliche Impfung.
Wir müssen es nur so organisieren dass es vor allem bei denjenigen ankommt diese natürliche Impfung die eben ein wirklich niedriges Risiko haben und dass die nicht sobald sie infiziert sind zu ihren Großeltern gehen.
Einrichtungen tätig es ist vielleicht auch eine Risiko Personen wobei das Risiko wirklich erst im späteren Alter ansteigt.
Und da muss man vielleicht dann auch entsprechende Schutzmaßnahmen ergreifen.
Aber ich würde gerne zitieren weil wir ja auch gerade mit Panorama III Die Diskussion hatten und der Hygieniker Peter Walker interviewt wurde.
Der wurde gestern auch von der Süddeutschen Zeitung interviewt und ich lese mal vor was er gesagt hätte Es ist praktisch identisch von dem was ich gesagt habe.
Schutz der Risiko Person aber sagt er. Problematisch finde ich dass die Kitas nicht geöffnet werden.
Warum. Nach wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen sind Kita und Schulschließungen umso effektiver je größer der Anteil der Kinder an der Pandemie Dynamik ist.
Für die aktuelle Covic 19. Pandemie gibt es dafür keine belastbaren Belege.
Wir haben aber Erkenntnisse zur Pandemie 2009.
Da bezieht er sich auf eine Publikation im Land sind vor einer Woche. Diese zeigen eine sehr geringe Effektivität von Schulschließungen.
Natürlich ist es sinnvoll dass Kinder den Kontakt mit Großeltern weiter vermeiden aber untereinander hätte man deutliche Lockerung erlauben können.
Bei gleichzeitig intensiveren Schutz des Personals in den Kitas kann ich nur unterschreiben.
Die Frage wie viele Leute werden an dieser Infektion sterben hängt auch sehr stark davon ab wer sich infiziert und der Fehler der immer wieder gemacht wird ist das.
Diese ganzen mathematischen Modelle Wenn der Maier Hermann aus Braunschweig als Physiker rechnet oder auch viele anderen rechnen ist bei jeder Infektion gleich eins. Aber das ist nicht der Fall.
Jemand der sich infiziert und lange die Infektion hat hat eine viel höhere Chance andere Leute anzustecken und natürlich auch eine viel höhere Chance zu versterben an der Erkrankung als,
Jugendliche die vielleicht das Virus überhaupt gar nicht vermehren weil es nur für paar Tage vermehren oder in geringer Menge vermehren.
Deswegen ist es schwierig das zu extrapolieren. Ich habe mit Karl Lauterbach auch länger darüber diskutiert weil seine Rechnung mit den 100 000 zusätzlichen Toten dadurch ist aus unserer Sicht eine Fel Rechnung. Wir werden.
Man kann sich darüber streiten ob das klug ist oder nicht wir werden praktisch dieses Experiment in einem Jahr beurteilen können.
Dänemark hat seine Kitas und Schulen geöffnet nachdem sie am Anfang ähnlich gebremst haben wie wir.
Schweden hat sie mehr oder weniger die ganze Zeit offengehalten.
Wir haben die Maßnahmen so wie Sie sie kennen. Und wir werden dann in einem Jahr sehen was der Unterschied ist.
Meine persönliche Meinung ist wir würden weniger Tote sehen und weniger überforderung des Gesundheitssystems wir Immunität in der niedrig Risikogruppe zulassen würden.
Richtig wissen tut es keiner von uns.
Manchmal muss man einen Kommentar machen das mir wichtig ist selbst immer mal wieder hören will.
Kann es sein dass gar keine Show kommt.
Ja es kann auch sein dass es gar kein.
Intro/Outro